A GOOD MORNING- WE ARE
EXPERIENCING SEPT TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. ON THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
EVIDENTLY THE AT&T CALLED IN-
FUNCTION IS NOT WORKING. AND WE
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE TESTIFYING
BY PHONE SO WE'RE GOING TO TRY
TO FIGURE OUT. I THEIR WORK
AROUND BUT WE'RE GONNA MAKE SOME
CALLS OR MAYBE MOVED TO ROME. WE
NEED TO WE DON'T WANT ELIMINATE
PEOPLE CALLING IN TO TESTIFY.
SO- WE WILL. I'LL BE RIGHT BACK
TO YOU LET ME- LET ME SEE WHAT
WHAT OPTIONS WE HAVE THAT COULD.
IN THE MEANTIME WHILE WE GET
THINGS OR TRY TO FIGURE OUT
SOMETHING I'M A CALL THE MEETING
TO ORDER- GOOD MORNING- THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE. IS A CALL TO ORDER-
MEANT SECTOR WE CALL FOR THE
CORE. JONES SAWYER HERE LACKEY.
BONTA BRIAN WEBER SANTIAGO.
SMITH. FORMS PRESENT- YOU KNOW I
AM GOING TO READ THIS- COALBED
STATEMENT EVEN THOUGH OUR
ABILITY TO HEAR- FOR THE OUTSIDE
WORLD IS HAMPERED RIGHT NOW-
BUT- I THINK I'M SUPPOSED TO
READ ANYWAY WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC TO PROVIDE WRITTEN
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE HEARING BY
VISITING TO COMMITTEE WEBSITE.
AT A. P. S. F. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT
CA DOT GOV PLEASE NOTE THAT ANY
WRITTEN TESTIMONY SUBMITTED
COMMITTEES CONSIDERED PUBLIC
COMMENT AND MAYBE READ INTO THE
RECORD OR REPRINTED. ALL ARE
ENCOURAGEDTO WATCH THE HEARING
FROM ITS LIVE STREAM ON THE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE W. W. DOT
ASSEMBLY DOT CA DOT GOV.
BACKSLASH TODAY'S EVENT T. O. D.
A. Y. S. E. V. E. N. TS. THE
HEARING ROOM WILL BE OPEN FOR
ATTENDANCE OF THIS HEARING. ANY
MEMBER. OF THE PUBLIC ATTENDING
A HEARING IS ENCOURAGED TO WEAR
A MASK AT ALL TIMES WHILE IN THE
BUILDING. THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO
PARTICIPATE. IF WE GET OUR ACT
TOGETHER- THE PUBLIC MAY ALSO
PARTICIPATE IN HIS HEARING BY
TELEPHONE WE ENCOURAGE THE
PUBLIC PUBLIC TO MONITOR THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE FOR UPDATES.
SO LET'S BEGIN WITH A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING. LET'S START WITH.
THE NUMBER OF BILLS THEY'RE OFF
CALENDAR THEY HAVE BEEN PULLED
BY THE AUTHORS- ITEM NUMBER
THREE. A. B. 1-925-192-4919 TWO
FOUR NINETEEN TWENTY FOUR GIPSON
CO BY THE AUTHOR. ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB. NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE
NINE EIGHT ZERO ONE PULLED BY
THE AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
ONE EIGHT THREE FIVE LACKEY
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN AB ONE SEVEN TWO
FIVE SMITH POLL BY THE AUTHOR
ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN A. B.
EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX BALLADARES
POLL BY THE OFFICE AUTHOR AND
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B.
EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN BALLOT
ADDRESS A POLL BY THE AUTHOR. IN
ADDITION. WE HAVE A PROPOSED
CONSENT CALENDAR- STARTING WITH
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE- JONES SAWYER
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
NINE MATHIS CRIMES FALSE PURSE
PURSE IMPERSONATION- ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE A. B. EIGHTEEN FORTY TWO
RIGHT THIRTY GUESS FIREARMS
RESTOCKING FEE- ITEM NUMBER
NINETEEN A. J. R. TWENTY EIGHT
CRISTINA GARCIA BERNARD B. HOME
B. JAMES. THE EVER MOTION TO
ACCEPT THE LOOKED. OBJECTOR CALL
THE ROLL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR JONES SAWYER HERE I
MEAN I JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
LACKEY HI BONTA. BONTA HI BRIAN
HI BRIAN I WEBER. SANTIAGO SMITH
SMITH I. CONCERT COVERS DOCTORS
IF YOU COULD BEAR WITH ME WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO FIGURE OUT THIS
TELEPHONE SITUATION OF THE NEXT
FIVE MINUTES- THE OTHER OF THE
WORKAROUND- ESPECIALLY FOR THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE HERE I DON'T
KNOW IF WE CAN HAVE A MEETING
WITHOUT GETTING INPUT FROM THE
PUBLIC SO THAT'S THAT'S A BIG
CONCERN DO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO COMMENT ON
EVERY BILL THAT COMES BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE. AND SO WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO EXCLUDE THE PUBLIC
FROM THE SULIDS THE BILL WERE TO
GIVE US A FEW MINUTES.
AND ALSO WELL I'M I NEED TO
ANNOUNCE THAT WE HAVE TO
SUBSTITUTION EVER SEVEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. OF THURSTON E.
SMITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER A KILO WEBER
TODAY. SEVEN FOUR MEMBERS OF
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE TODAY
BUT- ONE FOR MR QUIRK AND WEBER
THE TO SEATTLE.
ESPECIALLY MEMBERS THAT GOT HERE
EARLY IN THE WITNESSES THEY GOT
HERE ON TIME I'M SORRY ON TIME
WE'RE GOING TO GET TEMPORARY
RECESS WHILE WE TRY TO WORK
THROUGH THIS UNFORTUNATELY WE
CAN'T CHANGE ROOMS. AND NOW
WE'RE TRYING TO GET RULES ON.
JUST TALKING RULES ABOUT
WITNESSES AND THE PUBLIC BEING
ABLE TO CALL IN A COMMENT. I'M
LETTING YOU KNOW ALL OF THIS SO
THAT YOU KNOW- AGAIN WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO EXCLUDE THE PUBLIC
FROM FROM CALLING IN. I PONDERED
GAVEL DIFFERENTIAL DON'T GET
SCARED. FOR RECESS.
PUBLIC SAFETY IS BACK IN SESSION
AGAIN AGAIN WE'VE MOVED FROM
ROOM UP ONE TWENTY SEVEN TWO.
ONE TWENTY SIX TO ONE TWENTY
SEVEN I APOLOGIZE RIGHT ACROSS
THE HALL FROM THE FROM THE OTHER
ROOM- MISTER BRYANT'S NOT HERE.
SO WE WILL BEEN. START WITH MS
DAVIS. AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY. DRUG
TREATMENT STANDARDS. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY TO BE AND I THINK
YOU. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY. I
FIRST WANT TO THANK COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY STAFF
AND STAKEHOLDERS AND AMENDMENTS
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
UNDER CURRENT LAW SECTION ONE
ONE THREE SEVEN THREE OF THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE STATES
THAT WHENEVER ANY PERSON WHO'S
GRANTED PROBATION BY THE TRIAL
COURT AFTER CONVICTION FOR
VIOLATION OF ANY CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE OFFENSE. THE TRIAL
COURT SHELL AS A CONDITION OF
PROBATION ORDER THAT PERSON
SECURE EDUCATION OR TREATMENT
FROM A LOCAL COMMUNITY AGENCY
DESIGNATED BY THE COURT IF THE
SERVICE IS AVAILABLE AND IF THE
PERSON IS LIKEL TO BENEFIT FROM
THE SERVICE. HOWEVER THIS
SECTION IS VAGUE ON WHAT THESE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS MUST
SPECIFICALLY ENTAIL. FURTHERMORE
SECTION TWELVE ELEVEN OF THE
PENAL CODE CONTAINS LITERALLY
ONE SENTENCE ABOUT EDUCATION AND
COUNSELING PROGRAMS AND STATES
IT SHOULD BE AT LEAST TWENTY
HOURS OF INSTRUCTION. THAT'S IT
THAT'S ALL THE STATE CURRENTLY
SAYS ON THESE CRUCIAL SERVICES.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY IS A SIMPLE
MEASURE TO SIMPLY REQUIRE THE
COUNTY DRUG ADMINISTERED WORK
WITH MEMBERS OF THE COURT
PROBATION AND SUBSTANCE ABUSE
ADVOCATES TO DETERMINE WHAT
STANDARDS AND INFORMATION COULD
BE INCLUDED IN ANY COUNSELING.
OR EDUCATION PROGRAMS REQUIRED
BY THE COURT AS A CONDITION OF
PROBATION. MEMBERS WE KNOW THAT
DRUG ADDICTION IS IN A CRIME
IT'S NOT ILLNESS SOME ADDICTED
TO DRUGS MAY NEVER FULLY GET
OVER THIS ADDICTION. HOWEVER WE
ALSO MUST REALIZE THAT THE BEST
WAY TO HELP THESE INDIVIDUALS IS
TO GET THEM WITH PROFESSIONALS
WHO CAN SHOW THEM HOW TO MANAGE
THEIR ADDICTION. UNDER CURRENT
LAW THAT'S NOT HAPPENING IT
MAKES NO SENSE TO HAVE THE
COURTS REQUIRE COUNSELLING AND
NOT HAVE STATUTORY LEADING
LANGUAGE OUTLINING WHAT SHOULD
BE DISCUSSED IN THESE PROGRAMS.
I WANT TO EMPHASIZE THIS BY NO
MEANS DOES IT LIMIT WHAT THE
TREATMENTS COULD BE. AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY GIVE
STAKEHOLDERS FROM ALL SIDES A
SEAT AT THE TABLE TO HELP
DETERMINE WHAT CALIFORNIA SHOULD
DO WHEN IT COMES TO THE
COUNSELING AND EDUCATION FOR
INDIVIDUALS CONVICTED OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE VIOLATIONS. WITH
ME HERE TODAY VIA PHONE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS R. PAT
ESPINOSA AND ROBERT HIGH TOWER.
AND I ASKED FOR NOT A VOTE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND MR ESPINOZA
PAD ESPINOSA AND- MISTER HIGH
TOWER YOU MAY TESTIFY HOPEFULLY
THE LINES ARE WORKING WHEN EVERY
YEAR READY. YOU.
THE.
WE'RE GOING TO TRY IT AGAIN PAT
ESPINOSA ROBERT HIGHTOWER YOU
MAY TESTIFY.
EIGHTEEN ANTI OPERATOR CAN YOU
HEAR ME. EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WE
CAN'T HEAR YOU AND WE CAN'T HEAR
THE WITNESSES. HELLO. IF WE CAN
HEAR THE WITNESSES AND WE CAN'T
HEAR YOU AND WE CAN'T HEAR ANY.
PROS AND CONS FROM THE PUBLIC.
EIGHTEEN T. OPERATE DO YOU HAVE
A PHONE NUMBER TO WIN IT
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT LEAST LET
US KNOW. WHAT'S GOING ON IF YOU
HEAR ME.
OR ALIENATING HERE. THE THIRD
THEIR NUMBER IN THE ROOM I CAN
GIVE AT&T OPERATOR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES CALL IN. THE WHAT. IT
THEIR NUMBER TO DESK IN THIS
ROOM THAT I HAVE NO I'M NOT
GETTING ANYTHING FROM EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR. THEY'RE WORKING ON
IT NOW. AGAIN I APOLOGIZE. THE
NEW YORK. YOU. THIS IS. I CAN
GIVE YOU THE PROS. THANK. IN BE
HONEST WITH.
HI AT&T OPERATOR- HOPEFULLY YOU
CAN HAVE ARE WITNESSES SPEAK OF
MISSISSIPPI MR ESPINOZA AND
HIGHTOWER. YES LABOR DAY
EUROPE'S MISTER CHAIR YES THE-
PERFECT AND THEY ARE READY TO
SPEAK PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TO THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE CAN YOU HEAR ME OK
YES YOU BOTH HAVE FIVE MINUTES
TOTAL. EXCELLENT MY NAME IS
PATRICK ESPINOZA I'M CHIEF
DEPUTY IN THIS ANNUAL COUNTY
JUST ATTORNEY'S OFFICE THE SAN
DIEGO DA'S OFFICE IS PROUD TO
SUPPORT EIGHTY SEVEN TEN FIFTY
AN EFFORT TO ADDRESS BUT THAT
NOT CRISIS. THERE ARE MANY
APPROACHES TO ADDRESSING THE
FEDERAL CRISIS AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY FOCUSES ON PROVIDING
EDUCATION AND TREATMENT TO
INDIVIDUALS PLACED ON PROBATION.
FOR A CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE
THANKS THE EDUCATION WOULD
INCLUDE LECTURES CLASSES GROUP
DISCUSSIONS AND COUNSELING THE
GOAL OF EDUCATION TREATMENT IS
TO STOP CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE USE
AND SAVE LIVES BY EDUCATING
INDIVIDUALS IN OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM. ABOUT THE RISKS
AND DANGERS ASSOCIATED WITH
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES SUCH AS
THE ALARMING INCREASE IN THE BE
THOU THE EMPLOYABILITY. OF FAKE
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. OKAY
CHRISTIAN PILLS CAN SET. IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
DRUG ENFORCEMENT AGENCY ONE THE
PUBLIC ABOUT IT SIGNIFICANT
NATIONWIDE SURGEON COUNTERCULT
THEY'RE MASS PRODUCED. BY
CRIMINAL DRUG NETWORKS
DECEPTIVELY MARKETED AS
LEGITIMATE PRESCRIPTION PILLS
AND ARE KILLING UNSUSPECTING
AMERICANS. IN THE LAST WEEK SIX
MEN AND A WOMAN SUFFERED FEDERAL
OVERDOSED AT A FLORIDA VACATION
HOME DURING SPRING BREAK THEY'RE
USING COCAINE THAT WAS LACED
WITH THAT AND ALL. FIVE OF THE
INDIVIDUALS WERE REPORTED TO BE
WEST POINT CADETS. AN EXAMPLE
THE REPORT SAN DIEGO COUNTY CASE
INVOLVING NINE ONE ONE CALL TO
REPORT AN- UNRESPONSIVE NINETEEN
YEAR OLD MALE. MEDICS ARRIVED
AND ATTEMPTED TO REVIVE THE
YOUNG MAN BEFORE HE WAS
PRONOUNCED DEAD. INVESTIGATION
REVEALED THE YOUNG MAN HAD USED
COCAINE AND ECSTASY. PREVIOUS
NIGHT DETECTIVES DUG IN
IDENTIFIED THE PERSON WHO
PROVIDED THE COCAINE ECSTASY AND
DETERMINED THAT THE PERSON
BOUGHT PILLS. THAT TESTED
POSITIVE. BUT NOT AND GAVE THE
FEEL SO YOUNG MAN WHO DIED. IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THROUGH THERE
WERE ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY ONE
BUT NO RELATED DEATHS SINCE IN
YOUR COUNTY ACCORDING TO OUR
MEDICAL EXAMINER'S OFFICE. THERE
WERE FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY ONE BUT
NO RELATED DEATHS IN OUR COUNTY
IN TWENTY TWENTY TRIPLE THE
NUMBER FROM THE PREVIOUS YEAR WE
BELIEVE. THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE TOTAL COUNT WILL BE MORE
THAN SEVEN HUNDRED DEATHS
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THERE WERE THREE THOUSAND NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY SIX DEATHS
RELATED TO FENTANYL OVERDOSE IN
CALIFORNIA IN TWENTY TWENTY. BUT
NOW IT'S ONE HUNDRED TIMES MORE
POTENT THAN MORPHINE. FIFTY
TIMES STRONGER THAN HEROIN
ADDICT SUFFERING FROM OPIOID
ADDICTION DON'T REALIZE THE-
JESTING A FATAL DOSE. SAN DIEGO
DIEGO. IS ATTACKING THE PROBLEM
IN SUB FRONTS. WORKING TO.
EDUCATE AND RAISE PUBLIC WAY. IN
DECEMBER ARE OFF AND IT'S DIEGO
CA OFFICE AT. CLOSE IN OUR SOME
TWITTER THE DANGER OF BATON ALL
FOR LOCAL MIDDLE MILLS. AND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS THE SENEGALESE
TO KNOW OF THAT ADDRESS THE
PERVASIVENESS OF THAT NORWAY
STREET DRUGS. AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
IT'S A CONTINUATION OF THIS
EFFORT TO RAISE AWARENESS AND
EDUCATE INDIVIDUALS ABOUT THE
RISK OF STREET DRUGS OR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS. BEING LACED
WITH THAT KNOCK AND OTHER
DANGERS ASSOCIATED WITH THE USE
OF CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE. WE WERE
THIRD SHIFT AND I BOTH AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THANK YOU. NEXT
MISTER HI KAREN MISTER CHAIRMAN
THAT THE PROPER HIGH COURT. YOU
MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS ALL OF YOU ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT ISSUE ALL OF US I
THINK AND AGREE THAT BUT NOW AND
IT WILL BE A CONSTANT CRISIS IS
GOING ON WITH OPIOID ADDICTION
HAS TOUCHED MANY OF OUR LIVES
INCLUDING MYSELF- I PERSONALLY
HAVE HAD A COUSIN WHO PASSED
AWAY DUE TO AN UNFORTUNATE-
INCIDENT WORK BUT NO ONE LAKE
THEN OTHERWISE- BUT PRODUCT
WHILE ADDICTED. I THINK WHAT IS
IMPORTANT AND IF THE LEGISLATION
IS THE EDUCATION THAT WILL
PROVIDE THIS WILL PROVIDE AN
ADDITIONAL TOOL TO COURT AND THE
COUNSELORS TO ADD THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN DAVIES PUT IT HELP
INDIVIDUALS MANAGE THEIR
ADDICTION AS WE KNOW THERE IS
NOT A ONE SIZE FITS ALL PROGRAM
THAT CAN READ INDIVIDUALS FROM
THE CRIPPLING. EFFECTS OF DRUG
AND OPIOID ADDICTION HOWEVER-
AND WE HAVE SEEN IN THE ONGOING
CRISIS THAT HAS BEEN OCCURRING
WHAT HAS REALLY BEEN A HIDDEN
PANDEMIC- IS THAT OFTENTIMES A
DRUG THAT WERE ORIGINALLY NOT
LEGAL IN THEIR ORIGINAL FORM
HAVE BEEN LACED WITH PRODUCTS
THAT ARE- AND THIS WOULD PROVIDE
THE COURT AS WELL AS PROBATION
OFFICERS IN TREATMENT COUNSELORS
WITH AN ADDITIONAL TOOL I DID
WANT TO TOUCH ON ONE THING THAT
I KNOW HAS BEEN BROUGHT UP. BY
SOME OF THOSE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL I WHICH WHAT IN THE COURT
I'M NOT RESPECTFULLY I WOULD
DISAGREE WITH THAT I THINK THIS
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL TOOL OF
THAT COURT INFORMATION OFFICERS%
AND COUNSELORS CAN USE IN ORDER
TO ASSIST THOSE WHO ARE GOING
THROUGH THE TREATMENT PROCESS
WHICH IS OFTEN UP AND DOWN A
PROCESS SO I THINK THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS THAT AND
I ASK ALL OF YOU TO PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS VERY IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION. AND I ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. Q. NOW WILL OPEN UP
FOR PEOPLE THE ROOM TO IF THEY
HAVE ANY ROOM TWENTY. SEVEN TO
MAKE. ACT AND OF STAY ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
IN SUPPORT WILL GO TO THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IS YOUR NAME. ANY PEOPLE OUTSIDE
THEY WANT TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
OKAY. AT&T OPERATE YOU MAY OPEN
UP A LINE FOR SUPPORT. A. B. IF
YOU'RE A SUPPORT IF YOU'RE A
SUPPORT OF AB ONE SEVEN FIVE
ZERO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF A
B. SEVENTEEN FIFTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. ONE MOMENT
WHILE WE GIVE THEIR LINE NUMBERS
MISTER CHAIR.
AGAIN IT'S. ONE ZERO FOUR EIGHT.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY. OKAY. IRATE AND
THEN WE WILL GO TO. ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GONNA LINE UP WHITE EIGHTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. J. COULD ME MATTHEWS ON
BEHALF OF THE ORANGE COUNTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT TO A GOAL LINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH GOOD MORNING TURN
MEMBERS FANFIC OR A LOT AND I'M
CALLING ON BEHALF OF ALL OF US
OR NONE LOS ANGELES. AND I AM.
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. TWENTY
FIFTY. THANK YOU. Q. NEXT TO GO
TO LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR LIGHT IS
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME AND THAT MEANS
THAT BECAUSE AND I'M CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF US IN AN ORANGE
COUNTY AND I'M AND DRUNKEN PART
OF AB SEVENTY INDIAN. THANK YOU
IN MEXICO FORTY SIX ZERO IS OPEN
. HI WHERE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DUNN I'M WITH THE NEW RAIL. I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE WE HAVE
ONE PERSON SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
THEY JUST CAME IN NO OPPOSITION
OKAY. AND NOW WILL. HERE FROM
OPPOSITION OF- AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY- I DON'T SEE ANY WITNESSES
ON THE WITNESS LIST SO WE WILL.
GO TO THE TO THE IN ROOM TO THE
MICROPHONE. AND I WANT TO SAY
MORE THAN JUST ME TO. GO AHEAD
OF IT SORRY GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS TYLER RANDY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES- BUT WE REMAIN IN
OPPOSITION TO AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS- TO THE BILL WE HAD
THREE CONCERNS I'M COMING INTO
THE WITH THE BILL PRIOR TO THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT. THE PROBATION
DEPARTMENT APPROVING THE AND- IN
DESIGNING THE PROGRAMS WE WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EDGE- THAT
pTHE EDUCATION PROPONENT OF THE
PROGRAM THAT WOULD HAVE I'M
MANDATORY EDUCATION ABOUT THE
DANGERS OF CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
AS WELL AS WE WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE LANGUAGE AROUND TO
SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION WE REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT- THE INCLUSION
OF THE LANGUAGE SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION IN THE BILL- I
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS ARE
CHRONIC MEDICAL CONDITION AND SO
THE NATURE OF INCLUDING.
LANGUAGE I HAVE- SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION DOES NOT FIT WITH
THAT YOU KNOW MEDICAL
TERMINOLOGY IN THE WAY OF
TREATING SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS
WE'D RATHER SEE THAT THE
LANGUAGE SAY THAT THE PERSON
MUST PARTICIPATE IN A- CAN
EDUCATE CONTROLLED EDUCATION OR
TREATMENT PROGRAM RATHER THAN
SAYING THE LANGUAGE SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. ORDER ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN A ROOM IN OPPOSITION. POLICE
IN LEWIS ON BEHALF OF DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. FRED WILLIAMS ARE WE
HAVE A SO YOU CATCH ACTION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING MARC COACH GEORGE- ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK THANK YOU. ARE
THERE ANY OTHERS OUTSIDE THE
ROOM. AND THEY WILL GO TO THE
TELEPHONES- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY THOSE WHO
WERE IN OPPOSITION. IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
. AGAIN THIS IS FOR OPPOSITION
OF AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY. AND ONE
MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE GIVE THEM
MY NUMBER.
AS A REMINDER WE IN OPPOSITION
OF AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY. AND WE
WILL GO LINE AT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS THIS IS
pJUSTICE AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AN EXTRA LINE OF EIGHTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS
THE EVER SHE'D WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION LOOKING FOR CONTINUE
CONVERSATION WITH AUTHORS OFFICE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER%
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THE DATA THANK YOU- WE'RE NOT
BRING IT BACK TO COMMITTEE FOR
ANY QUESTIONS CONCERNS. MR
LACKEY YEAH THE OPPOSITION
EXPRESSED CONCERN OVER THE TERM
SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION. CAN YOU
ARTICULATE WHAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION
OF THE PROGRAM AND THEN REFER
THAT TO MY WITNESSES TO. EITHER. ESPINOZA HIGHTOWER BUT- YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU. I DIDN'T QUITE
HEAR THE QUESTION MISTER
CHAIRMAN. YEAH THE OPPOSITION
BROUGHT FORWARD THE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE TERM SUCCESSFUL
COMPLETION WHAT WOULD JUSTIFY
SUCCESSFUL. COMPLETION OR WHAT
WOULD QUALIFY. AFTER SERVICES
ROBERT HIGHTOWER WITH THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE I THINK THAT'S
FULL COMPLETION IS THAT THE
WITHIN THE DISCRETION OF THE
COURT THAT IS LANGUAGE IT IS
CURRENTLY USED AT OTHER PLACES
IN THE CODE SPECIFICALLY WITH
RESPECT TO PROBATION CONDITION-
A LOT OF TIMES THE COURT WILL
MAKE A DETERMINATION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT THEY HAVE BUT
FINANCIALLY COMPLIED WITH THE
TERMS- OR WHETHER OR NOT THEY
HAD COMPLETED THE REQUISITE
NUMBER OF HOURS. IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY SOMETHING LIKE WHERE
THEY HAVE TO PASS A TEST OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT AND IT'S
ABSOLUTELY UP TO THE DISCRETION
OF THE JUDGES- AND THEY HAVE
BEEN IMPLEMENTING THIS WITH A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS
ALREADY IN PLACE FOR EXAMPLE
WITH RESPECT TO. DIVERSION
PROGRAMS. FOR MENTAL HEALTH THAT
- SO GENERALLY SPEAKING THING
COME DIRECTLY NUMBER OF HOURS-
THAT USUALLY IF SUFFICIENT FOR
THE COURT BUT I'VE ALSO SEEN IN
MY EXPERIENCE. THAT COURT
SOMETIMES EVEN IF THEY HAVEN'T
COMPLETED THE REQUISITE NUMBER
OF HOURS WE'LL FIND SUBSTANTIAL
COMPLIANCE AND ALLOW THEM TO
HAVE BEEN A COMPLETE. SO IT
SEEMS TO ME LIKE YOU'RE STATING
THE SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION IS
ACCOMPLISHED BY ATTENDANCE. NOT
BY ANY OTHER CRITERIA. THAT'S
CORRECT AND IF IT'S SOMETHING
THAT IMPLEMENTED A NUMBER OF
ALREADY EXISTING CLASSES IN
TREATMENT THEY DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE TO PASS A PASTOR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT ASSEMBLY HAVE TO
ATTEND THE CLASSES AND COMPLETE
THE REQUISITE NUMBER OF HOURS.
YEAH BECAUSE THE INFERENCES THAT
SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION MEANS THAT
THEY HAVE OVERCOME THE ADDICTION
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THAT IS
WHAT- IS BEING. ALLEGED HERE MY
RIGHT. I WOULD COMPLETELY AGREE
SIR IN FACT I WOULD GO SO FAR AS
TO SAY OFTENTIMES IN DRUG COURT
FOR EXAMPLE. THE TERM OVERCOMING
OR BEING SUCCESSFUL WITH AN
ADDICTION IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
IS ACHIEVABLE ADDICTION AND I'M
SURE ALL THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- WHERE ADDICTION
SOMETHING THAT OF LIFELONG- AND
FILL INDIVIDUALS SIMPLY NEED TO
HAVE ATTENDED THESE TREATMENT
CLASSES AND PARTICIPATED- BUT
IT'S NOT SOMETHING WHERE WE HAVE
FOUND THAT THEY'RE NO LONGER
ADDICTED. BECAUSE MOST
INDIVIDUALS WILL STRUGGLE WITH
THIS FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES
AND THAT'S PARTLY WHY BUILD LIKE
A B. SEVENTEEN FIFTY OR SO
PORTANT. BECAUSE AT LEAST THE
TEACHER THEM TO MANAGE THEIR
ADDICTION WITHOUT JEOPARDIZING
THEIR LIVES. THEY YOU FOR THAT
CLEAR FOR. ON THE BILL. THAT
RANIERE COMMENTS OR- YES START
WEBER. GOOD MORNING- THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR YOUR PRESENTATION
AND FOR I'M BRINGING FORTH THIS
BILL I THINK ALL OF US ARE VERY
WELL AWARE OF THE ISSUES WITH
DRUGS THE ISSUES WITH FENNEL-
YOU KNOW IN SAN DIEGO WE'RE
DOING SOME GOOD THINGS BUT IT'S
NOT JUST A CALIFORNIA THING AS
WAS STATED EARLIER WITH THE
SITUATION THAT JUST HAPPENED
OVER THE WEEKEND IN FLORIDA- I
HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH. THE OPPOSITION TO- AT THIS
BILL CONTINUES TO MOVE FORWARD
IF IT DOES MOVE FORWARD. AND YOU
KNOW SOMEONE POINTED OUT THAT
ADDICTION IS A IT'S A MEDICAL
ISSUE IT IS A CHRONIC MEDICAL
ISSUE BUT I ALSO WANT TO REMIND
PEOPLE. THAT WITH ALL MEDICAL
ISSUES ESPECIALLY CHRONIC
MEDICAL ONCE ONE OF THE KEY
COMPONENTS TO THAT IS EDUCATION.
SO IF YOU HAVE DIABETES WE SENT
YOU TO ABOUT DIABETIC COUNSELOR
SO THAT YOU LEARN HOW TO WHAT
YOU SHOULD EAT HOW YOU SHOULD
TAKE YOUR MEDICATIONS- WHAT ARE
THE SIGNS AND SYMPTOMS IF YOUR
IF YOUR GLUCOSE IS TOO LOW- AND
SO THIS IS JUST LIKE THAT. YOU
HAVE A AN ADDICTION WE'RE
SENDING YOU TO SOME PEOPLE THAT
CAN EDUCATE YOU. ON ON HOW TO
HELP OVERCOME THAT POINT BECAUSE
IT IS A LIFELONG THING AND SO.
YOU KNOW I THINK FOR A VERY LONG
TIME THAT IT'S BEEN ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HAS BEEN LACKING
WHEN WE'RE DEALING WITH PEOPLE
WHO HAVE- ADDICTION TO DRUGS AND
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD- AND I
CAN'T I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
IF IT GETS ON THE FLOOR. WHAT
YOU HAVE DONE WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO HOPEFULLY REMOVE
SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT THEY
HAVE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR NICE THANK YOU- AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND- IN FACT A
- THE INCIDENT THAT HAPPENED
WITH THE MILITARY- IN. STATE
TUITION- VERY GOOD FRIEND OF
MINE I WENT TO COLLEGE WITH HER
NEW NEPHEW. WAS ONE OF THE
VICTIMS IN THAT AD IS WHOLE LIFE
AND CAREER AHEAD OF HIM- AND IF
YOU KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT GETTING
INTO ANY OF THOSE MILITARY
ACADEMIES. SPACECRAFT AMERICANS
JUST VERY DIFFICULT- IT WAS A
LOT OF WORK THAT HE HAD TO PUT
INTO TO GET THERE SO- IS IT IS
DEFINITELY A TRAGEDY FOR THE
CHURCH RECOMMENDED I'VE OF.
THANK YOU. ON A SEVENTY FIFTY BY
SEVEN DAVIES THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER. THANK YOU FOR TAKING A
MOMENT HI. JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY. LACKEY I BONTA. I'VE
BONTA HI BRIAN. HI BRIAN HI
WEBER. SMITH I. THE BILL PASSES
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
DIFFICULT. MISTER BRYANT'S
WITNESS- NEED TO GET BACK TO
WORK AND RIVER LET HIM COME
FIRST SO YOU Ó MISS IRWIN AND
HER WITNESS- W. BACKS. GET.
SO MUCH. YES IT IS A SMALLER.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS COLLEAGUES I RISE RISEN
AB SIX SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN A BILL
THAT WOULD CREATE THE
ALTERNATIVE CONSERVATION
COMMISSION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR STATE HAS.
ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED. WE SPEND OVER
FIFTEEN BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
JUST ON OUR STATE CORRECTIONS
EXPENDITURES. WE'VE USED
INCARCERATION FOR THE FIRST AND
LAST CHOICE TO SOLVE MANY OF OUR
SOCIAL PROBLEMS. IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OVER A DECADE OF
THOUGHTFUL OVER ORGANIZATION LED
TO COMMUNITY MEMBERS. PUSHING
THE BOARD OF SUPERVISORS TO
DEVELOP AN ALTERNATIVE TO
INCARCERATION WORKGROUP. ROOTED
IN A PUBLIC HEALTH APPROACH. TO
RE EVALUATING OUR CONTINUUM OF
CARE. I AN ALTERNATIVE SYSTEMS
TO INCARCERATION THAT STRATEGY
RESULTED IN A REPORT THAT HAD
OVER A HUNDRED AND FIFTEEN
RECOMMENDATIONS ONE OF THEM TO
ESTABLISH THE ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION OFFICE IN THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. IN THE
CEOS OFFICE. THAT OFFICE HAS
BEEN ESTABLISHED. AND A NUMBER
OF THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
THAT REPORT. HIGHLIGHTED SOME
THE JURISDICTIONAL LIMITATIONS
BETWEEN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES AND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. RATHER THAN RUNNING
THOSE. INCONSISTENCIES INTO
LEGISLATION I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT AT THE STATE FIRST
STOP AND GATHER MORE EVIDENCE
AND DATA AND ELEVATE THOSE HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED. BY OUR SYSTEMS OF
INCARCERATION BY DEVELOPING THE
SAME KIND OF COMMISSION THAT THE
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES. HAS
DEVELOPED. THE COMMISSION WAS
COLLABORATIVE INCLUDED STATE
ENTITIES THIS COMMISSION WOULD
BE THE SAME- AND ROOTED IN OUR
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THEY WOULD LAST FOR ONE YEAR
WOULD HAVE APPOINTEES FROM BOTH
HOUSES- AND APPOINTEES FROM THE
GOVERNOR. IT WOULD ALSO AGAIN UP
LIFT ASSIST SYSTEM ACTORS WHO
HAVE A ROLL AND ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION AND THOSE HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY THE CRIMINAL
LEGAL SYSTEM JOINING ME TODAY.
IS JUDGE SONG HI ARMSTEAD JUDGE
SONG HI ARMSTEAD. IS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
OFFICE FOR THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES. AT&T OPERATOR COULD
HAVE JUDGE ARM SAID COME IN AND
TESTIFY. DESIGN IS ONLY HERE BUT
- CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
BEGIN. OKAY GREAT. THE MORNING
CARE JONES SAWYER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M RETIRED JUDGE
FONG HIGH ARMS THAT I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
CURRENTLY I'M THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED
OF THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
ATTORNEYS TO INCARCERATION
OFFICE WOULD COORDINATE AND
IMPLEMENT THE COUNTY JUSTICE
RELATED REFORMS AND POLICY.
CONVENE STAKEHOLDERS AND MAKE
FUNDING RELATED RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR COUNTY FUNDED PROGRAM TO
REALIZE THE BOARD TO PROVIDE THE
VISION. OF A CARE FIRSTHAND JAIL
LAST. I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BRIAN FOR ADVANCING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL. AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY ADVANCES THE COUNTY
EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE OVER
RELIANCE ON THE **** CARPOOL
SYSTEM BY FOCUSING ON
INDIVIDUALS BY PROVIDING THEM
WITH CRITICAL CARE SERVICES AND
COMMUNITY BASED SUPPORT. WE ARE
PLEASED THAT THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A COMMISSION ON
ALTERNATIVES TO INCARCERATION
WHAT IN THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY TO
CONTINUE THIS IMPORTANT POLICY
RESEARCH AND WORK TO EXPAND
SEPARATE STATE WIDE. WE HAVE ALL
LEARNED BY NOW. THE ONE SIZE
FITS ALL APPROACH TO THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM HAS NEVER WORKED THE
COMMISSION ON ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION WILL HELP ADVANCE
MUCH NEEDED TOOL TO ADDRESS AN
IMBALANCE THAT THEM. THAT TOOK
DECADES TO GREAT AND WHICH WE
ARE ALL NOW COLLECTIVELY WORKING
TO CHANGE THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY. IS TAKING PROACTIVE
STEPS. TO RETHINK THE CRITICAL.
TO RETHINK ITS CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND THE ALTERNATIVES TO
INCARCERATION OFFICE. AT IS AT
THE HEART OF THE EFFORT. WE'RE
HEAVILY INVESTING IN COMMUNITY
BASED PROGRAMS AND SERVICES THAT
SUPPORT PEOPLE AT HOME BEFORE
THEY GET INVOLVED IN THE JUSTICE
SYSTEM AND AFTER AS THEY SEEK TO
BECOME PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS WE DO IN THE
EIGHT K. OFFICE IS TO COORDINATE
AND GUIDE BUDGETARY PRIORITIES
TO ENSURE THE COUNTY SPENDING IS
ALIGNED WITH THE BOARD TO
PROVIDE CARE FOR SHELL BLACK
VISION. I'M PROUD TO REPORT THAT
OUR WORK IS NOW EXPANDING ITS L.
A. COUNTY DEVELOP THE NEWLY
ESTABLISHED JEFF THIS CARE IN
OPPORTUNITIES DEPARTMENT THE
GOAL HERE IS TO MELT TO PROMOTE
COLLABORATION AND TRANSPARENCY
IN A PERSON CENTRED AND JUSTICE
SYSTEM AT. AS AS PART OF THAT
DEPARTMENT WE ARE CREATING A
PRETRIAL SERVICES AGENCY. I THAT
EXPANDS UPON OUR WORK TO DEVELOP
COURT IN JAIL DIVERSION PROGRAM
STATEHOUSES HAVE INCREASED SITE
LOCATIONS AND EXPANDED
CONTRACTING WITH COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS FOR FREE FOR PRE
FILE AND RAPID DIVERSION EFFORT
. WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO NIMBLY
OPTIMIZED PROGRAM MODELS TO FIT
THE PAINTING CALLED THE NINETEEN
LANDSCAPE AND ADJUST BASED ON
EACH COMMUNITY'S NEEDS. IN
ADDITION ATI HAS SOME OTHER
MAJOR PROJECTS IN THE WORKS
INCLUDING IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
ALTERNATIVE CRISIS RESPONSE.
THIS IS AN UPCOMING NATIONWIDE
EFFORT TO PROVIDE URGENT AND
APPROPRIATE CRISIS RESPONSE TO
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING MENTAL
HEALTH DISTRESS. AS WE NOW
STARTING THIS SUMMER YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO DIAL NINE EIGHT EIGHT
INSTEAD OF NINE ONE ONE TO GET
HELP FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING A
MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS. IS NOT
ONLY SAVE LIVES BY AVOIDING
POTENTIALLY FATAL POLICE
ENCOUNTERS BUT ALSO FREES UP OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS SO THAT
THEY CAN RESPOND THE TUITION
THAT TRULY MEET THEM. WE'RE ALL
COORDINATED THE EMPLOYMENT.
ABBAS AND TRAINING. A RE ENTRY
AND JOB TRAINING. FOR PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED YOUNG ADULTS
PREPARING THEM FOR CAREERS IN
PUBLIC SAFETY EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT AND WILDLAND
FIREFIGHTING. IT BUILT UPON THE
IMPORTANT WORK THAT YOU HAVE
ALREADY DONE IN THIS VERY
CHAMBER AB TWENTY ONE FORTY
SEVEN. WHICH ALLOW WARMER
NONVIOLENT INCARCERATED PEOPLE
WHO PARTICIPATED IN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
CONSERVATION. CAMP FIRE CREWS.
TO HAVE THEIR RECORDS EXPUNGED
REMOVING THAT COMPATIBLE BARRIER
SO THAT THEY CAN SEE JOBS
WILDLAND FIREFIGHTERS. WE HOPE
TO EXPAND THIS MEANINGFUL WORK
WITH FUTURE LEGISLATION THAT
WILL ALLOW THE PARTICIPANT OF
THE PROGRAM TOP WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME EMTS. AND
STRUCTURAL FIREFIGHTERS.
PROGRAMS LIKE THESE CAN
TRANSFORM PEOPLE'S LIVES AND
ULTIMATELY OUR COMMUNITY
RESEARCH REACHED. THIRTEEN SHOWS
THAT INCARCERATION IS NOT THE
BEST OPTION FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS.
FOR OUR COMMUNITIES AND QUITE
FRANKLY IT IS NOT THE BEST USE
OF OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS. AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY. TAKE THAT BOLD
STEP. THE MOVE CALIFORNIA TO A
MORE JUST. AND EQUITABLE PLACE
FOR ALL. AND FOR THESE REASONS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
BUT- THANK YOU AND I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWERING QUESTIONS. THANK YOU-
ORDER ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. OR OUTSIDE
THE ROOM. WE'RE CLOSE TO. NAME
IN ORDER. MARCO GEORGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. ONLY SEAL IT
WAS SUMMING UP THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT. GIVEN FRED
WILLIAMS A SEAL CAL ACTION IN
SUPPORT YOU. A LITTLE WE HAVE A
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
AND NOW ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IN THE ROOM. YOU MAY
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. AT&T OPERATOR-
FOR AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY. OKAY I
WOULDN'T SUPPORT FIRST
OPPOSITION. BOB THIS DO SUPPORT
. ON THE PHONE I APOLOGIZE FOR
TO BRING IT I'M IN A HURRY.
THANK YOU IF YOU WERE IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT
IS ONE AND THEN ZERO YOUR IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BRISKER IS
PLAYING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
NURSES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF
AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE THIRTY TWO
YOU YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ FOR THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT ABOUT A LINE OF THE NINETY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. IN THE
WATER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT
OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY THANK YOU. NEXAVAR LINE OF NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS JIM WOOD BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO A LINE OF NINETY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING IS THAT AWAY DIRECTOR OF
POLICY AND ADVOCACY AT THE
MEDIUM POWER ALLEN ONE OF THE CO
AUTHORS OF THE ATI REPORT IN LOS
ANGELES. IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MEXICO NIGHT OF NINETY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MARIN
FUNDING THE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
AGENCIES SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT
OF A LINE OF EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MORNING TO MEMBERS GREGORY
. SHOULD JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT OF A LINE OF NINETY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND REYES
GARCIA APPOINTED ANY ON ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN YOU KNOW
FREEDOM ALL AND PROJECT AMIGA IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE OF NINETY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
DAILY MALAKING WITH ESSIE
JUSTICE GROUP APOCALYPSE SERVER
AS PART OF YOUR FIRST COLLISION
AND STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
NEXT TO THE LINE OF ONE ON ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
YEP ROC THE STATE'S ABILITY
RIGHT CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT OUR LETTER IS
FORTHCOMING THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU NEXT OVER LINE OF ONE
HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MICHELLE PARA PROGRAM
DIRECTOR AT THE VERA INSTITUTE
OF JUSTICE BASED IN LOS ANGELES
AND I'M CALLNG IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY.
THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE OF
NINETY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING CANNOT BACK OFF ON
BEHALF OF CAL WASTED CALLING IN
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF FORTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. CAN DONE
FROM ANYWHERE. AND WE ARE PROUD
CO SPONSORS OF EIGHTY SIXTEEN
SEVENTY AND ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO LINE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS MY NAME IS
DIANE FIGUEROA AND I'M CALLING
IN BEHALF OF ALL OF US ARE NINE
LOS ANGELES AND I AM IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB. ONE SIX SEVEN
ZERO. THANK YOU NEXT OF A LINE
OF THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. GOOD MORNING INTERMEMBRANE
EXACTLY JEFF. CONTAINING ALL OF
THAT AND THEN ORANGE AND HEARING
TRONG MORE IN A SIXTEEN SEVENTY.
THANK YOU IN MEXICO LINE OF
NINETY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SHAYLA
LAWSON CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL PROJECT WE'RE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY.
THANK YOU IN MEXICO TO LINE OUT
ONE OH TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
GOOD MORNING- MY RIOS ON BEHALF
OF THE KERN COUNTY CRIMINAL
JUSTICE COALITION IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB SIXTY SEVEN. THANK
YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE
NINETY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
THIS IS AMBER ROSE BROKE
COALITION COORDINATOR FOR THE
JUSTICE LA COALITION CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF. EIGHTY
SIXTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
THE NEXT TO GO LINE OF EIGHTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. RIGHT
EIGHTY TWO I THINK YOU TOOK
YOURSELF OUT IF YOU COULD- ONE
ZERO AGAIN. THERE YOU GO RIGHT
EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS FIGURE OUT TO GO IT
WAS RIVERSIDE ALL OF US OR NONE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER SUPPORT QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU- I THINK ARE
ASKED FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. AND
DIDN'T SEE NONE OPRY MAY OPEN UP
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON
EIGHTEEN T. LOT. DO YOU SEE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB SIXTEEN OF
SEVENTY YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND THEN
ZERO UP IN OPPOSITION OF AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY. AND WE WILL GO
TO LINE ONE- FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. ONE ONE OH FOUR. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU WE NOW BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR
ANY. QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS A
QUESTION THAT IS LACKING YEAH IT
SEEMS TO ME AND LOOKING AT THE
COMPOSITION OF THIS COMMISSION
THAT THERE IS NO INCLUSION OF-
CRIME VICTIM REPRESENTATION IN
MY ACCURATE ON THE- NO I
WOULDN'T I WOULDN'T SAY THAT
THAT'S ACCURATE I THINK THAT WE
KNOW THAT THE VICTIMS OF CRIME
ARE MOST LIKELY. TO ALSO BE
IMPACTED BY THE CRIMINAL LEGAL
SYSTEM AND WE'VE GOT DEDICATED
SEATS FOR THOSE WITH LIVED
EXPERIENCE HAVING BEEN IMPACTED
BY THE FROM THE LEGAL SYSTEM AND
SO I THINK IT'S SAFE TO SAY THAT
THERE'S LIKELY TO BE OVERLAP.
BUT WE CAN DEFINITELY CLARIFY
THAT LANGUAGE. WHO ACCORDING TO
WHAT I'VE READ. THERE'S ELEVEN.
MEMBERSHIP SLOTS. ANOTHER ONE OF
ON- REPRESENT A CRIME VICTIM.
ORGANIZATION SO I FEEL LIKE- BUT
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
COLLABORATIVE I THINK IT SHOULD
HAVE TO INCLUDE CRIME VICTIMS
AND IT DOESN'T APPEAR TO BE
DOING THAT SO I'LL HAVE TO
OPPOSE IT. THEY GIVE ANY OTHER
RUSSIANS ARE CONCERNED. WITH
THAT YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR- AND THANK YOU FOR
ALL WHO CALLED IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR. YOUR AYE VOTE. JURORS
RECOMMENDED I. DOT YOUR MOTION.
THEIR SECOND. AB SIXTEEN SEVENTY
BY SEVEN MEMBER BRIAN THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER HI LACKEY LACKEY NEL
BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN HI BRIAN HI
WEBER WEBER I THOUGHT THE ARGO
SANTIAGO I MET. SMITH NOW. THE
MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU THANK
YOU. AND AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE RESTAURANT- AB
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN- OF DEATH
JURISDICTION. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WITNESSES FOR BEING PAID PATIENT
WITH US TODAY. MMHM AND FOR
BEING IN PERSON. THAT'S GOOD
ROLE FROM THE- YES. MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMIT MEMBER- TODAY HERE TO
PRESENT AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
WHICH WILL REENACT PENAL CODE
SEVEN EIGHT SIX POINT FIVE AND
ALLOW FOR THE CONSOLIDATION OF
RELATED ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
OFFENSES OCCURRING ACROSS
MULTIPLE JURIST A JUROR A HAD
MULTIPLE COUNTIES INTO A SINGLE
PROSECUTION I INTRODUCED THIS
BILL IN RESPONSE MY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT LEADERS AND
COMMUNITY MEMBERS GROWING
CONCERN OVER THE BRAZEN RETAIL
THEFTS ACROSS THE STATE WE'VE
ALL SEEN VIDEOS OF SMASH AND
GRAB ROBBERIES AND HUGE MOBS
DESCENDING UPON DEPARTMENT
STORES ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT IS
NOT A TEENAGER STEALING MAIL
POLISH. OR PERSON EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS STEALING A BAG OF
POTATO CHIPS IT IS ON A SCALE
THAT ENDANGERS THE SAFETY OF
RETAIL WORKERS THE SAFETY OF
CUSTOMERS TRYING TO SUPPORT OUR
LOCAL ECONOMIES AND SMALL
BUSINESSES TRYING TO MAKE PAY
ROLL WHEN I ASKED MY LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHAT WE COULD DO I
WAS SURPRISED BY THEIR SIMPLE
REQUEST BRING BACK A TOOL THAT
WAS PASSED BY THE LEGISLATURE
AND SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR TWICE
BUT WAS ALLOWED TO SUNSET LAST
SUMMER. THE CONTENT OF THIS BILL
HAS INTRODUCED WAS VERBATIM THE
MULTI JURISDICTIONAL CHARGING
TOOL THAT WAS PACKAGED IN AB TEN
SIXTY FIVE ALONG WITH THE
CREATION OF THE CRIME OF
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT IN THE
CHP TASK FORCE THE CHAIRS TIMELY
RESPONSE TO A SURGE OF THESE
OFFENSES IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE OVERWHELMING
OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORTED THAT
BILL AND FOLLOW UP BUDGET BILL
IN TWENTY NINETEEN THAT EXTENDED
THE SUNSET DATE THE BILL BEFORE
YOU HEAR DIFFERENCE ONLY
SLIGHTLY AND I NEGOTIATED WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION AND TOOK THEIR
AMENDMENT TO REQUIRE THE
PERMISSION OF THE PROSECUTING
AGENCY WITH THE ORIGINAL
JURISDICTION FOR ANY ASSOCIATED
OFFENSE. OTHER THAN THE
ENUMERATED THEFT OFFENSES I'M
HAPPY TO NOTE THEY HAVE REMOVED
THEIR OFFICE ADDITION TO THE
BILL. LASTLY I WOULD LIKE TO
REMIND MY COLLEAGUES OF THE
IMPORTANT INVESTMENTS BEING
DISCUSSED AS PART OF THE BUDGET
PROCESS. THE GOVERNOR'S REAL
PUBLIC SAFETY PLAN PROPOSES WE
INVEST THIRTY MILLION IN OUR
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S OFFICES AND
EIGHTEEN MILLION IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE TO COME COMBAT
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT. WITHOUT
AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN ATTORNEY
GENERAL BONTA WILL BE REQUIRED
TO WASTE TAXPAYER DOLLARS
SENDING DEPUTY ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S TO MULTIPLE. COUNTIES
TO PROSECUTE TO PERMIT SECURED
THE SAME THAT THEFT RING AND
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS WILL BE
SCHEDULING THE THIRD OR FOURTH
SEQUENTIAL TRIAL TO PROSECUTE
THE SAME DEFENDANT FOR STEALING
SIMILAR MERCHANDISE. ALL OF
WASTE OF TAXPAYER FUNDS. TODAY I
HAVE JOINING WITH ME. THE TWO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL HOPEFULLY
BOTH OF THEM WILL BE JOINING A
VETERAN COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY
ERIC NESTERENKO. AND BY PHONE
VENTURA COUNTY SHERIFF BILL A
YOU. MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS ERIC NESTERENKO
PLEASE TO BE BEFORE YOU THIS
MORNING I WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING AND RECOGNIZING.
ASSEMBLYWOMAN JACQUI IRWIN FOR
INTRODUCING ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN. AND I WANT TO
ASK ALL OF YOU TO BRING BACK A
BILL THAT WORKED AND THAT THE
OFFICE OF THE VENTURA COUNTY DA
RELIED UPON SPECIFICALLY WHEN
THE LAPSED STATUTE PENAL CODE
SECTION SEVEN EIGHT SIX POINT
FIVE WAS IN EFFECT. OUR OFFICE
USED IT IN SEVERAL DIFFERENT
CASES AGAINST TWELVE DIFFERENT
DEFENDANTS ONE UNDERSCORE
UNDERLINED SOMETHING THAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUST SPOKE UP
THESE ARE ORGANIZED
SOPHISTICATED RETAIL THEFT CREWS
AND RINGS. THEY ARE NOT USEFUL
IMPETUOUS AXE THEY ARE NOT SPUR
OF THE MOMENT CRIMES. NOR ARE
THEY CRIMES OF OPPORTUNITY.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT
TRAVEL OUR VAST NETWORK OF
FREEWAYS WHETHER THE FIVE EIGHTY
OR THE SIXTY OR THE ONE THE ONE
OF THE FOUR OH FIVE FOR THE
FOURTEENTH. AND THEY TARGET
SPECIFIC INDUSTRIES AND SPECIFIC
STORES WHY DO THEY DO SO BECAUSE
THEY USE A SOPHISTICATED
CRIMINAL NETWORK TO UNDERSTAND
THE STORE LAYOUT. TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE THE LOSS PREVENTION
OFFICERS ARE SITUATED WITH THE
SECURITY GUARDS MAYBE AND ALSO
MOST IMPORTANTLY TO UNDERSTAND
WHERE THE MERCHANDISE IS STORED
AND WHAT IT IS VALUED ACT. THESE
ARE VERY SOPHISTICATED ORGANIZED
RINGS THE RELY UPON THE
CELLPHONE. AND IN DOING SO THE
CHIEF COORDINATION COMMUNICATION
. LANNING AND WHAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT TO THE OFFICE OF THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY BOTH HERE AND
STATEWIDE IS THAT THESE CASES
RECEIVE A QUARTERBACK THAT IS
ONE OFFICE WHICH CAN TAKE ALL OF
THE STAFFS AND CONSOLIDATE THEM
INTO ONE PROSECUTION WHY IS THIS
IMPORTANT BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE
WOULD RELY UPON THE EXISTING
FRAMEWORK WHICH IS FRAGMENTARY
IN NATURE DISCIPLINE TO THESE
CASES ACROSS COUNTIES MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS ESSENTIALLY WHO
SPENDS RESOURCES IN A WAY THAT'S
NOT WISE FOR TAXPAYERS IT ALSO
HURTS VICTIMS BECAUSE THEY HAVE
TO TESTIFY CONCEIVABLY IN
MULTIPLE COURT ROOMS AND
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS. IN THE
BILL THAT ASSEMBLY WOMAN OR IS
COUNTRY IN TERMS BRINGS BACK A
FRAMEWORK THAT AVOIDS REPETITION
AND PIECEMEAL PROSECUTION. AND
THEN LASTLY I JUST WANT TO
SHARE- A COMMENT IN RESPECT TO
THE ANALYSIS THAT WAS BOUGHT
FORD IN THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
THE COMMENT WAS. SHOULD THE
LEGISLATURE PRESCRIBE LOOSER
JURISDICTIONAL RULES FOR THEFT
OFFENSES THAN IT DOES FOR FELONY
SEX OFFENSES AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING OFFENSES IT'S A
POINT WORTH DISCUSSING VERY
BRIEFLY NOW. THE NATURE OF THE
PUNISHMENT FOR FELONY SEX
OFFENSES AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING
OFFENSES IS VERY DIFFERENT FROM
THAT OF ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
THE REASON THE GUARDRAILS ARE
DIFFERENT FROM THE SEX AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES THAN THEY ARE
IN O. R. T. CASES. IS HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND SEX CRIMES ARE
PUNISHABLE BY THE POTENTIAL FOR
LIFETIME SIX REGISTRATION. BY
IMPRISONMENT IN CDC ARE- AS WELL
AS THE FACT THAT MANY OF THE SEX
OFFENSES ARE STRIKES SO THE
GUARDRAILS FOR THOSE TYPES OF
CRIMES ARE DIFFERENT FROM THE O.
R. T. ONES BECAUSE ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT FOR NINETY POINT
FOUR. FOUR NINETY SIX-
CONSPIRACY FORTY SEVEN GRAND
THEFT THERE PUNISHABLE BY FELONY
JAIL WHICH ESSENTIALLY MEANS
THEIR COMMITMENTS IN THE LOCAL-
JAIL THEY ARE PUNISHABLE UNDER
ELEVEN SEVENTY H. AND MANY OF
THEM ALSO ARE WHILE BLURS SO
THEY ARE VERY DIFFERENT IN
NATURE FROM THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND THE SEX CRIMES.
THAT ALLOW FOR CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL FILING IN PENAL
CODE SECTION SEVEN EIGHT FOUR
POINT SEVEN- MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL. IT IS TIMELY IT IS
NEEDED AND IT WILL HELP
DISMANTLE SOPHISTICATED VERY
COORDINATED CREWS WHO USE OUR
VAST NETWORK OF FREEWAYS TO
STEAL FOR MERCHANTS WHO STEAL
FROM BUSINESSES AND YOU UP ROUTE
AND ENDANGER OUR COMMUNITIES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE ROOM
AT IN SUPPORT. OF A- BUT SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN IRWIN AS ANY WITNESSES
OUTSIDE THE COURTROOM IN SUPPORT
OF BEER KIM STONE STONE ADVOCACY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DISTRICT ATTORNEYS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND
OUTSIDE. IN IN SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR WE
CAN NOW GO TO THE PHONES IN
SUPPORT. AB SORT AND EIGHTY.
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE
THAT MANY ZERO FJORD SUPPORT OF
AB. SIXTEEN THIRTEEN. AND WE
WILL GO TO LINE EIGHTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS A LIST OF
AT ASPEN THIS ON BEHALF OF THE
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND THE
COUNTY OF VENTURA INSTRUCTS THE
PORT EIGHTY SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO A LINE OF ONE OH NINE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MISTER JERRY MEMBER STEVE
MCCARTY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT LOCAL LINE THIRTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
SHARON MEMBERS AT LEAST OUR CITY
A CONDO WITH THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES IN SUPPORT. Q.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT IN QUEUE AT
THIS TIME. BIG NOTE HERE FROM
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO
ENOUGH OF OUR SECOND WITNESS WAS
TRYING TO GET ON THE LINE OKAY
EIGHTEEN OPERATOR I BELIEVE THE
SECOND WITNESS. I WAS TRYING TO
GET THROUGH CAN YOU BRING THEM
ON RIGHT NOW. AT THE END IT
WOULD BE DISPLAYED AEROFIT.
SHERIFF A GOOD MORNING SHARE
BILLY YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE
CAN. A GOOD MORNING JERRY JONES
SAWYER MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ABILITY YOU VENTURA COUNTY. YOU
HEARD MUCH SAID ALREADY ABOUT
THE PROBLEM OF ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE'VE
ALL SEEN IMAGES OF GROUPS OF
CRIMINALS ENTERING OPEN
BUSINESSES REMOVING LARGE
AMOUNTS OF MERCHANDISE- MANY
CASES WHILE NOT BEING CONFRONTED
BY STORE EMPLOYEES OR SECURITY
GUARDS. YOU ADD TO THAT THE
FLASH MOB STYLE TAKEOVERS OF
BUSINESSES AND SMASH AND GRAB
THEFTS AND WE'RE ALL LEFT WITH
THE IMPRESSION THAT CRIME IS
SPIRALING OUT OF CONTROL IN OUR
GREAT STATE. THERE ARE THOSE WHO
THINK RETAIL COMPANIES CAN
SIMPLY ABSORB THESE LOSSES AND
IT THERE ARE NO REAL VICTIMS OF
THESE RETAIL CRIMES AND THE
REALITY IS THAT WE ARE ALL
VICTIMS OF THESE BRAZEN ACTS.
RETAIL RETAILERS SIMPLY DO NOT
ABSORB THE COST OF THEFT THEY
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO RAISE
PRICES TO COMPENSATE FOR THEIR
LOSSES CAUSED BY THESE CRIMINAL
ACTS. WE ALL PAY A PRICE IN A
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTS THOSE
AMONG US. WHO CAN AFFORD AT
LEAST. IN COUNTY AGGRESSIVELY
PURSUE PEOPLE WHO TARGET OUR
COMMUNITIES WITH THESE TYPES OF
CRIMES. TWO OF THE LARGEST
RETAIL CENTERS IN VENTURA
COUNTY. ORANGE CITY POLICE BY
THE SHERIFF'S OFFICE. AND I CAN
TELL YOU THAT OUR COMMUNITIES
HAVE NOT BEEN IMMUNE TO THISLAWLESS BEHAVIOR. BUT WE FOUND
THAT VERY LITTLE OF IT IS
COMMITTED BY LOCAL CRIMINALS.
MOST OF THE HIGHLY MOBILE CREWS
ORIGINATE IN THE STATE'S LARGER
METROPOLITAN AREAS. IN FACT. OF
THE EIGHTY SIX ARRESTS WE MADE
CORGAN EYES RETAIL THEFT THIS
PAST YEAR. NEARLY 75% OF THE
OFFENDERS TRAVELLED INTO VENTURA
COUNTY FROM OTHER PLACES. TO
COMMIT THOSE CRIMES. THESE ARE
ORGANIZED THIEVES NOT DRUG
DEPENDENT VICTIMS OR OTHERS.
LOOKING TO SUSTAIN. A LIFESTYLE
THAT NEWS. YOU WILL BY DRUG OF
DEPENDENCE AND- USE. OTHER
GROUPS OF PEOPLE WHO COMMIT
THESE CRIMES BREEZE TRAVEL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. TARGETING
RETAIL CENTERS AND MANAGER
DIFFERENT JURISDICTION.
INCLUDING OUR OWN. AND FOR THIS
REASON IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
FOR DISTRICT ATTORNEYS HAVE THE
TOOLS. TO CONSOLIDATE CASES FOR
MULTIPLE COUNTIES. SO THEY CAN
PROPERLY. PROSECUTE CRIMINALS
FOR THE CRIMES THEY COMMIT.
RECENTLY OUR ARE SO CREW TO WERE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MULTIPLE
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT ACROSS
CITIES AND COUNTIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. WE TRY TO CONSOLIDATE
THOSE CASES ONLY TO LEARN THAT
THE LAW CHAPTER INTOPEOPLE CO
SEVEN EIGHTY SIX POINT FIVE.
WHICH PREVIOUSLY ALLOWED
PROSECUTORS TO CHARGE SUSPECTS
WITH MULTIPLE CASES ACROSS
JURISDICTIONAL LINES THAT
EXPIRED LAST YEAR. OUR DEBT
THESE WERE TIRELESSLY ALONGSIDE
PROSECUTORS TO BRING THOSE
OFFENDERS TO JUSTICE MAKING
ARRESTS ONLY TO HAVE SUSPECTS
QUICKLY RELEASED FROM JAIL AND
NOT CHARGE. FOR ONLY CHARGED
WITH A FRACTION OF THEIR ACTUAL
CRIMES HURTS PUBLIC SAFETY IN IS
NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
PUBLIC WE ALL SERVE. I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT ASSEMBLY MEMBER WANTS
BILL AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN. TO
REINSTATE THE LAW THAT GIVES
DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S THE TOOLS TO
CONSOLIDATE CASES FROM MULTIPLE
COUNTIES. TO PROPERLY PROSECUTE
CRIMINALS FOR THE CRIME THEY
COMMIT. IT IS FISCALLY
RESPONSIBLE. AND IT IS A STEP IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO ADDRESS
THE INCREASINGLY BRAZEN
INCIDENTS OF ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT WE'RE SEEING THROUGHOUT
OUR STATE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU. NOW HEAR FROM
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IN A
ROW MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS FRED
WHIMS ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION FIRST WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE IN THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING ON A MINUTES ON THIS
BILL. THE FORTY AT THIS TIME WE
MUST TO REMAIN OPPOSED. AB
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN UNDER EXISTING-
WOULD ALLOW PROSECUTOR WITH
ALMOST NO CONNECTION TO AN
ALLEGED OFFENSE TO PROSECUTE
SUCH ALLEGED OFFENSE. THIS BILL
RENDON A BROAD MANNER LIKE
PROSECUTORS IN THE COUNTY WERE
ANY ACT WAS DONE BY THE
DEFENDANT INSTIGATING PROCURING
PROMOTING OR AIDING. IN THE
COMMISSION OF THE THEFT OFFENSE
THE TEXT THIS BILL COULD CREATE
A SITUATION WHERE A PROSECUTOR
WITH THE LEASING NEXUS TO THE
OFFENSE. COULD BECOME THE
PRINCIPAL PART PROSECUTING
COUNTY REGISTER CONTAINS OFFICE.
UNDER EXISTING LAW PROSECUTOR
HAD THE JURISDICTION OVER ANY
ALLEGED OFFENCE OCCURRING THERE
COUNTY GIVING LOCAL PROSECUTOR
THE FINAL SAY OVER CHARGING
DECISION MAKES IT. BOTH BECAUSE
THE PROSECUTOR CAN CONSISTENTLY
DETERMINE WHAT CHARGES IF ANY
ARE APPROPRIATE. AND BECAUSE
FORCING VICTIMS WHEN THE SYSTEM
IN ITS TO TRAVEL OUT OF COUNTY
CAN BE DISRUPTIVE FORM
PRACTICAL. INCLUDING DURING
THEIR APPOINTMENT ABILITY CARE
FOR THEIR FAMILIES. LASTLY THIS
BILL REINSTATES A MECHANISM JURY
IDEATION OPTING. WILL PROSECUTE
DECISIONS ARE MADE BASED ON THE
PRESENCE OF THE MOST FAVORABLE
JERRY OR THE MOST RESOURCE DA
OFFICE. FOR THESE REASONS WE
MUST RESPECTFULLY REQUEST A
NOTEBOOK ON THIS BILL THANK.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES- EITHER IN THE ROOM OR
OUTSIDE. THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
. THE SCENE DOWN. OF EIGHTY TWO
OPERATOR YOU MAY OPEN UP THE
LINE. IRWIN AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU'RE IN A
POSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AGAIN THAT IS ONE AND THEN
ZERO FOR IN OPPOSITION AB
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN. AND WE WILL GO
TO LIE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NINETY ONE. AND WE WILL
GO ON TO LINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORNING
TURN MEMBERS GREGORY FELLOW
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. THANK SURE WE HAVE NO MORE
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU AND I BELIEVE SOMEONE
JUST STEPPED IN THE ROOM- IN
OPPOSITION NAME AN ORGANIZATION
THE MORNING DAN AYKROYD ON ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC DEFENDER IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU NOW BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS. OR. WHICH TO. OKAY I'M HONORED TO
GO FIRST I GUESS IS THE NUBIA I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD WE NEED TO
SO WE CAN START WORKING TOGETHER
WITH OUR D. X. THEY RUN FROM ONE
COUNTY TO THE OTHER COUNTY IN
THE CAN COLLECTIVELY WORK
TOGETHER I'LL BE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL TODAY. MR LACKEY YEAH-
AS WAS BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION-
THIS WAS THIS IS WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT RESTORING PROVISIONS OF
LAW AND LOGIC SUNSET TO ALLOW US
TO REASSESS WHETHER THERE ARE
COMPELLING CIRCUMSTANCES TO
REINSTATE THAT PARTICULAR LAW
WHO IN THE WORLD DOES NOT THINK
THAT ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
DOESN'T NEED HELP RIGHT NOW. I
MEAN THAT'S A COMPLETE
APPLICATION OF REALITY- IT IT'S
A GROWING PROBLEM NOT A
DIMINISHING ONE AND THIS IS A
COMMONSENSE PROVISION THAT
DESERVES TO BE REINSTATED NAVI.
CLEARLY SUPPORTING THANK YOU
BONTA CAN YOU HELP ADDRESS THE
ISSUE THAT THE OPPOSITION RAISED
AROUND A FORUM FORUM SHOPPING
AND THEN ALSO JUST IN THE
INTEREST OF MAKING SURE THAT
DEFENDANTS HAVE AT THE AMPLE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HAVE THEIR
CASES REVIEWED BY A JURY OF
THEIR PEERS WHAT IT WOULD MEAN
FOR US TO HAVE TO. TAKE THAT
INTO CONSIDERATION IN YOUR
LEGISLATION THE OTHER OUT I WILL
HAVE YOU FOLLOW UP ON THAT THE
LAWYER ACTUALLY BUT- THEY MEANT
TO THE OPPOSITION MENTIONS THAT.
YOU WOULD BE ABLE TO HAVE
PROSECUTORS WITH ALMOST NO
CONNECTION OR- TO THE DEFENDANTS
BUT- THE LANGUAGE OF SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN SAYS THE OFFENSES HAVE
TO OCCUR LOCALLY WITH
SUBSTANTIAL CONNECTION OF THE
SAME DEFENDANTS ARE THE SAME
SCHEME OR MERCHANDISE FOR A
PROSECUTOR TO FILE CHARGES. SO
THE CRIME DID OCCUR. IN THE
COUNTY AND- AND IT'S JUSTA
MATTER OF COMPILING ALL THAT IT
YOU KNOW IF IT'S IF IT'S CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL LINES COMPILING
ALL THOSE- ALL THE DIFFERENT
OFFENSES. AND THERE IS ACTUALLY
NO- THERE THERE IS NO
CONSTITUTIONAL- RIGHT TO. THE
END OF THAT THAT THE ACLU IS
TIME NOT JURY SHOPPING THERE'S
NO CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
HAVING A TRIAL WHERE YOU WANT
ITS WORD. THE CRIME ACTUALLY
OCCURRED SELF I'M SURE YOU
WOULD. HAVE A BETTER FOLLOW UP
NEXT. YEAH THANKS FOR THE
QUESTION- ASSEMBLY ONE. WITH
RESPECT TO FOREIGN SHOP AND I
WOULD ASSERT THAT. DA'S ARE
GOING TO BRING FORWARD THE CASE
THAT AROSE FROM THEIR
JURISDICTIONS WE'RE GONNA WANT
TO BRING FOR IT A ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT THAT HAPPENED IN
THE COUNTY OF VENTURA- THERE HAS
TO BE AS WE ALL KNOW SOME NEXUS
SOME CALLS A LINK TO OUR COUNTY-
I THINK IN A VERY EXCEEDINGLY
RARE CIRCUMSTANCE WOULD IT
SIMPLY BE THE MERCHANDISE- WE
WOULD WANT TO ACTUALLY HAVE AN-
O. R. T. IN OUR COUNTY- THAT
WOULD BE VERY IMPORTANT. AND
THEN WITH RESPECT TO- HOW DO WE
MAKE SURE THAT WE TAKE OTHER
COUNTIES AND- OFFENSES THAT
HAPPENED THERE- SERIOUSLY AND
RECOGNIZE BOTH DEFENDANTS AND
VICTIMS. I WOULD SHARE WITH YOU
THAT. IN OUR WORLD. OUR
CASELOADS ARE OVERWHELMING. SO
IN THE CASE OF THE SHERIFF
MENTIONED- THERE WAS A TWO
PERSON CREW THAT WENT INTO A
NUMBER OF BEAUTY SUPPLY STORES.
BASED TOLD ALL TOTAL THIRTY NINE
THOUSAND AND HIGH END PERFUMES
AND BEATY SUPPLY ITEMS. AND WE
LEARN THAT ONE MEMBER OF THE
CREW WAS BEING INVESTIGATED AND
FOR OTHER COUNTIES SAMBAR TO
DINO RIVERSIDE LA IN SAN DIEGO
FOR ALLEGE LOSSES UP TO HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND WHAT ARE OFFICE
WOULD DO SENSE. SUPPORTERS AND
ALL THIS MADERA COUNTY WERE
VICTIMS OF A R. T. WE WOULD
CONTACT THOSE OTHER
JURISDICTIONS IN WHICH SAY WE
HAD THE CRIME HAPPENED HERE CAN
WE GO AHEAD AND TAKE YOUR CASES
AND PUT THEM INTO A SINGLE
PROSECUTION. I BELIEVE THEY
WOULD WELCOME THAT BECAUSE ONE
THEY WANT SOMEBODY TO BE THAT
QUARTERBACK SOMEBODY NEEDS TO
STEP FORWARD AND SAY THIS IS A
REIGNING IT'S SOPHISTICATED IN
ORDER TO DISMANTLE IT WE NEED TO
BE EQUALLY COORDINATED AND IN
SYNC. AND WITH RESPECT TO-
LASTLY UST TO ADDRESS YOUR
COMMENT AND QUESTION. YOU KNOW
THE JURY WOULD BE ONE THAT WOULD
INDEED BE A JURY OF PEERS- IT
WOULD BE SELECTED THROUGH THE
SAFEGUARDS THERE NOW IN PLACE TO
THIRTY SEVENTY ANOTHER LOSS. AND
I BELIEVE THAT DEFENDANTS
WHEREVER THEY ARISE WHEN THEY
COME INTO COUNTIES AND- ARE
BROUGHT FORWARD ON THESE CASES.
THEY WILL RECEIVE FAIR AND
PUBLIC JURY TRIALS IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE LAW. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS CONCERNED. WITH WEBER
. GOOD MORNING- SO I- I JUST
HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT- THE
LANGUAGE SO WE KEEP TALKING
ABOUT THE FACT THAT WE'RE
FOCUSING ON ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT WHICH I COMPLETELY GET- IT
SAYS THIS BILL WOULD
ADDITIONALLY ESTABLISH THE
JURISDICTION OF A CRIMINAL
ACTION FOR THEFT. ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT OR RECEIPT OF
STOLEN PROPERTY NEVADA SO IT.
HOW DO IT DOESN'T SPECIFICALLY
SAY ONLY ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
SO WHY ARE WE FOCUSING JUST ON
ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT WHEN
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT IT BUT
THAT'S NOT WHAT IT STATES
HEARING ABOUT. THE BILL IS AIMED
AT ADDRESSING- THE SAME
DEFENDANTS. THE SAME TYPE OF
MERCHANDISE AND THE THEFT OF
WHICH IS DONE ACCORDING TO A
COMMON PLAN OR SCHEME. HENCE THE
SOPHISTICATION HENCE THE
ORGANIZED NATURE OF THE CRIME SO
YOU'RE LOOKING AT SIMILAR
PATTERNS OF CONDUCT ACROSS
COUNTIES ACROSS JURISDICTIONAL
LINES. THAT'S WHY WE CALL IT A
WAR T. NOW. THERE'S LANGUAGE
THAT WAS ADDED ABOUT WHAT WE
CALL THE ATTENDANT- PEACE IS A
CRIME THAT WOULD MOST LIKELY BE
FOR EXAMPLE PERHAPS A CONSPIRACY
CHARGE IT MAY BE A GRAND THEFT
FORTY SEVEN ABOVE THE VALUE OF
NINE FIFTY THAT WOULD REQUIRE
THE PERMISSION OF THE ENTITY
FROM WHICH WE ARE TAKING HE
CASE- VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT'S IN
LAW AT SEVEN EIGHTY FOUR POINT
SEVEN OF THE PENAL CODE. SO
THERE IS A SAFEGUARD IF WE GO
BEYOND SIMPLY THE ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT WE HAVE TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THAT OTHER
JURISDICTION AND SAY. MISTER OR
MISS DA DO WE HAVE YOUR
AUTHORITY TO TAKE THAT CASE
BECAUSE IT FALLS OUTSIDE THE
STRICT LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
RIGHT NOW SO IT'S A GOOD
PRECAUTIONARY MEASURE. I GUESS
MY CONCERN IS- WITH IT BEING
MORE PRIDE THAT YOU CAN PULL IN
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT NECESSARILY A
PART OF THE ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT AND I'M HOPING THAT
THERE'S SOME LEGAL DEFINITION OF
IT SOMEWHERE. WHAT EXACTLY
ENTAILS ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
LIKE A CERTAIN NUMBER AND YOU
KNOW PROOF THAT PEOPLE HAVE
ACTUALLY GOTTEN TOGETHER AND
IT'S NOT JUST. SOMEONE WHO
HAPPENED TO GO IN AND- STILL
SOMETHING UNFORTUNATE FROM A
RETAILER. HE HAD THE BEST GUIDE
TO ENSURE THAT ASSEMBLY WOMAN
WEBER WOULD BE LOOK AT THE
LANGUAGE OF FOUR NINETY POINT
FOUR- YOU KNOW. INDIVIDUALS
ACTING IN CONCERT THAT'S
IMPORTANT HAS TO BE SOME
COORDINATION SOME PLANNING
BETWEEN THE TWO OF THEM- THERE
HAS TO BE USUALLY SIMILAR
MERCHANDISE THAT'S TAKEN. COMMON
PLANS OR SCHEMES THAT IS THEY'RE
USING THE SAME MODUS OPERANDI
HI. IN DIFFERENT COUNTIES IN
DIFFERENT STORES BUT THE SAME
AMMO IS EMPLOYED. HMM AND ALSO
THE SAME DEFENSE YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE BASICALLY EXAMINING THE
SAME CONDUCT COMMITTED BY THE
SAME PEOPLE IT JUST HAPPENS TO
GO ACROSS COUNTY LINES. AND
HAPPEN IN MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS
BECAUSE AS WE ALL KNOW WAS
CALIFORNIANS THERE'S A VAST
FREEWAY NETWORK SO IF THEY WANT
TO TARGET HOME DEPOTS THEY'RE
GONNA GO TO MULTIPLE HOME DEPOTS
IN MULTIPLE COUNTIES. WHICH IS
WHY THIS BILL IS SO URGENT NEED
SO THIS BILL WOULD ONLY APPLY
TO. PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN DEEMED
TO HAVE DONE THIS MULTIPLE TIMES
NOT JUST ONE TIME. SURE YEAH I
MEAN THIS IS. THIS IS GOING
AFTER A SERIAL ISSUE IT'S NOT A
ONE TIME ACT IT'S HAPPENING IN
OTHER COUNTIES NOT ONLY BEEN
TURRETS WHAT THIS DOES FOR
JUDICIAL ECONOMY AND TO PRESERVE
SCARCE JUDICIAL RESOURCES. IS
BRING THAT CASE INTO OUR COUNTY
THAT AROSE AND SAMPOERNA DINO
RIVERSIDE OR ELSEWHERE OR SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. BECAUSE OTHERWISE
YOU HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO HAVE
FOUR DIFFERENT PROSECUTIONS IN
FOUR DIFFERENT COUNTIES AND I
ALSO WOULD SUBMIT TO YOU IF
YOU'RE THE DEFENDANT. THEN YOU
TOO COULD BE PROSECUTED SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND THEN YOU MAY BE
IN CUSTODY OR CONVICTED THEN
THERE'S AN ORDER FOR PRODUCTION
FOR YOU TO APPEAR NOW IN LA
COUNTY. SO YOU KNOW THIS GOES
BOTH WAYS. OKAY MISTER BRYANT.
I'LL BE QUICK UP STRUGGLING WITH
THIS BILL ACCENT OF THE AT THE
AUTHOR'S INTENTIONS- WHAT'S TO
PREVENT- DISTRICT ATTORNEY FROM
FROM STACKING CHARGES THAT OTHER
DA'S WOULDN'T HAVE FILED BECAUSE
THEY DON'T BELIEVE THAT THERE
AND THE INTEREST OF PUBLIC
SAFETY. WE DON'T STACK- BECAUSE-
THAT MAY BE THE WRONG LANGUAGE
WILL LET'S SAY THAT THERE ARE
MULTIPLE THINGS THAT HAPPEN IN
MULTIPLE JURISDICTIONS WITH SAN
DIEGO COUNTY. DOESN'T FEEL THAT
IN A RISE TO THE LEVEL OF FILED
A CASE WITH VENTURA WOULD LIKE
TO ADD WHAT HAPPENED SAN DIEGO
TO ITS CASE. WHAT'S TO PREVENT
THAT FROM HAPPENING IRRESPECTIVE
OF THE DA'S DISCRETION IN THOSE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS. YOU KNOW
IT'S SAN DIEGO DECIDED TO TAKE A
PASS ON IT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT OUR OFFICE WOULD CONSIDER
IT WOULD BE PROBATIVE AND
RELEVANT IN OUR EXAMINATION
PREVENT YOU FROM ADDING. NO
AGREE TO SOME A NUMBER BUT YOU
KNOW WE FREQUENTLY SPEAK TO ONE
ANOTHER WE'RE ALL COLLEAGUES IN
THIS PROFESSION SO WE WOULD.
SPEAK TO THE DA IN THAT COUNTY
AND SAY. WHY DID YOU NOT FILE
WHAT WAS THE INFIRMITY OF THIS
CASE WAS THERE SOME ISSUE THAT
WE NEED TO BE AWARE OF AND WERE
FREQUENTLY IN CONTACT WITH ONE
ANOTHER. SO ONE OF THE GUARD
RAILS WERE THE PRECAUTION SOME
PLACES. YOU KNOW IF ANOTHER
ENTITY HAS PASSED ON IT WE WANT
TO KNOW WHY AND THAT WOULD BE
PROBATIVE AND RELEVANT OUR
ANALYSIS WHETHER OR NOT WE
PERCEIVE. THANK BECAUSE THE
QUESTIONS ARE CONCERNED. SHE
GAVE ME YOU MAY CLOSE. OF
CLOSING I SIMPLY WANT TO REMIND
THE COMMITTEE THAT AB SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN IS SIMPLY PROVIDING A
TOOL FOR PROSECUTORS TO BRING
JUSTICE- THAT TO BRING JUSTICE
TO THEFT RINGS WHO DESIGNED
THEIR SCHEMES TO CROSS
JURISDICTIONAL LINES. AND USE
THE LIMITS OF PROSECUTORS
AGAINST THEM EVADING EVEN BEING
CHARGED WITH THEIR CRIMES WHILE
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SPEAKS
MAKING A TRIAL CONVENIENT FOR
DEFENDANTS- AS DEPUTY DA NAS
RECORD MENTIONED. I WOULD PREFER
THAT SAID THIS LEGISLATURE ACT
TO EFFECTIVELY AND EFFICIENTLY
COMBAT ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT IN
CALIFORNIA THE SAME WAY THAT IT
DID IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU ON. AND I GUESS
FOR PEOPLE ARE LISTENING AND-
JUSTIN AND JUSTIN MAKING SURE IN
FULL DISCLOSURE. WHEN YOU SAY
FORTY. FOUR NINETY POINT FOUR.
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MY BILL YES
WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
AUTHOR CORRECT OF THE BILL.
DEFINITELY KNOWS THE INTENT THE
PURPOSE. I ACTUALLY WROTE. BUT
I'M ALSO THE ONE THAT TOOK OUT
WHICH YOU WANT TO PUT BACK IN.
FOR VERY GOOD REASON. AGAIN. THE
PERSON THAT DID THIS AND WHEN I
DID THIS BILL. FOR ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT. I REMEMBER LAW
ENFORCEMENT DA'S INCLUDE SAID IT
WOULDN'T WORK WE SHOULDN'T DO IT
YOU'RE A GUEST. UNBELIEVABLY
AGAINST IT AND IT TOOK A LOT OF
ARM TWISTING PART OF THAT
NEGOTIATION WITH ADDING IN THIS
PROVISION SO IT LEASE GET IT
STARTED SIR WE GET C. H. P.
TOGETHER TO START AGGREGATING
AND WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
CROSS JURISDICTIONS. WOULD BE
ABLE TO PROSECUTE. OVER THOSE
YEARS- LAW ENFORCEMENT IN REALLY
PARTICIPATE- HELP C. H. P. IN
THIS EFFORT- I DON'T KNOW IF
BECAUSE- DO YOU WANT TO DO IT
THEIR WAY BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY WE HAVE SOMETHING IN PLACE
THAT DOES WHAT YOU WANT TO. DO
MUCH TO. MY SURPRISE OVER THE
SUMMER. WHEN WE- AFTER WE
DECIDED TO. EXTEND ORGANIZED
RETAIL THEFT PUTIN ANOTHER FIVE
MILLION TO KEEP C. H. P. ON TOP
OF IT. THE GOVERNOR OF THE STATE
OVER TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
INTO THIS EFFORT BECAUSE COULD
HAVE YOUR SAY. THIS IS A THIS IS
REALLY REALLY IMPORTANT AND WE
REALLY HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF IT
SOMETHING I WANTED TO DO. YEARS
BEFORE. WHAT'S BEEN GOING ON
RIGHT NOW- AND IN FACT I THINK.
AND I MAY BE WRONG AND STAFF
PROBABLY CAN CHECK. MY BILL MAY
BE THE ONLY NEW FELONY DOES COME
TO THIS COMMITTEE SINCE I'VE
BEEN ON HERE. SO THAT ALSO TELL
YOU HOW IMPORTANT IT IS TO THIS
COMMITTEE AS A WHOLE AND HOW
IMPORTANT IT IS THAT WE GO AFTER
WOULD YOU CALL THE REAL
CRIMINALS THE MASTERMIND THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE. ARE PULLING ALL
THIS TOGETHER. SO NOT ONLY DID
WE CREATE A LAW. NOT ONLY DO WE
FIX THE LAW NO NEED WE PUT FIVE
MILLION INTO IT NOT ONLY DO WE
PUT ANOTHER TWO HUNDRED MILLION.
WE'RE NOW TRYING TO WORK WITH
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE.
WHICH JUST STARTED TO BE ABLE TO
DO WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT.
TAKE THOSE CASES IN TODAY
AGGREGATE SO WE CAN MOVE FORWARD
WITH IT. WHAT WHAT I'M GOING TO
OFFER. BECAUSE I THINK AT THE
END OF THE DAY WE'RE NOT WORKING
IN A COLLABORATIVE WAY. DA'S
WHEN THEY DO THEIR OWN THING
POLICE DEPARTMENT DO THEIR WAY-
I HAVE MUCH. THE CHP DOING
SOMETHING AND NOW WE'RE GOING TO
ASK D. A. THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO DO SOMETHING ELSE BECAUSE WE
ALL. M. BECAUSE WORKING IN
SILOS. WOULD PROBABLY GONNA GET
THE SAME RESULT THAT WE GET AS A
WORK IN SILOS ON THE HOMELESS
PROBLEM WE HAVE ENOUGH MONEY WE
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES WE HAVE IN
THE PROGRAMS WE HAVE ALL OF THAT
BUT WE CAN'T GET IT DONE. YOU
KNOW WHY BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
WORKING IN A COLLABORATIVE.
EFFORT WHAT I WOULD OFFER IS-
SHOULD THIS BILL. NOT MAKE IT
THAT WE DON'T LET IT DIE HERE.
THAT WE ACTUALLY FOR THE FIRST
TIME. BRING THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
. C. H. P. THE D. A.'S AND THE
POLICE AND HAVE FIVE TO CONVENE
LIKE US IN A ROOM WE ALL COME
TOGETHER AND COME UP WITH ONE
PLAN. LIKE YOU SAID WITH ONE
INDIVIDUAL IN CHARGE YOU CAN'T
HAVE ALL THESE MULTIPLE. YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THE REASON WHY
TO SEIZE P. WORKS BECAUSE CHP IS
DOING IT BY THEMSELVES AND
THEY'RE GETTING IT DONE LOOK AT
THEIR ARREST RECORD LOOK AT
THEIR SUCCESS RECORD IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE IS OFF THE CHARTS
BUT THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE KIND
OF. THEY'RE NOT GETTING. THE
CREDIT THAT THEY NEED THEY DID
DESERVE TO SHOW THAT. AND AGAIN
IN FULL DISCLOSURE IT IS MY BILL
THAT THE ORGANIZED RETAILS THE
BILL DOES WORK. I'LL SAY IT
AGAIN THE ORGANIZED RETAIL THEFT
BILL MY BILL DOES WORK- AND SO I
I'M SAYING WE NEED TO WORK
TOGETHER. AND BRING IT ALL BACK
IN TOGETHER SO THAT- IF IT
DOESN'T PASS YOU ASK FOR
RECONSIDERATION. AND IN THAT
RECONSIDERATION WE COME BACK
AGAIN WE CAN WORK ON OUR
ULTIMATE SOLUTION. THAT WILL GET
RID OF THE SCOURGE. IN A IN A
MORE COMPREHENSIVE WAY AND THAT
WE ATTACK IT TOGETHER. NOT A
PART BECAUSE THE OTHER PART OF
THAT WHICH IS THE OPPOSITION
CONCERNED ABOUT. STACKING AND
YOU KNOW YOU COULD ASK RODNEY
KING ABOUT BEING. GOING TO SEAMY
VALLEY. THEY HAVE JUSTICE BEING
DONE IT IN QUITE WORK FOR HIM.
SO THAT IS THE ULTIMATE CONCERN
IS A CONCERN THAT THIS COULD BE
USED AGAINST. PROGRESSIVE D.
A.'S BUT YOU DON'T DO YOUR JOB
WE'RE GOING TO RUN IT FOR YOU
YES THAT'S NOT THE WAY WE CAN'T
WE HAVE STOPPED DOING THIS WE
JUST GOT WE JUST GOT TO STOP
BECAUSE THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT
SUFFER. ARE NOT ONLY RETAILERS
BUT THE PUBLIC AT LARGE AND SO-
I'M I'M OFFERING TO MAKE THAT
HAPPEN- ONCE AND FOR ALL. AND SO
THAT WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER AS A
TEAM. AS PARTNERS IN. SO WE CAN
ULTIMATELY- HAVE A COORDINATED
ATTACKAGAINST ORGANIZED RETAIL
THEFT SO WE CAN ELIMINATED IN
CALIFORNIA AT LEAST AND BE THE
LEADERS AND ELIMINATED GOING
FORWARD AND FORTUNATELY I.
ASKING FOR NO VOTE. ON AB
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN BY THE MEMBER
IRWIN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
JONES SAWYER NO JONES SAWYER NO
LACKEY HI LACKEY HI. ABSTAINED
BONTA ABSTAINED BRIAN ABSTAINED
BRIAN ABSTAINED WEBER. WEBER
ABSTAINED SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
ABSTAINED SMITH SMITH I. I'M
SORRY THAT MEASURE FAILS BUT IT
HASN'T FAILED IF YOU TAKE ME UP
ON MY OFFER YEAH WELL I WILL ASK
FOR RECONSIDERATION AT GRANITE
RIKEN OKAY AND IF THERE IS NO
OBJECTION WE WILL GRANT THIS
BILL RECONSIDERATION BY
UNANIMOUS. CONSENT THANK YOU.
MAIENSCHEIN AB SIXTEEN FORTY ONE
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS. I
REMEMBER NINE. THANK THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
SIXTEEN FORTY ONE CODIFIES
EXISTING BEST PRACTICE THAT
REQUIRE SEXUALLY VIOLENT
PREDATORS TO BE GPS MONITORED
WHILE ON CONDITIONAL RELEASE.
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS OR SB
PEAS ARE PERSONS HAVE COMMITTED
CRIMINAL SEXUAL OFFENSES AND
I'VE BEEN FOUND BY THE COURT TO
BE PREDISPOSED TO RE OFFEND.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE CIVILLY
COMMITTED TO A STATE HOSPITAL
FOR TREATMENT SOME SB PIECE
QUALIFY FOR CONDITIONAL RELEASE
INTO THE COMMUNITY WHILE THEY
CONTINUE TO RAISE RECEIVE
TREATMENT UNDER THEIR CIVIL
COMMITMENT. IS EXISTING
PRACTICES STATE ITS CONTRACTORS
TO USE TWENTY FOUR HOUR GPS
MONITORING HOWEVER THERE ISNO
STATUTORY REQUIREMENT THAT
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATORS BE
GPS MONITORED AB SIXTEEN FORTY
ONE CODIFIES THIS REGIONAL
MEASURE TO PROTECT PUBLIC SAFETY
THANK AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. SHARE OF THE BILL.
SECOND. ARE ANY WITNESSES IN A
ROOM IN SUPPORT. IN THE ROOM OR
OUTSIDE THE ROOM. KAMALA
TOMORROW IN. SOCIALIST.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. NOW WILL
GO TO AT&T LINE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB SIXTEEN
FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE TO
TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW
HERE FOR WITNESSES IN A ROOM IN
OPPOSITION I THINK I HAVE KATHY
SURE TESTIFYING IN PERSON. GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
KATHY SURE FOR THE ACLU ACLU
CALIFORNIA ACTION- WE
RESPECTFULLY MUST PROPOSED
EIGHTY SIXTEEN FORTY ONE- I WANT
TO START BY THANKING THE AUTHOR
FOR THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN MADE TO THE BILL AND HIS
RESPONSIVENESS TO CONCERNS THATHAVE BEEN RAISED- THAT SAID. WE
REMAIN OPPOSED TO WHAT IS LEFT
IN THE BILL A REQUIREMENT THAT-EVERY INDIVIDUAL PLACED ON
CONDITIONAL RELEASE UNDER THE S.
V. P. LAW BE SUBJECT TO GPS
MONITORING FOR THE ENTIRE PERIOD
THEY REMAIN ON CONDITIONAL
RELEASE. A PERSON COMMITTED FOR
TREATMENT UNDER THE S. B. P. LA
MUST GO THROUGH A GREAT DEAL TO
BE ABLE TO BE RELEASED ON
CONDITIONAL RELEASE. THEY'VE
ALREADY COMPLETED A PRISON
SENTENCE THEN THEY HAVE SPENT
YEARS UNDERGOING TREATMENT WHILE
CONFINED AT THE COALINGA STATE
HOSPITAL. THE PERSON MUST BE
FOUND BY A COURT NO LONGER TO
POSE A DANGER TO THE PUBLIC
BEFORE THEY CAN BE RELEASED. AND
EVEN THEN IS SUBJECT TO
STRINGENT REQUIREMENTS AS TO
WHERE THEY CAN LIVE. AND REMAINS
UNDER TREATMENT AND SUPERVISION
FOR THE PERIOD OF CONDITIONAL
RELEASE WHICH DOES NOT END UNTIL
THE COURT FINDS THAT THE PERSON
CAN SAFELY BE UNCONDITIONALLY
DISCHARGED. EXISTING LAW ALREADY
PROVIDES THAT ALL PERSONS ON
CONDITIONAL RELEASE ARE SUBJECT
TO SUPERVISION. THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT ENSURING THAT THEY WILL BE
SUPERVISED. THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES FOR EVERY
PERSON ON CONDITIONAL RELEASE
AND FOR THE ENTIRE PERIOD OF
CONDITIONAL RELEASE. THAT THEY
BE SUBJECT TO GPS MONITORING.
ALTHOUGH THAT IS THE CURRENT
PRACTICE IT IS NOT CURRENTLY
REQUIRED BY STATUTE AND IT
SHOULD NOT BE. DIFFERENT PEOPLE
PRESENT DIFFERENT CIRCUMSTANCES
AND HAVE DIFFERENT SUPERVISION
NEEDS. GPS IS NOT NECESSARY FOR
EVERY INDIVIDUAL OR BENEFICIAL
TO THEIR TREATMENT. IMPOSING IT
ON TO IT FOR EVERYONE ON
CONDITIONAL RELEASE LOCKS IN A
PRACTICE. THAT NEEDLESSLY
INCREASES COSTS TO THE STATE
WHILE PLACING UNNECESSARY
BURDENS ON THOSE WHO COULD BE
ADEQUATELY SUPERVISED WITHOUT
IT. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
NO VOTE. THANK YOU- ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN A ROOM IN
OPPOSITION. ANYONE OUTSIDE THE
ROOM. AT&T OPERATOR WILL GO TO
THE LINES OF FOR OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO AB SIXTEEN
FORTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AT
THE END ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS
CONCERNS COMMENTS. CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
TONIGHT BUT- I HAVE A MOTION TO
APPROVE IS THEIR SECOND. IT WAS
OKAY. INSPECTOR CALL THE ROLL.
ON AB SIXTEEN FORTY ONE BY SEVEN
MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN THE MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER IRAQI LACKEY I BONTA
BONTA HI BRIAN BRIAN HI WEBER
WEBER ICE SANTIAGO. SMITH SMITH
I. THAT MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU
THANK YOU. LET'S SEE IF I RUN
OUT OF ASSEMBLY MEMBERS. I HAVE
ITEM ELEVEN MCCARTY ITEM
THIRTEEN RODRIGUEZ. MR MCCARTY
THANK YOU- ITEM SEVENTEEN WAR I
MEAN I SEVENTEEN WALDRON IN
EIGHTEEN WARD. MMHM. AND THEN
I'M LAST JONES SAWYER A. B.
EIGHTEEN OH THREE. LET'S GO- THE
PASADENA. OOPS THANK YOU WHAT IT.
THANK YOU MR LACKEY. CHAIR
MEMBERS I PRESENT AB EIGHTEEN OH
THREE WHICH STREAMLINES THE
ABILITY TO PAY PROCESS BY
GUARANTEEING EXPUNGEMENT FEES
AWAY FOR INDIVIDUALS WITH LOW
INCOME CURRENTLY INDIVIDUALS WHO
PETITION FOR EXPUNGEMENT CAN
HAVE THEIR COURT FEES WAIVED IF
THEY PROVED AT A SEPARATE
HEARING THEY DO NOT HAVE THE
ABILITY TO PAY SUCH FEES DUE TO
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP OUR CURRENT
ABILITY TO PAY PROCESS BOTH ADDS
TO COURTS OPERATIONAL COSTS AND
PER PROLONGS THE EXPUNGEMENT
PROCESS AS WELL AS INCREASES
FINANCIAL BURDENS. TO
PETITIONERS ESPECIALLY THOSE
LIVING IN POVERTY AT A COURT
FEES NOT ONLY FAILED TO BE
ALLOCATED TOWARDS REHABILITATIVE
PURPOSES BUT OUR STATE HAS ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGED ONLY A FRACTION OF
FEES END UP BEING COLLECTED DUE
TO INDIVIDUALS INDIVIDUALS
INABILITY TO PAY BY CAROTENE IS
COURT FEE AB EIGHTEEN OH THREE
NOT ONLY BRING PARITY TO THE
CURRENT PRACTICE OF PROVIDING
FINANCIAL RELIEF TO HAVE BEEN TO
IT INDIVIDUALS WITH LOW INCOME.
BUT ALSO REMOVED THE OPERATIONAL
COSTS OF HOLDING AN INABILITY TO
PAY HEARING WHICH IS CENTURIES
OFTEN THE SAME OUTCOME. WITH ME
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN OH THREE IS THE BILL'S
SPONSOR KEVIN. ABOUT THE BUT YOU
NAME A SOFT GOING ON A- LOGMEIN
THAT COULD DIRECTOR OF COALITION
CALIFORNIA WELFARE RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION. AND I HAVE MIX
STEWART OPEN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION THAT. GOOD MORNING-
THIS IS MY FIRST TIME. BACK FROM
MARCH FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY-
THE SPACE TO BE BACK AT THE
TABLE. AB WITH THIS BILL WE ASK
FOR THIS BILL BECAUSE- WE WORK
WITH CALVERT'S RECIPIENT OF MANY
OF THEM GO TO THE WELFARE TO
WORK PROGRAM THAT WOULD SPEND
ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS IN
AFTER THEY GET THEIR TRAINING
THEY GO OUT THAT THEY CAN'T GET
A JOB BECAUSE THEY HAVE THE-
THIS CRIMINAL TOUGH- CONVICTION
ON THEIR RECORD. AND EXPUNGEMENT
IS ONE WAY TO GET RID OF THAT SO
THEY COULD GET A JOB AND THEN
START ACTUALLY PAYING
RESTITUTION THAT THEY MAY ALL
AND WE JUST WANT TO OPEN UP A
WAY FOR PEOPLE TO BE PREPARED.
TO GET A JOB AND START PAYING
RESTITUTION ALSO WOULD SIMPLIFY
THE PLUSES VERY THAN HAVING
EVERY DIFFERENT COURT TO COME UP
WITH DIFFERENT PROCESSES WILL
HAVE ONE WHO ALIGN PLUSES THAT
WOULD BENEFIT THE SYSTEM AND
SIMPLIFY THE PROCESS OF FLUID.
TO RIVAL THANK YOU. HERE AS A
PRESS ARE ON THE PHONE WAS ON
THE PHONE. THIS IS NEXT DOOR TO
AND CAN YOU HEAR ME MISTER CARE
YES CAN HEAR YOU YOU MAY PROCEED
EXCEPT. I CAN MORNING MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS NEXT
DOOR TO ANNOUNCED. TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION. CURRENT
LAW ALLOWS A FORMER DEFENDANT
WHO PERFORMS FLAWLESSLY ON
PROBATION TO SEEK AND OBTAIN
EXPANSION FROM THE COURT.
WELCOME TO YOU DOES NOT PREVENT
THE FENCE FROM BEING USED AS A
PRIOR THAT PERSONALLY OFFENSIVE
DOES NOT TERMINATE A PERSON'S
OBLIGATION TO PAY VICTIM
RESTITUTION IT DOES HELP OF
FORMALLY CONVICTED PERSON SEEK
LICENSURE. FIND HOUSING AND
PERHAPS MOST IMPORTANTLY FIND A
JOB. THE PROMISE UNDER CURRENT
LAW AN IMPOVERISHED DEFEND IS
NOT ENTITLED TO AN EXPUNGEMENT
WILL VICTIM RESTITUTION IS STILL
OWED. WHAT THAT RULE WITH THE
NEW REGIONALLY INTENDED TO
PROMOTE THE PAYMENT VICTIM
RESTITUTION BECAUSE THIS WILL
PREVENT DEFENSE REFINING WORK IT
HAS IN PRACTICE HAD THE OPPOSITE
EFFECT. BRING THE SAID ANOTHER
WAY TO PAY RESTITUTION OF FORMER
DEFENDANT NEED THE JOB TO GET A
JOB FOR PARTISAN THAT NEEDS AN
EXPUNGEMENT. UNDER CURRENT LAW
YOU CAN'T GET A JOB UNTIL YOU
GET AN EXPUNGEMENT. IF THIS
SOUNDS A LITTLE LIKE CATCH
TWENTY TWO THAT BECAUSE IT IS.
WORTH AS A SOCIETY WE'RE DOING
HERSELF NO FAVORS BY PUTTING
BARRIERS TO RE ENTRY IN FRONT OF
FORMERLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACTUALLY LOOKING FOR WORK
AND TRYING TO START OVER. AB TWO
THREE ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY
GIVING FORMER DEFENSE THE RIGHT
TO EXPUNGEMENT IF THEY HAVE
PERFORMED FLAWLESSLY ON
PROBATION FOR PREVIOUSLY UNABLE
TO PAY RESTITUTION. AS A RESULT
IN THE TNC. A BEACON TO DOES NOT
TERMINATE DEPENDENCE OBLIGATION
TO PAY RESTITUTION IN FACT LEADS
EXISTING LEGAL PROVISIONS IN
PLACE THAT ALLOW VICTIMS TO
GARNISH ANY EVENTUAL SALARY
EARNED BY THE DEFENDANT. BECAUSE
EIGHTEEN OH THREE EASES THE PATH
TOWARD REENTRY FOR CALIFORNIANS
SEEKING TO START AGAIN AND
BECAUSE IT INCREASES THE CHANCE
OF THE VICTIMS WAX RECEIVE
COMPENSATION FOR ANY LOSS. IT'S
A SMART LONG OVERDUE POLICY AND
FOR THAT REASON WE HAVE HERE
I'VE- THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU. OKAY OF COURSE YOU
HAVE IT I'M SORRY SO GOOD. WHAT
THIS IS IN SUPPORT OF THE ROOM
YOU MAY PRESS BARCODE ON THE OF
THE- PUBLIC DEFENDER THIS. AND
SOME THANK YOU THANK YOU. DANYCH
ORDER MOM HALF OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
SUPPORT. GIVE. SERIK ME ON
BEHALF OF INITIATE JUSTICE IN
STRONG SUPPORT YOU. A LITTLE ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIANS FOR
SAFETY AND JUSTICE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NO PHONE.
OKAY AT&T OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR LIKE
TO EXPRESS THAT SUPPORT. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF AB
EIGHTEEN OH THREE PLEASE PRESS
ONE TO TEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHY ONE TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NO WONDER WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU EVERYONE MORE
IT'LL JUST BE ONE MOMENT. TWO
MORE IN Q. I AM THIRTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. REBECA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
TWENTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I HAVE ONE MORE THAT
JUST QUEUED UP IT'LL JUST BE ONE
SECOND HERE.
I WON TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THE TWO CANNOT BECOME
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA CALLING
IN IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. INSTEAD OF THAT MAJOR
PROBLEM OF ALL OF US IN AN
ORANGE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RYAN FIFTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS FAVOURITE I'M CALLING
IN OF US TO NONE OF THE ACCIDENT
AND I IN STRONG. FOR THANK YOU
HAVE NO FURTHER COME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. I DO HAVE A WHAT IN
OPPOSITION. I DON'T SEE ANY. ANY
ON THE PHONE LINES. ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE RELIGIOUS PRESSURE
DROP THEIR OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES THEY MAY DO SO NOW.
ZERO IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO AB EIGHTEEN OH
THREE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU. CAN YOU HAVE ANYBODY
IN THE ROOM THAT WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION I DON'T SEE
ANY. OKAY I'LL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE. ANY COMMENTS OF THE
BILL. OKAY OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION
A SECOND I JUST WANT TO SAY REAL
QUICKLY AND I DO BELIEVE THAT
PAYMENT OF COURT ORDERED
RESTITUTION TO THE VICTIM.
REALLY IS AN ESSENTIAL ELEMENT
OF SHOWING SUCCESSFUL COMPLETION
OF PROBATION SO I WON'T BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT YOUR MEASUREMENT. AT
THE GREATER CALL FOR THE
QUESTION. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. SORRY ABOUT THE
CLOTHES. ON AB EIGHTEEN OH THREE
BY THE MEMBER JONES SAWYER THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER I JUST SAW YOUR LACKEY
LACKEY KNELT BONTA BONTA HI
BRIAN HI BRIAN HI WEBER WEBER I
SAN DIEGO. SMITH. THEY SMITH
OBTAINED. THAT MEASURES ON
COLONY TO CONQUER THANK YOU.
OKAY THAT MEASURE LOCAL YOU NEED
ONE MORE. WELCOME BACK THANK YOU
COULD YOU FOR THE. OKAY YEAH-
FIVE HUNDRED ELEVEN THE ITEM
NUMBER ELEVEN MCCARTY A. B.
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT. MA'AM I
GAVEL BACK. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I WAS AT CHARING-
COMMITTEE. FOR THE BUDGET JUST
UPSTAIRS AND- CAN WE BACK
CARILLO COZY IN HERE YES. ALL
I'M HERE PRESENT A BILL THAT
THAT- YOU YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR
WITH THIS WAS- HEARD LAST YEAR
STARTED IN THIS COMMITTEE WE HAD
A RIGOROUS DEBATE ON THIS ISSUE-
SINCE WE STARTED THAT DEBATE A
WEEK A YEAR AGO I WILL SAY THAT
WE TOOK ROUGHLY FIFTY AMENDMENTS
TO THIS AFTER HEARING FROM FIFTY
AFTER HEARING FROM TO PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEES TO HELP
COMMITTEES TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEES AND COUNTLESS
MEETINGS WITH ADVOCATE SO I KNOW
THAT THERE'S SOME CONSTERNATION
ON THIS OVERALL TOPIC BUT WE
HAVE LISTEN TO PEOPLE. AND TRY
TO MAKE IT BETTER THE BIG
PICTURE IS WE HAVE AN ISSUE WITH
OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM AND
DRUG ADDICTION AND WE KNOW THAT
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER AS A
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUE NOT A PUBLIC
SAFETY ISSUE AND PEOPLE DON'T
GET TREATMENT IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM FRANKLY SOMETIMES
THEY COME OUT BEING BETTER DRUG
ADDICTS AFTER INCARCERATION NOT
NOT NOT ADDRESSING THEIR THEIR
HABIT UNFORTUNATELY SO THIS IS
AN INNOVATIVE PILOT PROGRAM
WHICH WILL ALLOW THREE COUNTIES
THAT AT THE MINIMUM RIGHT NOW
THREE IN CALIFORNIA SANTA CLARA
AND SAN JOAQUIN IN YELLOW. TO
PROVIDE TEMPORARY CAN FIND DRUG
TREATMENT OPTION FOR QUALIFYING
INDIVIDUALS AGAIN- THIS IS A
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM AND JUDGES
WILL BE ABLE TO OFFER THIS TO
INDIVIDUALS WHO WANT TO
PARTICIPATE AT THE
RECOMMENDATION OF TREATMENT
PROVIDERS- THIS IS- MEANT TO
PROVIDE. ANOTHER OPTION FOR
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE IN THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. WHO RIP
WHO RIGHT NOW ARE GETTING- WHO
ARE NOT PROVIDE WHO ARE NOT
GETTING ADEQUATE TREATMENT THAT
THEY NEED TO DEAL WITH OR
SUBSTANCE ABUSE DISORDER. THIS
IS EVIDENCE BASED WHICH WE
CLARIFIED OVER AND OVER- THESE
ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT WILL BE
SENTENCED OTHERWISE TO GO TO
EITHER A STATE PRISON OR COUNTY
JAIL FOR A FOR A SENTENCE THESE
ARE INDIVIDUALS OTHERWISE WOULD
BE GOING HOME. WITH AN ANKLE
BRACELET AND IT'S SOME IT'S VERY
SIMPLE- THIS IS AN OPTION AN
INDIVIDUAL CAN GO SERVE THEIR
SENTENCE OR THE COOPER BE
PROVIDED WITH THE CHOICE TO GO
GET TREATMENT IF THEY CHOOSE TO
DO SO. WE CLARIFY HERE AT THAT
DISCRETION AB AND THAT THAT THE
DIRECTION OF THE SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE LAST YEAR. THAT
THE TREATMENT WOULDN'T BE NO
LONGER WITH THEN YOU'RE SET THEN
YOU'RE UNDERLYING SENTENCE IF
YOU DID GO THE ROUTE FOR
INCARCERATIONS IN OTHER WORDS
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO. BE LONGER
IN THIS BY DOING- THE DRUG
TREATMENTS- YOU KNOW SOMEONE SAY
THAT THIS IS NOT. 100% VOLUNTARY
ITS IT'S- CO WORSE I DON'T KNOW
IT'S KIND OF IT'S ENCOURAGED
CAJOLED AND SOME SAY THAT YOU
KNOW. VOLUNTARY IS OUT 100% THE
WAY TO GO BUT I DON'T KNOW I
THINK SOME MANY OF YOU AND YOUR
FAMILIES OF HEARD ABOUT
INTERVENTIONS. THAT'S NOT ALWAYS
VOLUNTARY WHEN FAMILY MEMBERS GO
TO SOMEONE AND SAY HEY. WE HAVE
A PROBLEM HERE WE NEED YOU TO.
SOMEONE TO STEP IT UP SOMETIME
PEOPLE SAY. NO OVER AND OVER AND
FINALLY THEY SAY YES SOMETIMES
THEY SAY YES AND THEY FAIL. BUT
THEY GOT BUT EVENTUALLY- THEY
ARE ABLE TO GET HELP AND SO WE
KNOW THAT THE CURRENT SYSTEM. IS
NOT WORKING THIS IS THIS IS NOT
THE SAME AS WHAT THE GOVERNOR
TALKED ABOUT LAST WEEK WITH
CONSERVATORSHIP. BUT THE SAME
SIMILAR ISSUE WE KNOW THAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IS FAILING WAY
TOO MANY PEOPLE WHO GO THROUGH-
THE SYSTEM. AND UNFORTUNATELY GO
BACK TO THE TO THE STREETS. AS
AS UNDERLYING DRUG ADDICTS AND
HAVE. ISSUES WITH THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM OVER AND OVER.
WINDOWS IS A COMPLEX ISSUE THIS
IS A PILOT. IT'S A SHORT TERM
PILOT ALLOWS US TO TRY THIS- TRY
THIS OUT IN A NUMBER OF
COUNTIES. AND WE THINK THIS WILL
PRODUCE. RESULTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA IS A GOOD PLACE TO
START- THIS WAS VETOED LAST YEAR
BY THE GOVERNOR. HE DID ADDRESS
SOME CONCERNS IN A VETO MESSAGE
SO WE IF WE HAVE SENSE. I MET
WITH THE ADVOCATES AND THE
ANALYSIS NOTES ON PAGE SEVEN WE
DO MAKE SOME CHANGES OUT OF THE
GATE- CLARIFY. THAT- THE
INDIVIDUAL B. THAT KNOWINGLY AND
FOCUSING ON THIS THIS THIS
DECISION WHAT THEY'RE ABOUT TO
CHOOSE. AS WELL AS CLARIFYING
THAT THE- THAT THE PROVIDERS OF
THIS WILL BE- NOT A PROBATION OR
PAROLE DEPARTMENTS BUT- THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS IN
CONJUNCTION WITH COMMUNITY
BASED. NONPROFITS SENSUALLY THIS
WON'T BE A LOCKDOWN FACILITY- SO
WITH THAT- I WOULD ASK YOUR I
VOTED ALLOW MY WITNESSES TO
PARTICIPATE THIS MORNING THANK
YOU. THANK YOU YOU HAVE
WITNESSES I DON'T THINK SO YES-
GOOD MORNING THIS IS DISTRICT
ATTORNEY JEFF REISIG OF YOLO
COUNTY. TOO MANY PEOPLE WHO
SUFFER FRM SERIOUS SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DISORDERS ARE GOING TO
PRISONS AND JAILS FOR CRIMES
THAT ARE MOTIVATED BY THEIR
ADDICTION. AND PRISONS AND JAILS
ARE SIMPLY NOT PLACES WHERE SICK
PEOPLE GO TO GET BETTER. AB
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT PROPOSAL
LOCAL TREATMENT ALTERNATIVE TO
PRISON AND JAIL FOR THOSE PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN CONVICTED. OF FELONY
LEVEL CRIMES MOTIVATED BY THEIR
SERIOUS ADDICTION TO DRUGS BUT
WHO POSE TOO MUCH OF A RISK FOR
A JUDGE TO SIMPLY RELEASE THEM
INTO AN UNSECURED RESIDENTIAL
FACILITY IN THE COMMUNITY. WHERE
THEY CAN SIMPLY WALK AWAY OR
CRAWL OUT A WINDOW ON DAY ONE.
AND POTENTIALLY CAUSE MORE HARM
TO THEMSELVES OR OTHERS INSTEAD.
AB NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT
INDIGENTS CREATING A SECURE
HOSPITAL LIKE TREATMENT
ENVIRONMENT WITHOUT JAIL BARS
AND GUARDS AND GUNS. THAT CAN
SERVE AS A SANCTUARY FOR
SERIOUSLY ADDICTED FELONY
OFFENDERS WHO VOLUNTARILY.
CHOOSE TO TRY LOCAL COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT AND WRAPAROUND
SERVICES IN A SAFE AND SECURE
SETTING. INSTEAD OF JUST BEING
WAREHOUSE BEHIND BARS WE CALL
THIS PLACE HOPE CALIFORNIA WHAT
ALSO MAKES THIS TREATMENT
ALTERNATIVE UNIQUE IS THAT IT
WILL BE DESIGNED AND STAFFED BY
TREATMENT PROVIDERS. AND THEY
WILL DECIDE WHO IS AN
APPROPRIATE CANDIDATE AND WHO IS
NOT. AND WHAT THE TREATMENT
SHOULD LOOK LIKE. FOR THOSE
SUCCESS CHIU INCOME TREATMENT
OVER PRINTING. THEY WILL HAVE
THEIR CONVICTIONS EXPUNGED AND
THEY WILL GET A CLEAN START
RIGHT HERE AT HOME. ULTIMATELY
AB NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT IT'S A
VERY MEASURED PILOT BILL WITH
JUST A FEW COUNTIES. THAT IS
DESIGNED TO OFFER A VOLUNTARY
TREATMENT ALTERNATIVES TO THOSE
WHO ARE OTHERWISE ON THEIR WAY
TO PRISON OR JAIL. I WOULD URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO GIVE THIS
PILOT PROGRAM A CHANCE. THANK
YOU.
THE IS THE- OF THE WITNESS. ANY
BROWN HELLO I'M MARK. YOU MAY BE
GETTING A HEARING. YES OKAY
YERLI- HELLO I CAN START. HELLO
HELLO- OF THE COMMITTEE AND
ASSEMBLY PARKS AND MCCARTY HI MY
NAME IS ANTHONY BROWN AND I
WOULD LIKE. TO OFFER MY SUPPORT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT THE HOPE CALIFORNIA. I AM
CURRENTLY BY THE IN CALIFORNIA
THE PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN I AM
A REGISTERED NRSE I'M ALSO A
PUBLIC HEALTH NURSE I AM
CERTIFIED IN ADDICTION
TREATMENT- ANGER MANAGEMENT AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE I'M NOT. HELLO
KEEP GOING I'M OKAY I'M OFF ON A
METAL OF PEOPLE OF GB MY MASTER
GROUP BUYS IN NURSING AND I PRAY
THAT ONE DAY I'LL BECOME A NURSE
PRACTITIONER. I'M ALSO A
PUBLISHED AUTHOR AS WELL AS THE
PROFESSOR. AT ONE OF THE
COLLEGES HERE IN CALIFORNIA. I
HAVE DEDICATED THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS OF MY LIFE SPECIALIZING IN
THE FIELD OF MENTAL HEALTH AND
SUBSTANCE. USE DISORDERS. IN
THIS BILL IN SECTION ONE D.
THERE'S A THERE'S A LOT. OF THAT
STATE BETWEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY
AND TWO THOUSAND UNTIL. THE
NUMBER OF PARTS OF THE STATE
PRESENCE REPUBLICAN VIEWS
OFFENSES. HAVE INCREASED FROM.
1-900-022-0060 FIVE THOUSAND.
I'M NOT PROUD TO ADMIT THAT BUT
IN ALL HONESTY I AM SICK OF
THOSE NUMBERS. I STAND BEFORE
YOU TODAY TO GIVE SPACE. TO GIVE
A FAKE WITHOUT THE TEST NEXT.
ONE NINETEEN NINETY TO TWO
THOUSAND ONE I SPENT A TOTAL OF
NINE AND A HALF YEARS IN AND OUT
OF JAILS AND PRISONS. I THINK
THE ENTERPRISE OF DONOVAN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY AGO OUR
VALLEY THEY PRESIDENT AVENAL
STATE PRISON KERN VALLEY STATE
PRISON CALIFORNIA TO PREVENT
CALIFORNIA MEN'S COLONY AND HIGH
DESERT STATE PRISON. I SET UP A
SHARED IT WITH YOU TO PAY A
PICTURE WOULD THEN. FROM A. B.
TWENTY EIGHT. THE PASSAGE AT THE
PIECE OF LEGISLATION WHAT IT IN
INDIVIDUALS LIKE MAYBE PART
MEMBER OF UP TO. BY ADDRESSING
ADDICTION EARLY LIFE. I LIVED UP
BY CRITICAL AND PRO. OUTSIDE TWO
THIRDS TO OPEN CULTURE. I HAVE
BEEN ADDICTED TO STOP WITH THE
. I THAT SOME MAY SAY THAT THIS
IS THE CHOICE TO GET WELL- THE
BY COERCION. BUT TO GET TO WHERE
I AM TODAY I IT KNOWLEDGE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BECAUSE CLOTHES
ARE MARK. I KNOW I'M HEART THAT.
WE RIGHT BUT I COULDN'T TELL YOU
EXACTLY WHAT WAS WRONG. I KNOW
IT TOOK TIME AND SOMETIMES
THAT'S- WHAT I FILLED OUT WE
COULD SAVE IT TIME. AND TIME IS
MONEY AND MORE IMPORTANT TIME TO
FLY. THE HOPE CALIFORNIA BILL
HAS THE POTENTIAL OPERATE A MOLD
A ROAD MAP TO DESTINATION IT
TOOK ME TWENTY TWO YEARS TO
ACHIEVE. I'M A LIVING EXAMPLE OF
WHAT TRANSFORMATION LOOKS LIKE
WHAT THE PROPER STEPS ARE TAKEN.
SIX BILLION LONG TERM TREATMENT
THIS IS WHY I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FIVE
MINUTES EXACTLY- ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. I
OUTSIDE THE ROOM. WE'LL GO TO
THE PHONES OPEN IT UP EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR- FOR AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT MCCARTY. IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE SEVEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. BORDERLINE
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CAMELINA DONE WHAT THE NEW WAY
ALIVE WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF EIGHT AB NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU RYAN THIRTY
PLEASE GO OUT. THAT MEANS THAT
WITH ALL OF US CAN ORANGE AND I
AM IN. THANK I WANT FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. WITH THE KURDISH. NINE
DOWNTURN ALL OF US HERE NINE.
AND CHANGE THE INSIDE WE ARE IN
. THANK YOU FIFTH PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS DAN FIGURE
AND I'M CALLING IN BEHALF OF ALL
OF US ARE NOT LESS THAN AND I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU KNOW HIT HERE FROM WITNESSES
AND- IN THE ROOM. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR JOINS SOMEWHERE AND-
MEMBERS TIRING THE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES WE REPRESENT
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFIT
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER TREATMENT
PROVIDERS AND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB NINETEEN TWENTY
EIGHT WE WERE PREVIOUSLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THAT BUT VERSION
LAST YEAR AB FIFTEEN FORTY TWO-
AND- IN DARK. WE HAVE A STRONG
COALITION OF TREATMENT ADVOCATES
AS WELL AS STRESS THE SYSTEM
ADVOCATES BETTER IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL- WOULD LIKE TO READ
THAT- YOU KNOW GOVERNOR NEW SO
I'M I'M VETO THIS BILL LAST YEAR
STATING THAT I AM CONCERNED THAT
THIS IS A FALSE CHOICE THAT
EFFECTIVELY READS TO FORCE
TREATMENT. I AM ESPECIALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF
SUCH TREATMENT GIVEN THAT
EVIDENCE HAS SHOWN THAT COURSE
THE TREATMENT HINDERS
PARTICIPANTS LONG TERM RECOVERY.
I FROM THEIR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER WE DO NOT BELIEVE THAT
THE- CONCERNS THAT THE GOVERNOR
WERE DRESSED IN AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT- AND YOU KNOW JUST
TO ADD A LITTLE BIT MORE I'M-
THIS BILL IS NOT EVIDENCE BASED
ON WHICH OUR SYSTEM OF ADDICTION
TREATMENT THROUGH THE PUBLIC
SYSTEM HAS BEEN BUILT UPON
THROUGH A SAM. AND THREE MEDIC
COW MEDIC COW CANNOT COVER THE
COST OF THIS PROGRAM AND WE SEE
THAT THIS BILL IT'S BEEN
EXPANDED TO ADDITIONAL COUNTIES
THIS YEAR- AND WE FEAR- YOU KNOW
AT THAT. THE OUTCOMES AT THE END
OF THE DAY WILL NOT BE WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS LOOKING FOR-
IT'LL HARM PARTICIPANTS AND WE
ALSO- OR SIGN THIS BILL IS ALSO
NOT A NEW IDEA- THIS IS BEEN
TRIED BEFORE. WE NEED TO FOCUS
MORE ON VOLUNTARY TREATMENT
INVESTMENT AND HOUSING AND
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES NOT INTO AB
NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE NO
ON AB. NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHAIR NUMBERS- LISA LEWIS HERE
ON BEHALF THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION. A DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE THE NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION ADVOCATING FOR DRUG
POLICIES GROUNDED IN SCIENCE
COMPASSION HEALTH AND HUMAN
RIGHTS WE HAVE SEVERAL CONCERNS
STILL WITH THIS BILL- OF JULY
TENSION TO TWO OF THEM. THE
FIRST IS THE IMPACT IT'LL HAVE
ON BLACK AND BROWN INDIVIDUALS
THE BILL STILL FAILS TO ENSURE
THE PILOTS WILL BE IMPLEMENTED
IN A RACIALLY EQUITABLE MANNER.
TO PREVENT THE UNNECESSARY
INCARCERATION OF BLACK AND BROWN
INDIVIDUALS. ARREST RATES FROM
TWENTY TWENTY DEMONSTRATE THAT
BLACK AND LATINOS HAVE UNFAIRLY
TARGETED HAVE BEEN UNFAIRLY
TARGETED FOR DRUG ARRESTS.
LATINOS CONSIST CONSTITUTED
FORTY TWO POINT 4% OF ALL FELONY
DRUG ARREST AND WHAT
CALIFORNIANS MADE UP THIRTEEN
POINT 3% OF ARRESTED DESPITE
MAKING UP ONLY SIX POINT 5% OF
THE STATE'S POPULATION. THE
SECOND CONCERN IS THAT THE BILLS
OPPOSED BY EVERY STATE TREATMENT
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA. THE
SCIENCE DOES NOT SUPPORT THE
EFFICACY OF COURSE TREATMENT.
AND ON THE CONTRARY DEMONSTRATES
THAT IS COMPLETELY INEFFECTIVE
AND COSTLY. TREATMENT
PROFESSIONALS RECOMMEND MOVING
AWAY FROM MANDATED TREATMENT AND
TOWARDS EVIDENCE BASED
APPROACHES THAT WE KNOW WORK.
THIS INCLUDES LOW BARRIER
COMMUNITY DRUG TREATMENT
OVERDOSE OVERDOSE PREVENTION
PROGRAMS AND CULTURALLY
RESPONSIVE OUTREACH. THE PATH TO
RECOVERY IS NOT LINEAR IT OFTEN
INVOLVES RELAPSES AND FOR THIS
REASON WE MUST INSTEAD INVESTING
RESOURCES INTO OUR COMMUNITIES.
TO FACILITATE TREATMENT AND
ROMAN ONCE A PERSON IS READY TO
TAKE THAT STEP. AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT WITH THE TRACK FROM
THESE EFFORTS AND DIVERT
RESOURCES THAT COULD BE BETTER
USED IN THE COMMUNITY. WE DO NOT
DISAGREE THAT MORE SHOULD BE
DONE TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT REPACKAGING A
PROVEN FAILED POLICY WILL NOT
WORK AND FAILS TO ADDRESS THE
ROOT CAUSES SUCH AS POVERTY
TRAUMA AND THE ENDURING IMPACTS
OF RACISM. AND OTHER FORMS OF
OPPRESSION. WE ALSO FEAR THAT
THIS PROGRAM WILL PUT CALIFORNIA
ON A DANGEROUS PATH TOWARDS RE
PURPOSING JAILS AND POSSIBLY
PRISONS FOR INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. AS WE
KNOW FIFTY YEARS OF ENFORCING
THE WAR ON DRUGS COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR WOULD BEAR THE BRUNT OF
THIS ENFORCEMENT. AND MEMBERS OF
THOSE COMMUNITIES WILL ALMOST
CERTAINLY BE DISPROPORTIONATELY
FORCED INTO LAW TREATMENT AND
LONGER JAIL SENTENCES.
SENTENCING A PERSON TO DRUG
TREATMENT INSIDE A LOCKED
FACILITY IS STILL
CRIMINALIZATION AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE JOURNAL ABOUT.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. MARCO GEORGE ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION I'M SORRY
BUT WE'RE STILL IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL. HEY
THANK YOU. YEAH THE REDNESS IS
DAN ACCORD I'M ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
STRONG OPPOSITION. FRED WILLIAMS
ACLU CAL ACTION IN OPPOSITION.
GERYGONE ON BEHALF OF INITIATE
JUSTICE IN STRONG BUT RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. NOW GO TO
THE PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATE HERE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO A. B. NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'LL
START WOULD LIE NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HOW MANY DO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF
CAN TO THE WHOLE THE WHOLE
BUILDING ALL THE CALIFORNIA
CONCEPT TELEVISION IN THE POSTAL. THANK YOU. THANKS YOU WHO I
WANT TO TWO GO AHEAD. DANIEL
GOOD CARE ON BEHALF OF THE
THIRTY FOR CRIMINALS AND
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I'M AT
THREE PREVIEW AHEAD. AMBER SHE
WITH THE TURKEY THE HEALTH
THIRTEEN OF COLLEGE AND OFF THE
- THANK YOU I NINETY ONE CALL.
BYE. NINE ONE. ONE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
HANNAH BACK OFF CALLING IN ON
BEHALF OF CAL VOICES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI THIS YEAR TEN ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PORTION OF
ADDICTION PROGRAMS AND
PROFESSIONALS IN OPPOSITION OF.
THANK YOU RIDE ONE THIRTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND. ONE THREE
ONE. BY ONE THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIS IS DEBORAH WITH
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA.
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THANK YOU
. BY NINETY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD
. THIS IS ANDREA GARCIA IN THE
M. WHEN SAMPLING YOU KNOW
FREEDOM ALL AND PROJECT IT MAY
NOT IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU DO
NOT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS. MISTER BRIAN-
STRUGGLING HARD WITH THIS ONE- I
KNOW THE AUTHORS AND IT YOU KNOW
HEART- ONE OF THE THINGS
STRUGGLING WITH IS CONTROLLED
SUGGESTED. NOT I THINK THE WORD
WE'RE HEARING FROM OPPOSITION IS
DIRECTLY. AND EVEN IN THE
EXAMPLE THAT THAT WAS GIVEN
ABOUT A FAMILY MEMBERS THEY SAY
NO THEY SAY NO AND AT ONE TIME
THEY SAY YES. THAT THE NO HERE
IS NOT CARE IT'S NOT TREATMENT
IT'S NOT SUPPORT- WHICH IS WHY
THE DIRECT FEELING AS BEING FELT
SO IF THIS MOVES OUT OF
COMMITTEE TODAY I HOPE THAT THAT
CONCERN CONTINUES TO BE
WORKSHOPS I KNOW FIFTY
AMENDMENTS AS A LOT- IT IS
IMPORTANT AND I THINK FIFTY
AMENDMENTS AND- FOLK STILL
FRUSTRATED IS ALSO. TIMING
THINGS WELL- SO BUT I THINK YOU
FOR WORKING ON THIS EVER BECAUSE
IT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT.
CONVERSATION THAT WE GET PEOPLE
TO CARE THAT THEY NEED AND THAT
THEY DON'T. GET THEIR MENTAL
SUBSTANCE ABUSE AND HEALTH
TREATMENT AND OUR JOB IS TO
LEASE WITH THEIR CURRENT AGAIN.
DR WEBER. GOOD MORNING- SO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT WOULD WOULD
QUALIFY FOR THIS PILOT PROGRAM
HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OF A
QUALIFYING DRUG MOTIVATED FELONY
CRIME IS THAT CORRECT. YES THEY
PUT COMMITTED OF A NON DRUG-OFFENSE AND GIVE ME SOME FINDING
BY THE COURT AND- THE DISTRICT
ATTORNEY THAT THAT IT'S RELATED
TO A DRUG ADDICTION. SO THERE
OPTION WOULD BE TO EITHER GO TO
JAIL OR GO TO THIS FACILITY
CORRECT AND WE KNOW THAT GOING
TO JAIL HAS NOT BEEN SHOWN TO
REALLY HELP WITH ADDICTION. SO
THIS IS WHY THIS IS BEING
OFFERED. EXACTLY IT'S A PILOT
PROJECT AND I KNOW THE PEOPLE
THINK IT'S GOING TO HAVE SOME
HORRIFIC OUTCOMES BUT THAT'S
BUDGET TEST THINGS THAT'S WHAT
WE HAVE PILOTS IT'S A FEW COUNTY
PILOT LIKE IT'S MY LAST TIME I
CHECKED WAS A FIVE YEAR PILOTS
AND WE'RE GOING TO- MONITOR
PEOPLE WHO WENT THROUGH IT TO
SEE IF THEY HAVE. YOU KNOW THEIR
RELAPSE NUMBERS WERE BETTER OR
WORSE THAN INDIVIDUALS WHO
DIDN'T GO THROUGH IT- BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT THAT STATUS QUO IS
NOT. EFFECTIVE YEAH EXACTLY
RIGHT- YEAH I GUESS THAT'S- WHAT
I WAS CONFUSED ABOUT WHEN
LISTING LISTENING TO THE
OPPOSITION WHAT ARE THERE WHAT
ARE THE OPTIONS SO. IF THE
OPTION IS BETWEEN GOING TO JAIL
WHICH WE KNOW IT'S NOT GOING TO
NECESSARILY TREAT YOUR ADDICTION
OR TO GIVE YOU THE EDUCATION AND
THE RESOURCES THAT YOU NEED
UNFORTUNATELY AT THIS TIME
VERSUS ACTUALLY. GOING INTO A
PILOT PROGRAM THAT IS
SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED ON HELPING
YOU OVERCOME YOUR ADDICTION- HI
I'M CONFUSED. AS TO THAT THAT
THAT THAT THE NATURE OF THE
OPPOSITION- I WOULD. RECOMMEND
THOUGH I KNOW YOU'VE TAKEN A LOT
OF AMENDMENT- FROM HEALTH CARE
STANDPOINT IT IS IMPORTANT TO DO
THINGS THAT ARE. EVIDENCE BASED
AND SO IF THERE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS OUT THERE LIKE ASM
YOU KNOW TO TRY TO ALIGN THE
CRITERIA AS CLOSE AS POSSIBLE. I
KNOW THAT- WE THROUGH THIS I.
HAS NO LAW FACILITY WHICH
PROBABLY WOULD NEED IN THIS
CASE- BUT JUST TRY TO ALIGN IT
AS CLOSELY AS POSSIBLE THE OTHER
THING YOU JUST MENTIONED WITH
THE- TIMELINE OF THE PILOT
PROGRAM AND I KNOW THIS WAS A
BILL THAT CAME UP LAST YEAR. I
THINK IT'S SUPPOSED TO AND- IN
TWENTY TWENTY SIX SO THAT WOULD
NOT GIVE FIVE YEARS- I DON'T
KNOW IF THERE'S BEEN ANY
CONVERSATION. ABOUT EXTENDING
THAT. DEADLINE OF THE OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM BUT IT SAYS IT
WOULD END IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX
BUT- THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
INTRODUCING AND CLARIFYING FOR
ME WHO WOULD ACTUALLY QUALIFY
FOR THIS PROGRAM. AND WHAT THE
OPTION WOULD BE IF THEY CHOSE
NOT TO. TO ACTUALLY DO THIS
PILOT PROGRAM. THE OTHER
QUESTIONS OR. DID YOU ANSWER
LETTER YEAH. WHAT THE SOMEONE
EVERY WEEK IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
FIVE YEARS IF THERE IS A
DRAFTING ERROR THAT WILL GO BACK
AND CLARIFY. AND WE DO CONCUR
THAT IT SHOULD BE- RESEARCH-
DRIVEN AND BASED UPON-
EDUCATIONAL SENSE SO- WE HAVE
THAT IN THERE WE DID THAT LAST
YEAR AND- YOU CERTAINLY TAKE A
LOOK AND- MAKE SURE IT'S EVEN
STRONGER THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VIRGINIA QUESTIONS. THE THIRTY
TO CLARIFY THIS MCCARTY AT JUST
PLEASE SHARE MORE ABOUT THE KIND
OF FEEDBACK WE WOULD GET. AT THE
END OF THIS PILOT. YEAH I THINK
THERE IS SOME SUCH A SUGGESTION
IN HERE FROM THAT HAVE SO MANY
PAPERS IN FRONT OF ME I THINK
IT'S- NONSENSE. IT ABOUT THE-
CLEAR. THAT YOU. UNTIL ON THE
REPORT BACK AND I WOULD THINK
THAT YEAH WE WOULD WANT TO NOT
JUST TO TRADITIONAL REPORT ON
THE PILOT HOUSE DOING BUT
INTERIM MEASURES THROUGHOUT THE
AND YOU KNOW- ANY DATA THE TALKS
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO'VE GONE THROUGH
THIS AND WHAT IS IT ABOUT YOU
KNOW PROMISING- PROGRAM BECAUSE
THAT'S WHAT WE DO A PILOT.
BECAUSE IF THIS WORKS MAYBE WANT
TO GO TO ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA SO-
WE DO HAVE THAT HAVE THAT
REPORTING AND I THINK THAT THE
SUGGESTIONS IN HERE ARE GOOD ONE
SYMBOL. IN CORPORATE THAT INTO
THE BILL. JUST TO CLARIFY IN
TERMS OF ELIGIBILITY. IF YOU
WANNA. REFER JUST TO CLARIFY IN
TERMS OF ELIGIBILITY AT SO IT SO
THIS IS FOR AS AN INDIVIDUAL WHO
HAS COMMITTED A FELONY BUT WE
KNOW THAT IT IS A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE DRIVEN- THAT THAT. ACT
ISSUE HAS CAUSED THEM TO COMMIT
THAT FELONY- ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PARAMETERS AROUND. THAT THIS
BEING AN AVAILABLE OPTION FOR
THE YES AND I GET SOMEWHAT
CONFUSED WITH THE FIFTY AND THE
CHANGES WE TOOK LAST YEAR BUT
MAYBE I CAN HAVE MY MAIN WITNESS
THAT THE DA FROM YOLO COUNTY
MISTER RISING I BELIEVE WE HAD
IT. THAT WITH THESE WERE NOT-
STRIKE OFFENSES AND NONVIOLENT
OFFENSES WOULD BE THE ONES WHO
WOULD BE KEPT CATEGORIZED HERE
AND I BELIEVE WE ALSO. EXEMPTED
OUT- THAT TO NINETY SIX SEX
CRIMES. IS THAT CORRECT MR
RISING. THAT'S CORRECT IT WOULD
NOT APPLY FOR- SECOND CHANCES
AND THEN SERIOUS AND VIOLENT
FELONIES WOULD BE EXCLUDED BUT
ANY OTHER INDIVIDUAL CONVICTED
OF A FELONY OFFENSE THAT WAS
FOUND TO BE DRUG MOTIVATED COULD
BE ELIGIBLE FOR ASSESSMENT AND
CHOOSING TREATMENT OVER PRISON.
WHAT DID YOU HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION ONE MORE QUESTION. SO
ARE ANY OF THESE INDIVIDUALS
THAT FIT INTO THIS CATEGORY.
WITH THEY'D BE ELIGIBLE FOR
PAROLE INSTEAD OF JAIL PROBATION
INSTEAD OF JAIL TIME. AT THE END
OF THEIR TERM YES BUT THE BUT
THEY ARE ARE THEY ARE SENTENCED.
AND THIS WOULD BE A CHOICE IN
LIEU OF THEIR SENTENCE SO IN
OTHER WORDS WE WOULDN'T HAVE
SOMEBODY GO THROUGH THIS IF THEY
COULD OTHERWISE BE. SENT HOME-
MISTER I THINK YOU WANT TO
CLARIFY FOR MISSING ANYTHING
THERE. NO THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT
THE IDEA BEHIND THIS PROGRAM IS
THAT THE TREATMENT PROGRAM WOULD
NEVER EXCEED. THE SENTENCE THAT
THE JUDGE WOULD OTHERWISE GIVE
THE PERSON. AND THAT'S DESIGNED
SPECIFICALLY TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS NOT TO NOTICE IT'S TREATMENT
OR WHATEVER THE OTHER
ALTERNATIVES WHETHER THAT'S
PRISON OR JAIL. JUST A
CLARIFYING QUESTION ON THAT ARE
THERE ANY BECAUSE YOU MENTIONED
NON NON VIOLENCE OF NON SERIOUS
AND TOOK SEVERAL THINGS OUT- IN
TERMS OF ELIGIBILITY ARE ANY OF
THE CRIMES THAT WOULD BE IN THIS
OPTION ONES WITH THE JUDGE
CURRENTLY HAS THE DISCRETION TO
SENTENCE YOU TO COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION INVOLUNTARY.
TREATMENT CENTER. YEAH I DON'T
THINK THAT CHANGES I THINK THAT
THIS I ONLY INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE. ARE SENTENCED TO THAT THAT
THAT TERM SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
MONSTERS YOUR YEARS AND THIS
WOULD BE PROVIDED AS AN OPTION I
DON'T THINK THIS AT ALL- UNDER
CUTS YOU KNOW JUDICIAL
DISCRETION FRIEND FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO BE- YOU KNOW
PLACE ON COMMUNITY RELEASED HER
PROBATION. MISTER ISAAC CAN YOU
CLEAR THAT AS WELL. THAT'S RIGHT
THE JUDGE HAS THE DISCRETION TO
YOU KNOW GIVE THE INDIVIDUAL
SENSE OF ANY LENGTH. AND IF IT'S
A- I THINK THE QUESTION IS
FOCUSED ON A VERY SHORT SENTENCE
PERHAPS WITH PROBATIONARY TIME
AND ENERGY ALL TIME THEN THAT
PROBABLY WOULDN'T BE AN
APPROPRIATE. SITUATION FOR THE
TREATMENT ALTERNATIVE. BECAUSE
IT JUST WOULDN'T BE THE TIME
AVAILABLE FOR THE PERSON TO
PARTICIPATE THIS IS REALLY
FOCUSED ON THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE RECEIVING NO LONGER
SENTENCES PRISON SENTENCES LONG
JAIL SENTENCES WHO ARE DRUG
ADDICTED. AND THEIR CRIME WAS
MOTIVATED BY DRUG BUSINESS TO
GIVE THEM A TREATMENT PATH THAT
THEY'RE CHOOSING INSTEAD OF. THE
SENTENCESENTENCE. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR FOR
WORKING WITH US FOR OVER A YEAR
ON THIS AND- THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND IT IS- AS
SUMMER BRAIN NOTED. SOMEWHAT
AWKWARD- WORKING ON A BILL THAT
IS OPPOSED BY INDIVIDUALS THAT
I'VE- AUTHOR GOES ON WITH THEIR
SUPPORT OVER THE YEARS ON
REFORMING OUR YOU KNOW. OUR
PAROLE- SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA-
BRINGING ABOUT VOTING RIGHTS FOR
FORMERLY INCARCERATED YOU KNOW
WORKING ON BANNING THE BOX SO I
AND I FULLY SUPPORT TO HOW WE
CAN KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM TO BRING
ABOUT SMART REFORMS. BUT THIS IS
SOMETHING I'VE COME TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT THE STATUS QUO
IS NOT WORKING I DON'T BELIEVE
IN WAREHOUSING ANY. ANYMORE
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA HI I'M
TRYING TO FOCUS ON THE PEOPLE
THAT WE DO HAVE IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM HOW TO BRING
ABOUT THE BEST RESULTS FOR THEM.
AND I WILL ADMIT THAT I WOULD
RATHER. FOCUS OUR EFFORTS IN THE
COMING JUSTICE SYSTEM. ON AND
YOU KNOW FOCUSING ON SUCCESS IN
HOUSING AND EMPLOYMENT I KNOW
WE'RE WORKING ON BILLS ON THAT
ISSUE BUT THIS IS A SEPARATE
ISSUES ARE INDIVIDUALS BEFORE
THEY'RE RELEASED HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE WHEN THEY ARE RELEASED
THROUGH ON THE PATH. TO SUCCESS
AND THIS IS- YOU KNOW ONE OF
THOSE. UNCOMFORTABLE ISSUES THEY
WERE DEALING WITH IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE THE SAME DEBATE ABOUT.
MENTAL HEALTH AND
CONSERVATORSHIP MAYBE ON THIS
COMMITTEE BUT THE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT- I THINK WE KNOW THAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON A NEW APPROACH
BECAUSE THE STATUS QUO IS NOT
WORKING IT'S FAILING US IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS A PILOT.
AGAIN IT'S A PILOT THIS ISN'T A
MANDATE FOR CALIFORNIA. WE TRY
THINGS SOMETIMES WE TRY THINGS
ALL THE TIME SOMETIMES THEY WORK
SOMETIMES THEY DON'T WORK I HOPE
THIS IS AFFECTED THAT'S THE PLAN
THAT'S WHY WE'RE OFFERING IT.
BUT WORST CASE SCENARIO WE
REALIZE YOU KNOW WHAT. MAYBE
THIS WASN'T AN APPROACH ON IS IT
GOING TO RUIN LIVES BY HAVING
PEOPLE DO MORE- DRUG TREATMENT
WHILE THEY'RE INCARCERATED
PROBABLY NOT I THINK IT'S THE
ONLY UPSIDE HERE- AND WITH THAT.
I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND I'M
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THESE ISSUES AS WE- PUT THIS
ISSUE- CLOSER TO THE GOVERNOR'S
DESK THIS YEAR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- DO WE HAVE A MOTION AND
SECOND. THEIR MOTION. SHARE
REMOVED. GOOD. AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY SOME OF OUR
MCCARTY THE MISSION IS TO PASS
TO THE HEALTH COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER IRAQI.
LACKEY ABSTAINED BONTA I'VE
BONTA HI BRIAN HI. BRIAN I
WEBER. WEBER I SANTIAGO. SAN
DIEGO BY MATT. SMITH OBTAINED.
THE MEASURE PASSES THANK YOU WE
WILL NOW HAVE A MR RODRIGUEZ-
FARMS AND SERIALIZED. FIRE THE
ITEM THIRTEEN LUCKY THIRTEEN.
MAYBE NOT SO. EIGHTEEN SIX NINE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN BURST THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT A. B.
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE WHICH WOULD
MAKE POSSESSION OF IT UNSER LICE
FARM OR FARM WITH AN ALTERED OR
REMOVED ZERO NUMBER NUMBER
PUNISHABLE AS A FELONY HAVING
SERIAL NUMBERS ON FARMS IS A
CRITICAL TOOL FOR PREVENTION AND
INVESTIGATION OF GUN VIOLENCE
WITHOUT ZERO NUMBERS LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS UNABLE TO CONTACT
THE MANUFACTURER DISTRIBUTOR
IMPORTER RETAILER AND OTHERS
INVOLVED TO LEARN WHO PURCHASED
A FARM AND THEIR CONNECTION TO A
POTENTIAL CRIME. GHOST GUNS ARE
TRACKED OF THE CRIMINALS FOR
THAT REASON BECAUSE THEY DO NOT
REQUIRE A BACKGROUND CHECK FOR
PURCHASES AND THEY ARE
UNTRACEABLE TAMON FORSMAN IT
SHOULDN'T BE A SURPRISE THAT
MANY POLICE DEPARTMENTS ARE
REPORTING INCREASES IN THE
NUMBER OF COURSE GUN SEIZURES
AND RECOVERIES FOR EXAMPLE THE
LOS SOUNDS POLICE DEPARTMENT
SHE'S NEARLY 4100% MORE GHOST
GUNS SINCE TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
SAN FRANCISCO POLICE DEPARTMENT
REPORTED AN INCREASE OF MORE
THAN 27100% SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN. OF THE TWELVE HUNDRED
FARMS OAKLAND RECEIVED NEARLY
22% WERE GHOST GUNS MANY OF
THESE COMMITTEES HAVE TURNED TO
BANNING GHOST GUNS INCLUDING SAN
DIEGO COUNTY AND THE CITIES OF
SAN FRANCISCO LOS ANGELES OKRENT
SANTA CLARA COUNTY IS ALSO
CONSIDERING ABOUT THIS PUBLIC
SAFETY CRISIS HAS LED THE BUDGET
ADMINISTRATION GOVERNOR NEWSOM
AND MEMBERS OF THIS LEGISLATURE
TO TAKE ACTION AGAINST THE
INCREASING NUMBERS OF GHOST GUNS
I APPLAUD ALL THEIR EFFORTS ON
THIS CRITICAL ISSUE AND BELIEVE
THAT A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE
IS ANOTHER ELEMENT NEEDED TO
PREVENT THOSE GUNS FROM CAUSING
MORE GUN VIOLENCE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. WHILE THEIR EFFORTS
FOCUSED ON SUPPLY OF GHOST GUNS
IN OUR LOCAL COMMUNITIES THERE
HASN'T BEEN ANY PROPOSALS TO
ADDRESS THE FARMS CURRENTLY IN
THE COMMUNITIES OR TO
SUFFICIENTLY DETER SOMEONE FROM
PURCHASING OR BEING IN
POSSESSION OF THESE FIREARMS
LAST YEAR THE LOS SOUTH STREET
APARTMENT. RELEASED A REPORT
STATING THAT COSTA AS WERE
INVOLVED IN THAN ONE HUNDRED
VIOLENT CRIME. INCLUDED TWENTY
FOUR MURDERS IT ATTEMPTED
HOMICIDES AND DOZENS OF ARMED
ROBBERIES AND ASSAULTS. LAST
WEEK SACRAMENTO COUNTY CHURCH
SHOOTING INVOLVED A GHOST GUN.
DESPITE HAVING A RESTRAINING
ORDER AND WHAT SOUNDS LIKE
ISSUES WITH MENTAL HEALTH HE HAD
AN A. R. FIFTEEN STYLE RIFLE
GHOST GUN. THAT WAS USED TO KILL
INNOCENT PEOPLE. THIS STORY
HIGHLIGHTS THE NEED FOR A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
TACKLING ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERNS WE ARE
FACING. AGAIN WHILE APPLAUD THE
WORK OF THE- TO ELIMINATE THE
SUPPLY OF GOES GUNS WE NEED TO
TAKE MORE ABOUT THE DATE DEMAND.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY
SUPPORT IS NICOLE CAN KNOWN AS
ON BEHALF OF EVERY TOWN FOR GUN
SAFETY. AND I BELIEVE SHE'S ON
THE PHONE. HELLO EVERYBODY GOOD
MORNING CHAIR NUMBERED THE
COKING SOMETHING AND EVERYTOWN
FOR GUN SAFETY MOMS DEMAND
ACTION AND DIDN'T DEMAND ACTION
REPORT AND- SIX NINE OUR OUR-
AND THEN ONE. ON IT ACT Q. AND A
DIFFERENT THEM GUN MANY YEARS.
SHE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RIGHT OF
AFTER WITH EIGHTY SIXTY NINE AND
WE'RE THAT IN THE PENALTY. OKAY
BACK THING GOT GOTTEN WILL SOME
ACQUIRE IT FIREARM AND THEIR IN
A CAR OR ACT THAT TRACKING. FOR
THE REASON THE PORT E. DE. NINE
YEAH. THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN A ROW IN
SUPPORT. YES SIR. MORNING PUT IT
DOWN FOR THE VERSE I KIND OF AS
FAR ON BEHALF OF- THE SUREST
BARMAN AND CHURCH BIANCO SUPPORT
THE THANK YOU THANK. ANY OUTSIDE
THE ROOM. THE MAY GO TO
TELEPHONE LINE WITH AND- OF AB
EIGHTY SIXTY NINE RODRIGUEZ. IF
THERE IS A PART OF AB EIGHT SIX
NINETY MAY PRESS ONE ONE ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S AND THEN IF AREN'T
OF AB. EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE. WE
WILL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MISTER KAREN MEMBERS BRENDAN UP
ON BEHALF OF THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NEXAVAR LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI GOOD MORNING THIS IS AT ONE
FOUR BONE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF ONTARIO IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. YOU MISTER CHAIR WE
HAVE LOST SUPPORT AND YOU AT THE
TIME. GOOD THEN WILL GO TO-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION AND BEAR
IN A- HEARING ROOM.
MY NAME IS MARCO GEORGIA I'M
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE. AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE IS NOT NEEDED AS THE
AUTHOR AND SPONSOR OF THIS BILL
NOTED THE RECOVERY OF GHOST GUNS
IS USUALLY IN CONNECTION WITH
THE COMMISSION OF ANOTHER CRIME
FOR WHICH THE INDIVIDUAL FACE
MUCH MORE SERIOUS CONSEQUENCES.
RANGING FROM A YEAR FOR ARMED
WITH A FIREARM TO TWENTY FIVE
YEARS TO LIFE FOR USE OF THE
FIREARMS RESULTING IN DEATH.
THIS BILL WILL NOT SEND A
MESSAGE TO CRIMINALS IT WILL NOT
DETER CRIME. WHAT AB EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE WILL DO IS SEND MORE
BLACK AND BROWN CALIFORNIANS TO
JAIL OR PRISON IT WILL
IMPOVERISH THEIR FAMILIES AND
THEIR COMMUNITIES. IT WILL
PERMANENTLY CAN LIMIT
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE SUFFERED
FELONY CONVICTIONS TO LOW PAYING
JOBS BECAUSE MANY EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES AND BETTER PAYING
JOBS ARE OPEN TO FELONS. IT
WASTE TAXPAYERS MONEY
IMPRISONING PEOPLE WALK
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS HEALTH CARE
AND HOUSING GO WANTING FOR
ADEQUATE FUNDING. C. PDA INSTEAD
URGES YOU TO ADOPT A PUBLIC
HEALTH APPROACH TO THE PANDEMIC
OF GUNS IN OUR STATE. IT WOULD
BE MORE COST EFFECTIVE AND
HUMANE. CALIFORNIA HAS REDUCE
SMOKING BY A COMBINATION OF
TAXES ON CIGARETTES BANS ON
SMOKING IN PUBLIC SPACES AND
EDUCATION SUCH A MULTI PRONG
STRATEGY SHOULD BE EMPLOYED TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF GHOST GUNS
IN CALIFORNIA. ALSO THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO
BRING PUBLIC NUISANCE LAWSUITS
AGAINST INDIVIDUALS AND
COMPANIES TO MANUFACTURE GHOST
GUNS OR GHOST GUN MANUFACTURING
EQUIPMENT. SERIOUS FINANCIAL
PENALTIES ARE MORE LIKELY TO
DETER THESE INDIVIDUALS AND
THEIR COMPANIES THAN CRIMINAL
PENALTIES AGAINST THE UNWITTING
INDIVIDUAL WHO POSSESSES SUCH A
WEAPON. AND JUST ON THAT-
INSTANCE I WOULD SAY THAT
APPARENTLY NOW ON THE INTERNET
YOU CAN ORDER A QUICK MINUTE SO
YOU CAN MAKE YOUR OWN GHOST KIND
AT HOME. SO WE HAVE THE ABILITY
IN CALIFORNIA TO TAX. SO THERE'S
NO REASON THAT THESE MACHINES
SHOULD NOT BE PROHIBITIVELY
EXPENSIVE IN CALIFORNIA. SO ON
BEHALF OF C. P. D. A. R.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE ON A. B. EIGHTEEN SIXTY
NINE. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION WHAT IS
THAT. THAT'S GOOD OKAY HI FRED
WILLIAMS A SAY YOU CAL ACTION-
ONE ECHO THE COMMENTS ABOUT
CURRENCY PDA AND AFTER NOBLE ON
THIS BILL- WELL WE- DEFINITELY
APPLAUD THE AUTHOR FOR TAKING ON
GHOST GUNS WE DO. UNDERSTAND THE
IMPACT OUR COMMUNITIES IT IS OUR
VIEW THAT- INCREASE IMPRISONMENT
AND REYES FROM MISDEMEANOR TO A
FELONY IS NOT THE CORRECT WAY TO
DO THIS. THERE ARE ALREADY A
MYRIAD OF PENALTIES AND
ENHANCEMENTS FOR AN INDIVIDUAL
WHO COMMITS AN OFFENCE WHILE
ARMED WITH ANY KIND OF FIREARM
OR USE A FIREARM DURING THE
OFFENSE. DISABILITY RIGHT FROM
ADDITIONAL YEAR TO COUNTY JAIL
TO TWENTY FIVE YEARS TO LIFE IN
STATE PRISON DEPENDING ON THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE OFFENCE.
BILLS SUCH AS THE THAT INCREASE
PENALTIES FOR MISDEMEANORS TO
FELONIES WITH A FOUNDATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S MASS INCARCERATION
CRISIS AND HAVE BEEN ROLLED BACK
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN SHOWN TO BE
INEFFECTIVE AND HARMFUL. MASS
INCARCERATION POLICIES RESULT IN
OVER POLICING AND OVER
INCARCERATION OF BLACK AND BROWN
COMMUNITIES. AS WELL AS
DIVERTING RESOURCES AWAY FROM
SCHOOLS HEALTH CARE AND HOUSING.
IS FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR NOBLE
ON THIS BILL THANK. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN A ROOM.
IN OPPOSITION. AND WE NOW GO TO
THE- AT&T LINE IT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU FOR IN
OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHTEEN SIXTY
NINE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THAT MANY
ZERO. AGAIN IT IS ONE THEN ZERO
FOR ANY OPPOSITION AB. EIGHTEEN
SIXTY NINE. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI THIS IS KIMBERLY DOWN WITH
A NEW WAY ALIVE AND WE STRONGLY-
OPPOSE AB. EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU NEXT WEEK ONLINE OF
ONE THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND
COMPROMISED ONE TWENTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI YES BY MANY
CENTER TO SOME ABOVE WITH THAT
TIRED- AND ALSO ALL OF A SUDDEN
ON SECOND. I STRONGLY OPPOSED
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT. PEOPLE OF
COLOR SORRY LEVEL. THANK YU.
THANK YOU NEXT GO TO LINE THIRTY
SAY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. DURING
THE THAT MEANS AFTER WOULD NOT
OF US ARE OR COUNTY AND WE ARE
ENOUGH. TO THANK YOU I MISS
CHERRY NOW FOR OPPOSITE TO GIVE
THIS TIME. THANK YOU- BUT BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
BUT MISTER SMITH- WHAT DO WE
CONSIDER IT WOULD YOU WOULD
CONSIDER AMENDING SECTION TWO OF
THIS BILL TO MAKE MANUFACTURING
A FIREARM WITHOUT A OBTAINING A
SERIAL NUMBER A WOBBLER WHICH
WOULD GIVE THE JUDGE THE
DISCRETION OF THE TO GIVE IT UP
INCREMENTALLY GOING FORWARD BUT
GOING STRAIGHT TO A FELONY-
COULD BE EXTREME IN SOME CASES.
AND IT WASN'T A CRIME A FEW
YEARS AGO SO I DON'T KNOW IF OU
ARE UP TO TAKE A ANY AMENDMENTS.%
THANK YOU FOR THAT BUT YES I'M
OPEN TO ANY TYPE OF- AMENDMENTS
TO THIS BILL I THINK THE END OF
THE DAY WE NEED TO. SEE WHAT WE
CAN DO TO TURN THE VICTORS FROM
POSSESSION OWNERSHIP OF THESE
FIREARMS SO. ANY HELP IS OR A
CHANGES IS WELCOMED AND I'M OPEN
TO THAT AS WELL AS LONG AS
EVERYONE ELSE AS WELL BUT ALMOST
UP TO THE CHURCH QUESTION BUT
I'M OPEN TO IT. YES OKAY. ANY
OTHER. QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS.
YOU MAY CLOSE. MISTER CHAIRMAN
WITHOUT CLOSING I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
TRYING TO FIND AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD ACCOMPLISH MY POLICY GOES
WILD DRESSED IN THE CONCERNS OF
THE MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
WILL UNDERSTAND THE COMMITTEE IS
CONCERNED ABOUT INCARCERATED
MORE INDIVIDUALS AND THE IMPACT
THIS POLICY MAY HAVE A SPECIAL
ON COMMUNITIES OF COLOR I CANNOT
EMPHASIZE ENOUGH. HOW DANGEROUS
INCOME OF THESE GHOST GUNS HAVE
BECOME AS MANY OF YOU KNOW MY
SON IS A DEPUTY SHERIFF AND HE
TOLD ME MONTHLY HE GETS ONE TO
TWO OF THESE FARMS OFF THE
STREETS AND THAT'S JUST THEM. AS
A TO AND LOCAL. WE MUST DETER
OFFENDERS FROM POSSESSION THESE
FARMS WHICH ARE MADE. TO
INTENSIVELY. COMMITTEE CRIME FOR
MURDER. I HOPE ALL OF YOU. KNOW
THAT I WILL CONTINUE THIS FIGHT
TO REMOVE THESE DANGEROUS
WEAPONS FROM OUR STREETS AND A
WE HAPPILY WELCOME. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH ANYONE
WILLING TO ADDRESS. THE
POSSESSION AND OWNERSHIP OF
GHOST. WITH THAT I RESPECT YOU
HAVE FOR I WILL. YOU DO A
PROMOTION- IS THERE A SECOND.
OKAY THANK YOU SO THIS ONE
ACTUALLY WAS DIFFICULT FOR ME
BECAUSE I. OBVIOUSLY I. HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH FELONIES THIS ISN'T
JUST IN GENERAL- NOT ONLY IS A
MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE BUT
JUST PRSONALLY AND WHATNOT THEY
ACTUALLY GET. TO WHERE WE NEED
TO BE BUT I ALSO HAVE A REAL
PROBLEM WITH GUNS ESPECIALLY IN
. AREAS LIKE MYSELF LA VERSION
AREAS WHERE YOUR SON WORKS THAT
IT IS A IT IS A PROBLEM- WHILE
I. PERSONALLY BELIEVE THAT WE'VE
THE BEST WAY WE COULD SOLVE THE
GUN PROBLEM IF WE JUST TAKE THE
GUNS OUT OF ALL MEN BECAUSE MEN
ARE THE MAIN PROBLEMS WITH GUNS-
AT THE DAY CO YOU AND NOT. THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S WHICH SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES WITH WITH
HAVING THAT KIND OF- MOVEMENT-
AND SO I'M I'M- NOT VOTING BUT
IF IT DOESN'T MAKE IT- WE TWEAK.
LET'S GET TOGETHER AND TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE CAN DO NEXT. THANK
YOU A CALDERON. ON AB SIXTY NINE
BY SEVEN MEMBER RETREAT GUESS
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER NOT VOTING
LACKEY. LACKEY NOT VOTING BONTA
. BONTA KNOW BRIAN STATE BRIAN
ABSTAINED WEBER WEBER ABSTAINED
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I MET. THE
OTHER MAN. SMITH NOW. I'M SORRY
THAT MEASURE DID PASS THANK. YOU
WANT RECONSIDERATION MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. S. OPTICAL DIVERSION
YES TO READ THE STATEMENT. CLOSE
REVIVED IT. IF THERE IS NO
OBJECTION WE WILL GRAB THIS BILL
RECONSIDERATION BY UNANIMOUS
CONSENT YOU HAVE AG. APPRECIATE
NOW MISS WALDRON. EIGHT NUMBER
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WALDRON SHOPLIFTING
INCREASE PENALTIES FOR PRIOR
CRIMES. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK SENATOR BATES AND-
PUBLIC SAFETY MEMBER OF SOME
WOMEN SAY ARTIFICAL AUTHORING
THE BILL ONCE IT GETS AMENDED-
AB FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN WILL
HELP KERR OF THE WAVE OF THEFT
IN OUR STATE BY RESTORING SERIAL
THEFT PROVISIONS THAT WERE IN
LAW PRIOR TO THE PASSAGE OF PROP
FORTY SEVEN. AND ALLOW IT TO BE
PUT BEFORE THE VOTERS. THESE
PROVISIONS ALLOW PROSECUTORS TO
AT ADEQUATELY CHARGE REPEAT
OFFENDERS UPON THEIR FOURTH
THEFT CONVICTION. EVERY DAY I
HEAR FROM FOLKS IN MY DISTRICT
THAT THEY DON'T FEEL SAFE
ANYMORE. IT IS A FACT THAT CRIME
HAS RISEN IN OUR STATE RECENT
NEWS STORIES HAVE EVEN
DEMONSTRATED THAT THEFT HAS
RISEN SIGNIFICANTLY IN
CALIFORNIA AND HAS LED RETAILERS
TO ANNOUNCE PLANS TO SHUT DOWN
OR SLASH THEIR HOURS IN RESPONSE
TO RAMPANT SHOPLIFTING.
ACCORDING TO LAPD DATA THROUGH
NOVEMBER TWENTY SEVENTH PROPERTY
CRIME IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS UP
OVER THE SAME PERIOD OF TWENTY
TWENTY ROBBERY IS UP OVER TWENTY
TWENTY AS WELL AND CAR THEFTS
ARE UP NEARLY FIFTY THREE
PERCENT. SINCE TWENTY NINETEEN
WE'VE BEEN ADDRESSING THE
ORGANIZED NATURE OF THEFT BUT WE
ALSO MUST INCLUDE TOUGHER
CONSEQUENCES TO DETER REPEAT
OFFENDERS- ANY AS YOU ALL KNOW I
AM INCREDIBLY PASSIONATE ABOUT
ENSURING SECOND CHANCES ARE
AVAILABLE. TO THOSE WHO ARE MOST
VULNERABLE IN OUR STATE BUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FOLKS WHO
HAVE BEEN CONVICTED OF THE SAME
CRIME. FOR THE FOURTH TIME SO WE
NEED TO GO. GET THEM THE HELP
THAT THEY NEED- WHICH PROP FORTY
SEVEN ELIMINATED THAT ABILITY.
SO THE REPEAL. OF SYRUP THAT
STATUTE WAS A MISTAKE THAT
SHOULD BE CORRECTED WE HAVE A
CHANCE TO DO THAT TODAY WITH AB
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN AND PUT
BEFORE THE VOTERS. JOINING ME
TODAY ON THE PHONE IS LIEUTENANT
BRANDON AB LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE
FOR THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT. AND I'LL
HAND IT OVER TO LIEUTENANT UP IF
HE IS THERE. THANK YOU THE
AGENCY OPERATOR YOU CAN OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR A- WTF. THERE ARE
MEMBERS. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS LIEUTENANT BRANDON UP
WITH THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT HERE TODAY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN. OPTIMIST COULD TELL YOU
SOME SOME REAL LIFE STORIES TOLD
TO ME FROM DEPUTIES DOWN THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY AND I AND I
STRESS THAT THESE ARE STE THE
STORIES TOLD BY DOCTORS DIRECTLY
TO ME BUT- YOU'RE GOING TO FIND-
DID YOU THE SEATTLE FAMILIAR- MY
FIRST STORY INVOLVED A MAN. WHO
UPON BEING DETAINED BY DEPUTIES
QUICKLY HELD UP A CALCULATOR IN
ORDER TO PROVE HE TOOK THE TIME
TO MAKE SURE ITEMS YOU JUST
STOLEN NOT ADD UP TO NINE
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS. DOESN'T
HEARING HE WOULD ONLY BE ISSUED
A CITATION AND SENT ON HIS WAY
AFTER SHORT BOOKING. MY SECOND
STORY ABOUT AMANDA ENCOUNTERED
CARRY NOT ONE. NOT TWO. BUT SIX
CITATIONS IN HIS WALLET FOR PAST
VIOLATIONS SHOPLIFTING. HE SO
PROUDLY DISPLAYED THEM YOU WERE
THOUGHT THEY WERE CERTIFICATES
OF ACCOMPLISHMENT- NOT CITATIONS
FOR BAD BEHAVIOR. AND PERHAPS
ONE OF THE MOST MORRISON FOR
THINKING SHOPLIFTER STORED UP
THESE SHE HAS NEVER MISSED A
COURT DATE BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T
WANT ANY OF HER CITATIONS TO
BECOME WARRANTS. I THINK THE
COMMON ATTITUDE THE PEOPLE WE
ARE ARRESTING SEEM TO SHARE IS
THAT THE REWARD FOR THIS
BEHAVIOR FAR OUTWEIGHS ANY RISK.
AND BEING INCONVENIENCED BY
CITATION IT'S JUST THE COST OF
DOING BUSINESS. AND RESTORE THE
MANY LIKE IT'S WE ENCOURAGE YOUR
YES VOTE. ON THE AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME. THANK YOU OF ANY WITNESSES
IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT. WANT TO
CHECK MY CREDIT MY NAME IS
WILLIAM RIVERSIDE COUNTY
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT WE SUPPORT
THE BILL THANK YOU OR ANY OTHER
WITNESSES OUTSIDE THE ROOM.
IT. SERVER THAT GOOD MORNING J.
MEMBERS SPREAD WHIMS ACLU CAL
ACTION IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL OR WE MUST BUT WHAT WE
SHOULD DO IN SUPPORT OF WHAT
OKAY THE BUDGET GREEN WAIT RIGHT
THERE. YEAH WE'RE GOING TO LOOK.
LET'S GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN T.
OPERATOR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
. IN SUPPORT I'M SORRY IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOR FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN THREW ME OFF- THANK YOU IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN IT'S ONE THEN
ZERO FOR SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. ONE MOMENT OUR
FIRST WITNESS. WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. A YEAR. GOOD AFTERNOON ONE OF
PROBABLY MY NAME IS ISRAEL WE
ARE WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE
FOR YOUTH AND COMMUNITY DUSTED
IN STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK THANK YOU AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. AND WE'RE GONNA
LINE AT ONE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SELECT THE TABLE WITH THE
VILLAGE ADVOCATE CALL TO A
MEMBER OF ALL OF US ARE NINE AND
CHECK THEM OUT ACTING WE ARE
OPPOSING THE BILL EIGHT EIGHT
THE FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN. WE
OKAY. THIS IS POOR SUPPORT AGAIN
WE'RE IN. THANK YOU. AND THIS IS
FOR SUPPORT IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB. FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO. AND WE'RE GOING TO LINE
ONE FORTY NINE. THIS IS BREANNA
THE VALLO CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
ONE FORTY THREE. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MUTCHLER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION. AB FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
TO A LINE OF FORTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ONE FORTY ONE. OKAY
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXAVAR LINE
ONE FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. AND ONE FORTY FIVE DO YOU HAVE
A SON MUTE. NEXT TO GO TO LINE
ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GLOBAL WILLIAMS REMEMBERS
RAUNCHY LOOK CLOSELY. FUTURE
ALSO. A. THE PARKING CONFUSION
FOR CORONA MONA OPT FOR. THE I-
YOU HAVE THERE. IF YOU WISH. WE
HAVE NO FURTHER SUPPORT AND AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU NOW TAKE
WITH IN A IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS FRED WILLIAMS
A CAL ACTION IN RESPECT OF
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL WE KNOW
THAT THESE PROVISIONS WILL NOT
BE EFFECTIVE IN REDUCING THE
INCIDENCE OF THEFT MANY YEARS OF
RESEARCH SHOW THAT AN INCREASE
IN SEVERITY OF PUNISHMENT DOES
NOTHING TO DETER FUTURE
OFFENSES. THEREFORE THIS BILL
WILL STRETCH STATE RESOURCES
WITH LITTLE BENEFIT TO PUBLIC
SAFETY. WE ALSO KNOW THAT ANY
INCREASE IN PUNISHMENT FOR THIS
TYPE OF LOW LEVEL CRIME IS GOING
TO FALL DISPROPORTIONATELY ON
BLACK PEOPLE PEOPLE OF COLOR
THOSE WHO LIVE IN OVER PLEASE
COMMUNITIES AND THOSE WHO
THEMSELVES ARE OVER POLICED.
THIS BILL WILL HAVE DAMAGING
IMPACTS LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
AND THOSE FACING OR AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS FROM A SOMETIMES OF
TO SHOPLIFTING OR TO PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE. CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN
MEANINGFUL STEPS TO MOVE TOWARD
LESS PUNITIVE MORE EFFECTIVE AND
MORE HUMANE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
POLICY. WE KNOW WHAT WORKS TO
PREVENT CRIMES. AND IT'S OUR
VIEW THAT THE BEST WY TO
PREVENT THAT IS TO OFFER REAL
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY. AND ROBERT
BUSTS SOCIAL SERVICES TO ALL
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. AND PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
PROGRAMMING IN SUPPORT OF
REINTEGRATION. FOR THOSE WHO ARE
RE ENTERING OUR COMMUNITIES. NOT
CREATE MORE OPPORTUNITY FOR
FELONY CONVICTIONS. AND LONG
DISTANCES AND FOR THE REASON WE
MUST. RESPECTFULLY ASKING ABOUT
THANK. YOU THE OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING I'M
OFTEN ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY
SENIOR ADVISER FOR CALIFORNIA
FOR SAFETY AND JUSTICE RETIRED
CAPTAIN INGLEWOOD PD RETIRED
DEPUTY CHIEF WAS SACKED PT
RETIRED STATE DIRECTOR PAROLE.
THE PROMISE OF PART PROP FORTY
SEVEN WAS ORGANIZED UNDER IS
PRETTY SIMPLE AND BASICALLY IT
SAYS THAT WE WERE ATTEMPTING TO
OF DIVERT PEOPLE FOR WELL THEY
SOME THE LOWEST LEVEL CRIMES IN
IN OUR MASSIVE PENAL CODE. LAW
OUT OF OTHER STATE INSTITUTIONS
SYSTEMINTO LOCAL FACILITIES
WHEN THEY WERE- CONVICTED WE
ALSO OF THE INTENDED AND THIS IS
WORKED THAT A SERVICE FOR A
PREDICTABLE FUNDING STREAM WOULD
BE GENERATED TO PROVIDE THESE
SERVICES. IN COMMUNITIES ALL
ACROSS THE STATE SINCE ITS
INCEPTION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN PROP FORTY SEVEN HAS
DIVERTED ABOUT SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN THE
COMMUNITIES OF OTHERWISE WOULD
NOT HAVE BEEN THERE. FOR
SERVICES FOR INTERVENTION-
EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES AND
IMPORTANTLY SEVENTEEN TRAUMA
CARE CENTERS FOR VICTIMS OF
CRIME THAT OTHERWISE WOULDN'T
HAPPEN IT'S BEEN PREDOMINATELY-
A RESOUNDING SUCCESS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT GETS OVERLOOKED I
THINK AND WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
PROP FRTY SEVEN IS BENEFITS
AND- AND- IS IT ALLEGED
WEAKNESSES. THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO GET THEIR FELONY
CONVICTION REDUCED BY THE COURT
OF THE JUDICIAL PROCESS TO A
MISDEMEANOR THAT'S HUGE IF
YOU'VE EVER TALKED TO ANYBODY
THAT HAS LIVED A LIFETIME AS A
CONVICTED FELON. AND HAD THAT
BURDEN TAKEN OFF THEM IT IS LIFE
CHANGING LIFE CHANGING FOR ALL
OF US TO BECAUSE IT IMPROVES OUR
OPPORTUNITY FOR HOUSING.
EDUCATION AND OTHER SYSTEMS. WE
ALSO AFTER. THAT WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT A BILL THAT SAYS. WE'VE
ARRESTED SOMEBODY AND CONVICTED
THEM AND SYMPTOMS IN THREE
TIMES. AND WOULD HAVE TO ASSUME
BEEN ON PROBATION THREE TIMES
AND THAT DIDN'T. ALTER THEIR
BEHAVIOR SOMETHING WRONG THERE
IS SOMETHING WRONG THERE AND
WHAT ABOUT GOING INTO THE STATE
PRISON SYSTEM. WOULD ANYBODY
THINK IS GENERALLY SPEAKING A
GOOD OUTCOME. I DON'T THINK ANY
OF US BELIEVE THAT PUT ASIDE THE
FACT THAT ALSO PUTS US ON A
DIRECT COLLISION COURSE. WITH
THE FEDERAL MANDATE ABOUT
POPULATIONS INSIDE OUR GATES
AND- IT ALSO COMPROMISES THE
CAPACITY TO RETURN MONEY TO THE
LOCAL COMMUNITIES. ONE OF THE
THINGS I SAID IN THE OF A
COMMITTEE MEETING THE LAST WEEK
OR WEEKS IS STILL IN MY MIND
REALLY RELEVANT. WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT THIS I THINK MISPLACED.
REVERENCE FOR THE UTILITY OF
ARREST AND CONVICTION AND
INCARCERATION AS THE CENTER
STONE PIECE OF PUBLIC POLICY TO.
ACHIEVE AND MAINTAIN PUBLIC
SAFETY I HOPE THEY WERE ALL
UNDERSTANDING THAT IN WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THE CRIMES AND FORTY
SEVEN. AROUND EIGHT POINT 5% OF
THE REPORTED CRIMES 50% OR NOT
REPORTED OF THE REPORTED CRIMES
ARE EVER SOLVED. BY THE
IDENTIFICATION OF THE REST OF
THE SUSPECT. SAN FRANCISCO PD
JUST PUT OUT THEIR STATS FOR
LAST YEAR THREE POINT 67% HOW
CAN IT POSSIBLY BE LOGICAL AND
MEANINGFUL. BETTER FILL YOUR
RATE OF NINETY FIVE PERCENT.
SITS AT THE WHEEL AT THE CENTER
OF WHAT MAKES US SAFE. IT
DOESN'T WHAT MAKES A SAVE I
BELIEVE. AND LET ME SAY THE
QUICK AND THE PRO EXPERIENCE WE
HAD A LOT TO DO WITH THE WAY I
FEEL ABOUT THIS AT THIS POINT MY
LIFE. IT MAKES A SAVE. IS
ADDRESSING THE CAUSATIVE FACTORS
OF CRIME. WE ALL KNOW WHAT THOSE
ARE. PROP FORTY SEVEN WAS THE
FIRST STEP IN TRYING TO ADDRESS
THAT. IN IN A- DIRECTED AWAY.
WHAT IF WE DID THAT TO SCALE.
AND SO FOR ALL THESE REASONS AND
OTHERS. WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A NO VOTE ON THIS LEGISLATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. I THINK WE
DON'T HAVE TIME FOR NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. SERIK ME ON BEHALF
OF INITIATE JUSTICE AND UP IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OUR OPPOSITION.
PLEASE FEEL IS ONLY HALF OF DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE IN OPPOSITION.
CANACCORD OUR MOM HALF OF THE
SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC DEFENDER IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU. MARCO
GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. A LITTLE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS FOR SAFETY AND
JUSTICE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. DANIEL GOOD TEARS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEYS FOR CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU. NO MORE
IN THE ROOM BUT I WOULD OF
TELEPHONE LINES IN OPPOSITION.
AT&T OPERATING. IF YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AGAIN IT'S ONE THEN ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION OF AB. FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. WE'LL GO TO LINE
ONE OH SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
WHAT ARE NEXT YEAR GO AHEAD
MAYES. YES MY NAME'S MICHAEL
JURADO- REPRESENTING STARTING
OVER HANK IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY
AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE. AB
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU
NEXT OVER LINE ONE FORTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI THIS IS
AVALON EDWARDS ON BEHALF OF
STARTING OVER INC- AND WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THE BILL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE SB THIRTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEN MEMBERS MY NAME IS ANNA
HONEYCUTT AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN I'M SORRY- YES ON
BEHALF OF THE THOSE ARTISTIC
PRESENTATION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MEXICO LINE ONE OH SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THE MORNING
CHEN MEMBER VOTING RECORD OF I
AND I LIVE IN SOUTH LA- I'M
CALLING TO STOP THE VISION OF AB. FIFTEEN NINETY. THANK YOU NEXT
ALIGNED FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FORTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
AROUND THE CORNER FROM LOS
ANGELES I'M CALLING STRONGLY
OPPOSE- A. B. FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO
LINE ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TWENTY ONE FIFTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SIX OF- TO
LINE EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN.OKAY EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
COAL. AND REPEAT PUBLIC SAFETY
ASSEMBLY LOCALITY IN STRONG
OPPOSITIONA. B. ONE FIVE NINE
SEVEN. THANK YOU. NEXT TO A VOTE
TO ONE MOMENT PLEASE. ONE FIFTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
MORNING TURN MEMBERS MY NAME
JESSICA GUNBATTLE I'M HOPING
REDEMPTION PAYING LIFE COACH AND
EVERYTHING EVERYTHING COALITION
I'M CALLING IN- STRONG
OPPOSITION. AB FIFTY NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXAVAR LINE ONE SIXTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS CLINTON
DRUMMER I'M A MEMBER OF THE AND
PROBABLY SHOULDN'T COALITION
HOPING RETENTION TEAM CANNOT-STRONGLY OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. BUT YOU'RE A
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE AS
FUNDING AS WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO EIGHTY
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT SOBRE LINE ONE
FORTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON WHEN THE FEATHER
THIEF BELA BELA THE CALIFORNIA
ALLIANCE YOUTH AND REJECTED
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE OF. ONE THIRTY
EIGHT. MY NAME IS IVANA ROBINSON
AND I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CONGREGATIONS ORGANIZED THANK
YOU GAVE ME COLD AND WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO A BE
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE. ONE FORTY
ONE. YES HI GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS MAKAYLA FROM CO AND I'M
CALLINGIN STRONG OPPOSITION AB
ONE FIVE NINE SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE
FORTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI
MY NAME IS KIMBERLY DONE WITH
THE NEW WAY ALIVE AND WE ARE IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
AFFECTING JEFFCO CALLING ON
BEHALF OF ALL OF US TO NINE
ORANGE COUNTY AND WE ARE IN THE
STRONG OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE OF FIFTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ANDMEMBERS MY
NAME IS DIANE FIGUEROA I AM
CALLING IN BEHALF OF ALL OF US
AND THEN LET FANS. AND I AM IN
STRONG OPPOSITION OF AB. FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT TO
GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY NINE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. STEVE MCCARTY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE AMENDED ON AB FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN FOR REASONS STATED
IN OUR LETTER THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE A ONE
THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MY
NAME IS JENNIFER. AND I'M
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
CHIU AP FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN ON
BEHALF OF THE- ENTIRE YEAR CAN'T
COALITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME I CHRIS THE WASHINGTON
AND I RESIDE IN CALIFORNIA AND
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIANS TO TAKE INJUSTICE.
AND I'M IN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
EIGHTY FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NXR GO TO
LINE ONE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. MY NAME IS JOE PATTERSON
AND ON BEHALF OF CONGREGATIONS
ORGANIZED A PROPHETIC ENGAGEMENT
INTIMATE IN A COUNTY I STRONGLY
OPPOSE AB. ONE FIVE NINE SEVEN.
THANK YOU AN EXTROVERT SO I TO
ONE TWENTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI TO THE DRIVEWAY AND
DIRECTOR OF ORGANIZING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA NATIVE FO PROJECT
REPRESENTING THOUSANDS THE
NATURE THAT WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU
NEXT WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE- FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE OH
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YOU HAVE
A SUMMIT. OKAY NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE FORTY FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. REMEMBER BY THE HAVE BEEN
IDEA MANY ARE CONFIDENT I'M
CALLING THE POSITION. EIGHTY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK NEXT TO
GO TO LINE ONE OR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS KATHERINE
ALSO I'M CALLING CHILD. AB ONE
FIVE NINE FIVE ON BEHALF OF
SHOWS FAMILY THANK. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE SO. YOUR LIE
IS OPEN. IN ONE SEVENTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO THERE WAS A
MUTE. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE
TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ONE YES ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME'S
MCCARTY SHINE IN HAYWARD AND
WITH TIME DONE IN ALL OF ON
OAKLAND WE ARE IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO PROP FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. AB THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE ONE FIFTY FOR
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. LINE ONE
FIFTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. SO
GO TO LINE ONE FIFTY EIGHT YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NATURALLY WITH
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
ETHNIC COMMITTEE OR CONNIVING
NETWORK IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE A ONE FORTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MYRA
RODRIGUEZ FROM LONG BEACH AND
I'M CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
AB FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NINE ONE TWENTY FOUR. NEXT TO
GO TO LINE AT ONE FORTY YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AGAIN AT THE LAKE ROAD TAYLOR
WITH THE VILLAGE ADVOCATES AND
THE WE ARE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE SIXTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME
IS TERRENCE STUART AND I WITH
THE TARGET OF A NUMBER NINE IN
I'VE BEEN STRONG OPPOSITION TO
UPHOLD THE DISAPPEAR. THANK
THANK YOU NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE
FIFTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I AM
I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
RIVERSIDE ALL OF A SUDDEN ON MY
NAME'S VIDEO TO GLORIA AND I'M
CALLING TO STRONG OPPOSITION TO
AB FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN. THANK
YOU THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MY NAME IS CHLOE TO ME RIGHT
AND I'M CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY NINETY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. EXTRA GO TO LINE ONE
AT SEVENTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. I THINK THEY COUNTY HALF OF
CALIFORNIA COLEMAN I'M CALLING
IN STRONG OPPOSITION AB. FIFTEEN
NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT
ABOUT TO LINE ONE THE FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MY NAME IS ROBERT
DECAMP BY LIFE COACH WITH THE
HEART AND WE NEED YOU CAME AT
THE END PIRATED. COALITION AND I
AM IN STRONG OPPOSITION. TO
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU
MEXICO TO LINE A ONCE FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. ONE ONE SEVENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU WE WILL GO TO NEXT OF ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SET UP IN A LONG AND I'M WITH
THE ANTI RECIDIVISM COALITION
VOEPEL RETENTION TEAM AND I'M
CALLING BECAUSE BOND YIELDS
POLLS A. B. ONE FIVE NINE SEVEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT OVER
TO LINE ONE EIGHTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HI JIM LINDBERG ON
BEHALF OF A FRIEND COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION TO IT WOULD BE
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN THANK YOU
TODAY. YOU.NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE ONE EIGHTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO GO AHEAD PLEASE
I'M SORRY HELLO- HELLO ALL I AM
CRISTINA TUNICA'S ROBINSON AND I
AM ONE THOUSAND BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY DOLLARS AND GOT DONE
WE ARE IN COMPLETE OPPOSITION OF
EIGHTEEN SB FIFTY NINE SEVEN.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MEXICO
COLLIDE ONE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
DAVID ROSE I WORK FOR THE AT THE
RECIDIVISM COALITION FOR THE
OPEN REDEMPTION KING I AM A LIFE
COACH. ONLY TO STRONG OPPOSE AB
NINETY THANK. THANK YOU TEXACO
TO LINE ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HI MY NAME IS
CANDACE LEWIS I'M A LIFE COACH
FOR THE HOPE RETENTION TEAM I AM
CALLING IN STRONG OPPOSITION
EIGHTY FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN ON
BEHALF OF THE ANTI RECIDIVISM
COALITION. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT TO GO TO LINE ONE EIGHTY.
HELLO MY NAME IS ANTHONY ROMERO
I AM A LIFE COACH FOR THE HOPE
AND RETENTION TEAM FOR ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION I STRONGLY
OPPOSE A. B. FIFTEEN NINETY
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
OVER THE LINE ONE EIGHTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HELLO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS STEPHEN
ABOUT THAT IF I'M ALIVE COACH
HERE AT THE HOPE INVITATION TEAM
AT ANTI WHICH IS A COLLECTION
AYE OPPOSED A. B. ONE FIVE NINE
SEVEN. THANK YOU NEXT WE'LL GO
TO LINE OF ONE MINUTE TWENTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS MONNING
STEVEN CRISPY OPEN ON A LIVE
CALL FROM THE OPEN DENTURE. AT
THE END TO PRISON BECAUSE- I'M
CALLING TO STRONG OPPOSE. AB ONE
FIVE NINE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MEXICO LINE UP ONE NINETY ONE
YOUR IS UP. YES MY NAME IS JOHN
WINAMP CARTER AND COGNITIVISM
COALITION- THE- COLLEGES DON'T
HOLD IT NOW YEAH. ON THE HEART
PART. THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF ONE NINETY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
NUMBER MY NAME IS RAJ BROWN AND
I AM CALLING IN STRONG
OPPOSITION AB ONE FIVE NINE
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF THE ANTI.
COALITION THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE NO MORE
OPPOSITION IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
. THANK YOU. UP WE'RE NOW BRING
IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS CONCERNS. HE DOESN'T.
DO YOU WANT TO MAKE COMMENT
MISTER LUCKY YES I DO YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR YOUR COMMENT RIGHT
NOW I'M LOOKING FOR THE SUPPORT
OF MY COMMENT YET- THE QUESTION
TO A MISS WALDRON. ARE YOU AWARE
THAT THE LOS ANGELES TIMES
COSPONSORED A POLL WITH UC
BERKELEY WHICH REVEALED THAT 59%
AGREED WITH THE PROPOSAL IN YOUR
BILL AND I'LL- READ THE QUOTE
FROM THAT THE PAPER. THE BALLOT
MEASURE RAISE THE THRESHOLD. FOR
THE VALUE OF GOODS STOLEN TO
TRIGGER FELONY FROM FOUR
HUNDRED. TO NINE FIFTY AND
RECLASSIFIED SOME OFFENSES AS
MISDEMEANORS 59% OF THE SURVEY.
SAID THAT THEY WOULD SUPPORT.
AMENDING PROP FORTY SEVEN TO LET
CERTAIN PROPERTY CRIMES BE
PROSECUTED AS FELONIES WHILE
ONLY 30% FAVORED LEAVING THE LAN
CHANGED. I THINK THE PEOPLE ARE
. FED UPWHAT'S THE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN OUR RETAIL CENTERS
AND TO THINK THAT PROP FORTY
SEVEN CHANGING THE CONSEQUENCES
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT IS-
KIDDING OURSELVES SO I- DID YOU
FOR BRING THIS FORWARD AT THIS
TIME. TO GIVE MISTER SMITH WHO
PRETTY MUCH ON THE SAME KIND OF
LINES HERE I DON'T REALLY
UNDERSTAND ALL THE OPPOSITION
EXCEPT FOR WE WENT FROM A FELONY
TO A MISDEMEANOR PROP FORTY
SEVEN AND NOW WE'RE TRYING TO
PUSH BACK WITH ALL THE CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY THAT'S GOING ON.
THERE'S NO CONSEQUENCES. THEY DO
IT EVERY DAY. AND UNTIL THE
BUSINESSES THE RETAIL CENTERS
ARE STARSTRUCK CLOSE IN OUR
SEVEN ELEVENS RITE AID'S IN
WALGREENS IN SAN FRANCISCO
CLOSED ALL THEIR STORES. SO
PEOPLE OF LOW INCOME PEOPLE OF
COLOR HAVE NO WHERE TO GET THEIR
LOCAL GOODS. WE HAVE TO START
DOING SOMETHING IF THERE'S
SOMETHING BETWEEN A MISDEMEANOR
AND A FELONY BUT THERE'S NO
CONSEQUENCES FOR THEIR ACTIONS
AND I WILL MOVE THE BILL BUT I
DON'T THINK IT'S GOING VERY FAR
TODAY. SO YEAH YEAH. OKAY ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. YES MISS WEBER.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR- FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION TODAY AND FOR
TRYING TO TACKLE THIS ISSUE- ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT YOU SAID THAT
REALLY KIND OF. YOU KNOW MADE ME
PERK UP AND LISTEN IS THAT-
THESE PEOPLE NEED. TO GET HELP-
THAT THEY NEED TO GET THE HELP
THAT IS NEEDED. AND I AGREE WITH
THAT- I THINK UNFORTUNATELY- WE
DIFFER ON HOW TO GET THAT HELD-
I'M A DATA DRIVEN PERSON. AS A
SCIENTIST AND WHAT STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN IS THAT LOCKING PEOPLE UP
OVER AND OVER AGAIN- EXTENDING
THEIR SENTENCES DOES NOT REDUCE
THEIR CHANCES OF DOING IT AND
SO- I AGREE THAT WE NEED TO GET
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING- I DON'T THINK
THAT. THIS BILL AS IS. I WOULD
PRODUCE THOSE RESULTS BUT I AM
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THE CONVERSATION WITH ANYONE ON
HOW WE CAN IMPROVE- OUR SYSTEM I
DO BELIEVE SOME OF THAT THE
PROGRAMS THAT HAVE BEEN PUT IN
PLACE BY THE FUNDING FROM
PROPERTY SEVEN. ARE DOING THAT-
BUT I DON'T THINK THAT THIS BILL
IS GOING TO GET US TO THAT
POINT. I THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. WITH THAT YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WOULD URGE RESPECTFULLY FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU AND- AND I
KNOW YOUR HEARTS IN A MINUTE IN
THE RIGHT PLACE BECAUSE WE
WORKED TOGETHER ON SEVERAL
BILLS- FORTUNATELY THIS ONE.
DOESN'T GET THERE AND THAT SAME
LA TIMES. ALSO WROTE THAT THIS
WASN'T THE WAY ON THE THREE.
PROP FORTY SEVEN BILLS THAT ARE
GOING THROUGH. A FACT THEY WROTE
IT NOT SO FLATTERING. EDITORIAL
ABOUT IT BUT- I THINK. YOUR MAY
BE WONDER WHAT WE COULD WORK
WITH TO ACTUALLY GET TO A BETTER
PLACE AS- DR WEBER SAYS WE
NEEDED WE NEED TO COME OUT OF
SOLUTION- UNFORTUNATELY. DURING
THE BABY OUT WOULD HELP THE
BATHWATER HIS IT'S NOT TO HUESO
. UNFORTUNATELY I RESPECTFULLY
WILL HAVE TO RECOMMEND A NO VOTE
. ON EIGHTY FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN
BY SEPTEMBER WALDRON THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE JONES SAWYER JONES
SAWYER NO LACKEY AT A GUY LACKEY
I BONTA. FONTANELLE BRIAN. BRIAN
NO WEBER. WEBER NOTES SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO KNOWS. SMITH I. SORRY
THE MEASURE DOESN'T PASS THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE I
ASK FOR RECONSIDERATION AND
WOULD LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS ISSUE AND ALSO LOOK AT THE
CAUSES OF WHAT'S GOING ON THANK
YOU THANK YOU AND IF THERE'S NO
OBJECTION WE WILL GRANT THIS
BILL RECONSIDERATION BY
UNANIMOUS CONSENT. IN OUR LAST.
ONE FOR TODAY MR WARD. WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY TO BE GET. YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A LONG HEARING YOU HAD
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES I WANT TO
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE-
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
ACCEPT THEPROPOSED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO IS THE FIRST STEP TOWARDS
DIVERSIFYING THE COUNTY GRAND
JURY. GRAND JURIES IN CALIFORNIA
TO ENSURE THAT THEY ARE TRULY
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE
CONSTITUENCIES THEY SERVE GRAND
JURIES YOU KNOW HAVE THE POWER
TO ACT AS A WATCHDOG FOR SOME OF
OUR MOST CONSEQUENTIAL LOCAL
AGENCIES AND OFFICIALS HOWEVER
WHEN THE MAKE UP OF THOSE GRAND
JURIES DO NOT REFLECT THE
CONSTITUENCIES PROPER
REPRESENTATION OF THESE
COMMUNITIES IS VALUE AND
PRIORITIES IS ALMOST IMPOSSIBLE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE TIME-COMMITMENT AND LOW COMPENSATION
RATE FOR GRAND JURY SERVICE
EFFECTIVELY BAR MOST
CALIFORNIANS FROM SERVING
ESPECIALLY THOSE FROM
DISADVANTAGED IN LOWER INCOME
COMMUNITIES UNDER CURRENT LAW
PER DIEM COMPENSATION IS CAPPED
AT FIFTEEN DOLLARS PER DAY NOT
PER HOUR SERVICE UNLESS A HIGHER
FEE IS PROVIDED BY SATUTE OR
COUNTY OR CITY ORDINANCE THIS
RATES NOT BEEN CHANGED SINCE TWO
THOUSAND ONE MAKING THE SERVICES
SENSUALLY VOLUNTARY. SO TO
MEANINGFULLY ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES AND WHY IN THE POOL OF
POTENTIAL GRAND JURORS AB
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO MAKES THREE
CHANGES TO THE GRAND JURY
SELECTION PROCESS FIRST IT WOULD
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL DEMOGRAPHIC
DATA TO BE COLLECTED DURING THE
COUNTY GRAND JURY SELECTION
PROCESS FOR THE PURPOSES OF
YEARLY REPORTS RELEASED BY THE
CALIFORNIA JUDICIAL COUNCIL.
SECOND IT WOULD RAISE THE PER
DIEM RATE FOR GRAND JURORS TO
MAKE THE SERVICE A MORE VIABLE
OPTION FOR LOWER INCOME
INDIVIDUALS AND THIRD IT WOULD
PROVIDE EDUCATION TO POTENTIAL
JURORS BY INCLUDING INFORMATION
ON HOW TO BECOME A GRAND JUROR
IN THE EXISTING TRIAL JURY
SUMMONSES THAT WE ALL GET IN THE
MAIL. AB NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
RECOGNIZES THE INFLUENCE OF
GRAND JURIES ON THE PUBLIC'S
TRUST AND CONFIDENCE IN OUR
INSTITUTIONS AND MAKES NECESSARY
CHANGES AIM TO INCREASE THE
REPRESENTATION OF LOW INCOME
HISTORICALLY DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST COMMUNITIES FOR THESE
REASONS I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTES AND ON
THE PHONE LINES TODAY WE HAVE
CYNTHIA CASTILLO FROM THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LONG HI. AND
HUGHES FROM THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC DEFENDERS ASSOCIATION TO
PROVIDE WITNESS TESTIMONY THANK
YOU. EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR. OPEN
UP THE LINE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHEERING MEMBERS MY NAME IS TO
PICK UP BEYOND THE POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH WESTERN CENTER ON
MOM PROPERTY WESTERN CENTER THE
STATE'S LARGEST AND OLDEST
SUPPORT CENTER WITH THE GOAL OF
ENDING POVERTY THROUGH THE LINE
ECONOMIC AND RACIAL JUSTICE.
WE'RE PROUD TO SPONSOR EIGHTY
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO WHICH WILL
ENSURE THAT I BIRTH OCCASION OF
GRAND JURIES IN CALIFORNIA BUT
THAT THERE WERE REPRESENTATIVE
OF THE STATE'S POPULATION A KEY
COMPONENT OF THAT IS ALSO
ENSURING THAT JURORS ARE FAIRLY
COMPENSATED WITH THE END GOAL OF
MAKING GRAND JURY DUTY
ACCEPTABLE. FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
LOW INCOME. WHEN A GRAND JURY
THAT. BY EVERYDAY HEALTH. WHO
THEIR TIME TO. AND ENSURE THAT
THEIR LOW GOVERNMENT INTEREST.
AND SHARED COMMUNITY. GRAND JURY
PERFORMED PRIMARY ROLE WANTED
TO. THE BILL OF CHARGES BEING
PROCESS BY APART. AND YET DURING
. IN AND- THE OPERATIONS COUNTY
AGENCIES AN OFFICIAL. IN THE
LATTER FUND. GRANT BACK OF THE
CAR. WATCH TO ESSENTIAL.
DEPARTMENTS BUT THIS YEAR
DEPARTMENT AND- FACILITY. TO
INSTITUTIONS THAT HISTORICALLY
INVOLVED THE DETENTION AND
PROSECUTION OF LOW INCOME PEOPLE
OF COLOR. ADDITIONALLY THEY'LL
RECEIVE ISSUING A CRIMINAL
INDICTMENT AND INVESTIGATE
ALLEGATIONS OF PUBLIC
CORRUPTION. UNFORTUNATELY
CALIFORNIA DEEP RACIAL
DISPARITIES IN ACCESS TO JUSTICE
AND INCOME AND WEALTH. HAVE
RESULTED IN A GOLDEN OPPORTUNITY
FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR
JESTERDIGITAL DUTY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORK RIGHTLY HIGHLIGHTED
THE FIFTY DOLLAR PER DIEM RATE
IS PROHIBITED MANY CALIFORNIANS
UNABLE TO INCREASE A LOT WAGES.
FOR THIRD. CURRENT DATA THAT
GRAND JURIES ARE. MADE UP OF
WHITE INDIVIDUAL WHO CAN TO TAKE
THE TIME OFF. IN DEMOCRATIC
COUNT BIRTHDAY 70% OF. FOR
TWENTY TWENTY GRAND JURY. AS
WHITE WITH ONLY ONE PERSON I
DON'T AT THE- BY THE COUNTY THE
WHITE HISPANIC OR LATINO. BEING
30% MEANING YOU ADDRESS YOU
DISCUSS. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY TWO
REQUIRE YOUR SIX ARRAY THE PARTY
RATE FOR GRAND JURY AND- HIM
GRAPHIC DAY. TO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL CAL. THE CHANGE ARE
NECESSARY FOR A RACIAL. EQUITY
TRUTH. JERRY PLAY CRITICAL IN
THE CAL INVOLVED IN THE LEAGUE
SYSTEM SUPPORT. PEOPLE OF COLOR
THOSE LIVING POVERTY ARE OVER.
AND I AND REPRESENT DURING THE
BILL PUBLISHED IN. IN OUR COURTS
. AB NEED TO MAKE NECESSARY
CHANGES. BODY BLACK. AND WE-
URGE AND I. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COME- ON HOPING YOU CAN HEAR ME
YES MY NAME IS LAST WEEK. THANK
YOU MY NAME IS LESLIE CALDWELL
HUGHES I'M A REPRESENT OF CAL
DEFENDER OF SOLANO COUNTY. I
CURRENTLY SERVE ON THE SOLANO
COUNTY CIVIL GRAND JURY THIS IS
MY SECOND AND LAST YEAR ON THE
CIVIL GRAND JURY AND I'M HAPPY
TO OFFER THIS TESTIMONY IN
SUPPORT OF NINETEEN EIGHTY
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. THERE ARE
USUALLY IN THE COUNTY TWO
SEPARATE ENTITIES THE CRIMINAL
GRAND JURY AND THE CIVIL GRAND
JURY- OFTEN THEY GET CONFLATED.
THEY HAVE VERY DIFFERENT JOBS A
REPRESENTATION OF THE DIVERSITY
OF ANY COUNTY AND OR JURY IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO THE SUCCESS IN
OUR SYSTEM. OF COURT AND THE
GOVERNMENT. SUCH A REFLECTION
LEADS MORE FAITH IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND THE WORK BEING
DONE FOR THEM IN THEIR NAME THIS
BILL DOES TWO IMPORTANT THINGS
THAT ENSURES THAT A REASONABLE
FEE IS PAID FOR THE WORK OF THE
GRAND JURORS. AND IT WORKS TO
REQUIRE THE GRAND JURY
MEMBERSHIP REFLECTS THE DEMO
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THE CANYON WHICH
IT SERVES. BECAUSE GRAND JURY
WORKS PAYS SUCH A SMALL THE PER
DIEM AND LET ME. SAY THAT FOR MY
EIGHTY HOURS OF WORK LAST MONTH
ON THE U. CIVIL GRAND JURY I
RECEIVED ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
DOLLARS FOR MILEAGE AND MY
EIGHTY HOURS OF WORK- I'M LUCKY
I HAVE A PENSION. THIS THAT
LIMITS THE GRAND JURY TO A
DEMOGRAPHIC OF PERSONS THAT CAN
AFFORD TO SERVE PARTICULARLY ON
A GRAND JURY BUT ALSO ON A
CRIMINAL GRAND JURY HOWEVER ON A
CRIMINAL GRAND JURY THE PEOPLE
AT LEAST HAVE SOME OPPORTUNITY
IN MOST COUNTIES TO LET THE
COURT KNOW WHAT CERTAIN THAT THE
SERVICE CAN CAUSE GREAT FOR
FINANCIAL HARM. WELL CRIMINAL
GRAND JURIES ARE OFTEN SUMMONED
BY THE COURTS TO SEVERAL GRAND
JURIES ARE MADE UP OF VOLUNTEERS
IN MY COUNTY WHICH IS VERY
DIVERSE AND IN FACT HAS ONE OF
THE MOST DIVERSE CITIES IN THE
COUNTRY VALLEJO ONE QUARTER
ASIAN ONE QUARTER AFRICAN
AMERICAN ONE QUARTER LAST YEAR
NEXT. AND ONE QUARTER CUT
CAUCASIAN OUR GRAND JURY OF
NINETEEN PEOPLE AS ONLY FOR
PEOPLE OF COLOR. YOU REQUIRE
EFFORTS TO BALANCE THE
DEMOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY IS A VERY
POSITIVE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION REGARDING OUR GRAND
JURY. IT WOULD BE A SHAME TO
FAILED TO PASS THIS BILL BECAUSE
OF CUTS- NURSING COMMUNITY
SUPPORT IN OUR SYSTEM IS
PRICELESS THANK YOU THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
. SUPPORT THEY WERE USING OUR
COACH GEORGE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC DEFENDERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. DANIEL GUTERRES ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEYS FOR
CRIMINAL JUSTICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. AT TO GO TO THE-
PHONE LINES. WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
AGAIN THAT'S ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU AREN'T SUPPORT OF AB.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. WE WILL GO
ONLINE ONE TWENTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. MCCARTY SHOCKED WHEN HE
WORKED WITH CHANGE ON THE INSIDE
IN ALL WESTERN ON OAKLAND WE ARE
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WE HAVE
NO FURTHER SUPPORT APPEAL THANK
YOU BRING A- OPPOSITION
OPPOSITION ANY WITNESSES IN OF
IN A ROOM IN OPPOSITION. UPSIDE
IN OPPOSITION. ANY WITNESSES
ONLINE IN OPPOSITION TO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK AT AT&T LINE.
OPPOSITION OF A. B. NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AGAIN THAT'S ONE AND
THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION OF A. B.
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. AND THAT'S
ONE AND THEN ZERO IN OPPOSITION
. AND ONE MOMENT WE DO HAVE ONE
PARTY HERE. OKAY. GENNETT'S
REMINDER OF ONE AND THEN THEY'LL
FOR OPPOSITION. AND WE WILL GO
TO LIKE TWO HUNDRED YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU
CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF RIGHT MORE IMMUNITY HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES.
THE URBAN COUNTY THE CALIFORNIA
IN THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA.
WE GENERALLY I GENUINELY
APPRECIATE DOCTORS EFFORTS TO
INCREASE DIVERSITY ON GRAND JURY
BUT RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO PROVIDE FUNDING FOR
THE PREVAILING WAGE FEES THAT
COUNTIES WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
UNDER THE SPELL. I THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR WOULD
HAVE NO FURTHER OPPOSITION IN Q.
THE TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS. YES
PERSPECTIVE. YEAH I AM I HAD A
CONCERN OVER THE FACT THAT. WE
ALL KNOW THAT THE GRAND JURY.
THE REVIEWS VOLATILE CASES AND-
VERY VERY PIVOTAL CASES. AND
PART OF WHAT YOUR BILL. A
REPRESENTS AND SECTION EIGHT
SUBSECTION BE IT TALKS ABOUT.
EACH SUPERIOR COURT SHALL ON OR
BEFORE MARCH FIFTEENTH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR AND- UNDER BEFORE
MARCH FIFTEENTH OF EACH YEAR
THERE AFTER PROVIDE THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL WITH A LIST OF PERSONS
SELECTED BY THE COURT CONTAINING
THE FOLLOWING. CONTAINING THE
NAME F THE JUDGE WHO SELECTED
EACH PERSON ON THE LIST. AND THE
PERSON'S NAME GENDER AGE RACE OR
ETHNICITY. AND RESIDENTIAL WARD
JUDICIAL DISTRICT ARE
SUPERVISORS ORIEL DISTRICT OF
THE RESPECTIVE COUNTIES THAT
GOES ON AND ON. BASICALLY
DISCLOSING WHO IS ON THAT THAT
GROUP AND SPECIFICITY AND I HAVE
. RESERVATIONS OVER THE FACT
THAT- IT'S BEEN PROVEN THAT- WE
HAVE SOME PEOPLE THAT ARE
DANGEROUS. AND WHO TAKE INTO
THEIR HANDS A RETALIATORY- FRAME
OF REFERENCE AND OTHER ACTIONS
ARE VERY DANGEROUS AND SO I FIND
THIS TO BE A LITTLE BIT-
DANGEROUS QUITE FRANKLY AND- I
OBJECT TO THAT LEVEL OF-
SPECIFICITY. BONTA RIGHT-
RESTORED THIS SMART THOUGHTFUL-
MOST OF THE BILL. A SECOND. ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
APPRECIATE- THOSE OBSERVATIONS
PRIVACY IS A BIG CONCERN OF MINE
AS WELL AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
THE EXISTING STATUTE ACTUALLY
HAS SOME PROCESS FOR THE
DISCLOSURE OF THE NOMINEES-
INDIVIDUAL NAMES- THE JUDGES WHO
NOMINATE THEM- BUT CURRENTLY
ONLY ASK FOR THE SUPERVISORIAL
DISTRICT OR THE OLD RESIDENTIAL
MORE DISTRICTS AS WE DON'T NEED
THEM IN HISTORY- SO BY ADDING
ADDITIONAL DEMOGRAPHIC
INFORMATION TO THAT IS GETTING
AT THE HEART OF THE- THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL THAT THE
MODIFICATIONS OF THIS BILL-
FURTHERMORE THE- SMART COMMITTEE
AND THEN IT'S THAT WE- HAVE
ACCEPTED- ARE GOING TO BE ABLE
TO HELP TO ANONYMIZE SOME OF
THAT. INFORMATION BY ONLY-
PUBLISHING THE AGGREGATE DATA ON
THE INTERNET- WHILE PRESERVING
THE EXISTING EXISTING STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS FOR A LIST- AND IN
GENERAL PUBLICATIONS AS WELL AND
NEWSPAPER PUBLICATIONS WILL
CONTINUE WORK ON PRIVACY
CONCERNS BUT- I HEAR THAT LOUD
AND CLEAR THANK YOU RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST DRIVE THEM. THANK YOU.
YES ON AB NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
BY SEVEN MEMBER WARD THE MOTION
IS DUE PATH AS AMENDED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE JONES
SAWYER JONES SAWYER I LACKEY
LACKEY NO BONTA BONTA HI BRIAN
BRIAN HI WEBER WEBER I SAN DIEGO
. SAN DIEGO BY SMITH. SMITH NOW
THAT MEASURE PASSES THAT MEASURE
PASSAGE OF. NEXT WE WILL DO ANY
ADD ONS OR BOTH CHANGES. AND
LIFT ALL CALLS MANUFACTURED
PLEASE GO THROUGH ALL THE
MEASURES TAKEN UP TODAY. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WEBER WEBER I
THOUGHT THE ECHO SANTIAGO I. I
DON'T NUMBER ONE HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH. ITEM NUMBER TWO
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY BY THE MEMBER
DAVIES SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I DON'T
NUMBER THREE WAS PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR ITEM NUMBER FOUR HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH IDENTIFIED WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. ITEM
NUMBER SIX THAT MEASURE WAS ON
CALL AB EIGHTEEN OH THREE BY
JONES SAWYER SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO
I SMITH A CHANGE MY OF SUBSTANCE
INTO A NO VOTE. SMITH GO CHANGE
OF STAND TO KNOW. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB
NINETEEN WHAT NINETY EXCUSE ME
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE WITH A
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WAS
PULLED BY THE AUTHOR. ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB SIXTEEN FORTY ONE
MAIENSCHEIN SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I. I DON'T NUMBER TEN EIGHTEEN
NINETY NINE WITH ON CONSENT. THE
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH. I TO NUMBER
TWELVE AB EIGHTEEN FORTY TWO WAS
ON CONSENT. I AM THIRTEEN AB
EIGHTEEN SIXTY NINE HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH ITEM FOURTEEN
EIGHTY SEVENTEEN TWENTY FIVE WAS
PULLED BY AUTHOR. ITEM FIFTEEN
AB EIGHTEEN FORTY SIX WAS PULLED
BY AUTHOR ITEM. SIXTEEN EIGHT AB
EIGHTEEN FORTY SEVEN WAS PULLED
BY AUTHOR. ITEM SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
FIFTEEN NINETY SEVEN HAS BEEN
DISPENSED WITH. I ITEM NUMBER
EIGHTEEN AB NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO
HAS ALSO BEEN DISPENSED WITH. OF
ITEM NINETEEN WAS ON CONSENT-
BEEN DISCLOSED TO BUSINESS FOR
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE.